this is jocko podcast number 339 with
echo charles and me jocko willing good
evening echo good evening
i awoke
face down in blood soaked
sand the world spun around me
what little sounds i could make were
muffled and indistinct
it was like i had been twirled around on
an old tired swing
then flung into a swimming pool
i couldn't gather my wits any more than
i could get my bearings the harder i
tried to get a handle on the world
around me the more slippery my grip
became
my eyes strained to adjust to the scene
pain sunk its fangs permanently
we have just been hit by rockets i
assume
this must be a coordinated attack
my confusion turned to panic oh god oh
god please god
the sounds that surrounded me became
clearer
i could decipher some individual words
but they seemed only to add uncertainty
who is groaning i heard gurgling as
someone tried to force air through a
blood-filled throat
the wounded and dying were bellowing in
both english and arabic
screams of death filled the air
rage filled our hearts medic medic ala
akbar
i propped myself up as much as i could
the inch or two that i was able to
manage was not enough to make a
significant difference in my field of
view
i thought i heard the reports of rifles
is that ak fire i need to start helping
my guys i thought to myself we're being
ambushed
shock was setting in
i desperately tried to locate my weapon
and return fire but i was totally unable
to move
i wanted to figure out why but i
couldn't get my body positioned in a way
that would allow me to look toward my
legs
i could see both of my arms and my chest
my arms were definitely broken
osmosis was spreading blood throughout
the sleeves of my uniform but i could
still move them sort of
i propped myself up again onto my side
and peered down toward my legs
but when i finally looked downward in
the direction that my legs should have
been all i could make out was thick
black blood and a pile of muddy entrails
i am cutting two i said aloud unsure
whether i was talking to the dying men
around me or to myself
i ran a bit of organ through the
fingertips of my left hand
i was certain that it once belonged to
me
where did it fit in this mess i searched
the jumbled human remains that rested
underneath me and wondered exactly where
this little organ went but i couldn't
complete the puzzle
my mind drifted
distractedly i wondered what was going
what it was going to be like to die
certainly there would be no way to save
a man who had been cut in half
oh god oh god oh god the screams filled
my ears again i'm hit
johnny medic
was that me yelling i wondered
i tried to look for the frantic american
voice but all i could see was dark red
sand limbs which had been flung from
their torsos bloody men writhing on the
ground begging for death to end their
suffering and hundreds of empty sandals
lying there
still rubbing that piece of what i
believe to be a pancreas between the
tips of my fingers i again contemplated
what was going what it was going to be
like to die
was i going to cross over into some
other dimension and meet jesus like i
had been taught my entire life
or was it all
just going to go black
like slipping quietly into a slumber
a sleep that one never comes back from
please don't let this be my final
resting place i thought
not this [__]
not now
and that right there
is an excerpt
from a book
that is called
the glass factory
written by braxton mccoy
and the [__] that he was referring
to
was a [__] that i'm familiar with a
place called ramadi iraq
and the title of the book
the glass factory is a title that anyone
who served in ramadi instantly knows
and i have talked about
the glass factory on this podcast a
couple times i've talked about it on the
unraveling podcast as well
the glass factory was the place of a
horrific attack
where suicide bombers detonated
themselves at a police recruiting event
killing over 50 iraqi police recruits
and also two americans
the americans that were killed
lieutenant colonel
michael mclaughlin of
mercer pennsylvania
and sergeant adam cann from davey
florida
and there were scores of wounded iraqis
and americans as well
many of them severely wounded
one of them was
a young soldier
who is also the author of this book
braxton mccoy
and it is an honor to have braxton here
with us tonight to talk about his
experiences in war and
perhaps more important
his lessons learned after the war
and how he
followed the path
toward the truth
braxton thanks for joining us man thanks
for having me jacob
great to meet you and i know
uh you sent us this book a while ago
years ago and somehow i look i i get
sent
uh hundreds of books actually and i just
it slipped past my radar and it wasn't
until
i was on twitter
and i think
someone tagged you and me
and said
hey jocko was just talking about the
glass factory on the podcast
and you came back and said something
like
he got it mostly right a couple errors
which you know of course
i said minor minor errors though yeah
minor errors uh but you know of course i
i know i'm not going to know everything
i don't ever claim to know everything
but as soon as i saw you had a book
called the glass factory that you were
wounded there you know i
said hey man
you you know you said hey do you want
this book and i said absolutely
and said let's talk about on the podcast
so
here you are man thanks for coming down
yeah thank you it's really kind of crazy
to be here
hearing you read my book it's kind of
weird
uh
man it's a it's a great book and i i
should start off by saying this you
never know what you're gonna get when
you read a book
and
i think
one thing that
one thing that you can measure a book by
is how
vulnerable
someone is willing to be
in order to convey
what happened to them
and this book is raw and you talk about
things in this book that i know had to
be hard as hell to write
and that's
one of the things that make it so
powerful
and the other thing that makes it so
powerful even though look
it's a book
definitely there's there's a chunk of it
that has to do with war
and there's a chunk of it that has to do
with the struggles after the war
but
the most powerful part of the book
is
you
figuring out
how you needed to live
in a proper way
and
it's it's just an epic book it's an
outstanding book
and so anybody that is listening right
now
jump on there we'll we'll have it on our
website and
go go buy this book immediately we're
gonna read some of it today there's no
way i could read the whole book i know
that you're working on an audio book
right now
so eventually you'll be able to buy that
but you know
actually never mind the audiobook for
now the
the cover of the book
is awesome
and
what's the deal with the cover i read a
little bit about the cover of the book
but where did it come from uh the guy
who designed it was a medic there that
was at the glass factory with me and uh
we
i told him i wanted i told him i wanted
it to be
look like the windows you know the the
brass over the windows over there and
the copper stuff but with a i wanted a
buffalo on there so he kind of worked it
in
yeah it's a it's a very
distinct cover and plus it's well this
version is hard cover so are there still
hard covers available there's like
maybe 300 you can get on my website
those are as good as gone
closer as good as god anybody if you can
get the one of those 300 get it order it
what's your website so people can write
mccoy.com braxton mccoy.com so
there we just sold all those 300 books
um and then the other ones are available
on amazon those are soft cover i'm
assuming yeah
and we we actually you know without
getting goofy political rights about we
tried we tried to work on getting
another print run and white paper stock
is short like everywhere so
or at least the publishers we had before
and then we tried to use a different
published publishing company out of
idaho and they couldn't uh check we
might have to talk to other publishing
companies that other people know like
mine
figure out what we can do
uh all right so
the again this is a very interesting
book
and one of the things that's interesting
about the book is it it basically starts
off
with the attack on the glass factory
but and it doesn't you have flash some
flashbacks throughout the book pertinent
flashbacks but
there's no detail
there's not much detail on how you grew
up and probably that's the next book you
should write
uh is
just some of the experience that that
made you who you are but before you
write that book since you're sitting
here let's talk a little bit about you
know how you did grow up and where you
came from and how you ended up being who
you are so
where did you grow up
i grew up in well
i lived before utah salt lake valley
started to get expanded there was a
place called the rose canyon estates up
there's a bunch of just small ranches
and ranchettes up south of salt lake
it's now kind of all the same valley but
back then it was like i don't know 25
miles of town or so then i'd go to
school every morning
and we had just a little horse operation
out there my my mother and father are
divorced so my mother married uh
my stepfather when i was four and so we
were you know pretty much been in my
life and
so what was going on in the horse ranch
like what were you doing
uh when i was a kid yeah
man
feeding and watering and hitting golf
balls and shooting arrows into the
haystacks and
shooting rabbits and lizards and man i'd
get home from school and get my chores
done and go grab a backpack and throw a
water bottle on there and get my baby
gun and just head up the mountain
because there's nobody behind us and
there's this creek's called yellow fork
and you can go up yellow fork all the
way up and just shoot every bird known
amount
i must have smoked 500 woodpeckers this
time i was 13.
and my grandpa had a thing for songbirds
he just loves songbirds and i kind of
get it now as i age i like having them
around my place too so if i got cop
shooting songbirds i'd get in big
trouble but woodpeckers all day all day
did your stepdad have any military
experience no
no his father's uh
his father was a he grew up on a ranch
in scipio utah which is where we ended
up moving when i was 13.
but he
world war ii or right after world war ii
i guess he joined the navy ended up an
air traffic controller eventually ended
up air traffic controller out here at
top gun
and then he got out and
came home to the ranch and sold it he
said i never want to do another day of
farm work in my life
and moved up to the city and uh he was a
air traffic controller for
delta airlines or something i don't know
salt lake international for years and
then he ended up moving back after he
retired and and what about your mom what
did she do
she was uh she worked for cisco as like
a food sales rep for a while and then
she went into real estate now she's real
estate broker
and your
what grandfather the grandfather that
you write about in the book what
primarily what was his background he was
a marine and then a plumber
he was a plumber my whole life just
big-time outdoorsman
he was all like everything praying was
hunting and fishing i mean work working
just so he could get out and hunt fish
with his grandkids mostly dude i got
pictures of me i'm like two years old
and his cowboy hat with a damn deer leg
in my hand like walking around deer camp
like that was his jam so and that was my
mother's dad
and then you said you moved from one
ranch to another ranch when you turned
13. yeah we moved down we sold uh we
sold out up there and then moved down to
scipio utah and my stepdad had about 40
head of horses down there and our yeah
roughly 40 head and then he's an
electrical contractor helped make ends
meet and then the horse market went bust
pretty hard back in 20 2000
let's see what was that 2002 maybe
i can't remember the first time anyway
when they passed the the no kill bill
oh yeah i can reference 202 or 2004
and anyway it hit hard i mean there was
good horses on the market for nothing
people were just taking their horses out
and turning them out in the desert and
stuff like
go on live free i mean those horses just
died yeah no idea what to do
the reason i said oh yeah because i read
an article about that not too long ago
about how people were just letting their
i guess their domesticated horses go
yeah and they're not ready to survive
out there well especially most everybody
has gildings and
no
no wild horse herd is going to let a
gilding in i mean the stud's just going
to kill him it's not a mare and it's you
know it's eunuch and he doesn't need
that around so
i mean if you maybe mayors could make it
but but even then it's doubtful their
hooves are not
there's not built for it anymore you
know it's really bred out how does a
horse kill another horse uh they kick by
like so a lot of times they'll break
their backs like stud horses they'll get
up on their behind ends like this and
flip them
break their necks or backs and
bite and kick and i mean they can kick
the horse kicks another horse and they
had to kill easy for sure i had a horse
kill one of my cows
last fall
kicked it at least that's all we can
figure out too cow was fine next day
there was a horse around there so
uh now you were you were pretty into
sports too right when you were going
when did you start like wrestling and
what other sports did you play i didn't
start wrestling until i was a freshman
in high school um i played baseball
growing up and did some boxing my
family's friends with uh jim fulmer as a
family friend or gene former i'm sorry i
was a family friend growing up and so
did a little getting punched in the head
for a bit
uh and then i got in it was a it was i
think there was like a middle school
that's what it was it was a middle
school pe you know uh where you'd go
through like all the different sports
like badminton and [__] like this but
then there was like a red wrestling
section i was like man i like this so
well compared to badminton yeah
that's right
so then uh my mom signed me up at the
tree house with yvonne even off for a
while
uh that was in draper utah i was like
maybe an hour drive and so i was taking
his classes for a bit with like cam
jones and some of these other studs from
like high school wrestling studs and
cameron wrestle college but uh and then
uh then we moved and i went oh no i
wrestled that first year at robertson
high school and then after that i went
moved down to
uh fillmore and did you still wrestle
when you got to fillmore yeah
yeah what what year was this what year
did you graduate from 2003
how did you do wrestling and did you
make the state or anything yeah yeah i
won districts my senior year and then at
state uh
i ended up i was man it sucked so bad i
got super sick i had to drink
yeah my my wrestling coach i still talk
about this all the time but i was
weighing in with a gallon jug of water
trying to get up to weight because i was
wrestling 89 and i just was burning i
just didn't weigh enough you know you
got to make the 160 weight limit i
wasn't making it mistake well plus uh
two pound allowance i guess so
anyway yeah i struggled that's still
pretty impressive that you only started
wrestling your freshman year and you
made it to state in your senior year
yeah pretty impressive man my man my
junior year i think i was probably a
better wrestler but
i got in trouble um
i was kind of an idiot and what'd you do
to get in trouble um
this is where the good story's going
so
well i uh
i got
me and my stepdad got in a fistfight and
i got kicked out
we me and i had butted heads since i was
little big time and i ended up we got in
a
pretty good scrap and
anyway we had we couldn't live in the
same places anymore so i went to live
with my other grandpa on salt lake and i
went back to riverton that year
riverton high school and uh i just was
an idiot you know i was like just not
going to school
i mean and my dad my whole life my
biological father was like in and out of
jail and stuff in that prison for what
what was he doing man i
you know i don't know i get stories i
don't know what's i know at least one
thing was a white car thing i know there
were some violent things but
i don't know what you know
anyway
i don't know i don't
so he he was out for a minute and so i
was like well i'll just live with him
then and that was a bad idea that lasted
for like man he was out for like a month
or something and then being a stepdad's
like a tough like a really tough job
yeah and he's man he's i don't want him
sitting
he had some issues of his own so i mean
like whiskey bottles in the damn grain
bins and [__] gonna be out trying to
feed horses you're like oh here's some
rich and rare
so check when did you so you were
hunting your whole as growing up your
whole life oh yeah bow hunting too i
started bow hunting in about 14. okay my
cousin cody hasson got me into it
he's actually i think last week i think
it was he wouldn't try it out for the
world team damn for uh uh stikbo dang
yeah he's pretty solid
at what point did you start thinking
about joining the military
uh i you know gi joe and [__] as a kid i
always thought about it you know but i
was
you know what i thought for sure
i was going to go in the military but
then like there was nothing going on you
know
i mean i don't understand why anybody
would join without a war like what's the
hell's the point so then i was just i
you know for so anyway it went through a
stretch where i thought i won't do this
and i was an f off and just riding bulls
and just being dumb and partying and
every other thing that young kids do
chasing girls and such
and then uh 9 11 happened and i was this
is when i was actually at riverton high
school so you're a sophomore maybe just
starting your software no yeah yeah
sophomore year yeah sophomore year no
junior year oh yeah because you said you
graduated in 03 i was a junior yeah
because i was at riverton because my
sophomore year i was at millard
um
yeah and we were sloughing school
and which you know was like the first
period of the day but we were all over
at my cousin's house and one of the kids
that was there was a uh i can't remember
if he's from pakistan or
whatever but anyway
a friend of ours was from the middle
east and he was there with us you know
watching the stuff go down and i feel
like that always kind of helped me
like view things differently
because he was still a buddy you know
but we so we saw the towers come down i
was like man i'm gonna go i wanna go
fight over there you know
so i finished up school and then art
whale actually enlisted as a junior as
first recruiter that talked to me i'm
just enlisted and
i was going as soon as over
and you just the first recruiter you
talked to was an army recruiter yeah
that was that
yeah i didn't know crap man my grandpa
didn't really like the marine corps very
much and the only thing he says i'll
kill you if you join the marine corps
he told me that
at least a dozen times growing up uh and
so i thought well it's not the marine
corps
did your grandfather fight in which war
or no he he's he split vietnam and uh
korea
and then his bro his two little brothers
went over to vietnam and i think he was
bitter about that
i i mean i've never i never asked him
why he ate the marine corps so i really
don't know
i know he had a tattoo of a bulldog over
here
and when he was older he used to say i
say grandpa or when i was little and he
was older he said grandpa what's that
you know he said it's a picture of your
grandma
so you did you know what kind of job you
were having the army did you even know
that the army had jobs or no well i mean
not really no
so he shows me this video okay
this is the recruiter yeah
i almost want to say his name but he uh
he's not a bad guy he just did bad
things but
so he shows me this video and he's like
check that out these dudes are like
jumping out of planes and [__] i'm like
oh yeah that looks bad
he's like that's what you want to do i'm
like hell yeah he's like see that one
guy and it's like the i'm assuming it's
the echo the 18 echo or whatever
and he's like see that guy with that
radio i was like yeah he was like he
gets paid six extra grand to join if he
carries that radio
i mean that's not exactly how he said it
but he's like you get a signing bonus
and all you got to do is carry this
extra 20 pounds of gear or whatever you
know he's like you're tough enough to
carry 20 extra pounds aren't you like oh
hell yeah
you run that racket before it happens
yeah playing psychological warfare
you're tough enough right yeah oh it was
just
yeah i still it still frustrates me so i
mean i don't hate the guy it worked out
but
so the so what did you enlist ask did
you have an mos when you enlisted yeah
it's a comm job this is a 31 series com
jobs 31
unit they changed it but i think it was
a 31 uniform at the time
and it's like signal something i
honestly goodness did not a single thing
like i had i had dudes i i could barely
feel a cingar when we were over there i
didn't know [__] in fact one time i was
dating a girl and she was like what's
the smartest thing you ever did when you
were over there and i was like what are
you talking about she's like what's the
thing took like the most brain power
i was like
i set up a tax at one time on this
island and then i was i was thinking
about i'm like oh [__] i just carried it
i really you know you couldn't even say
it
but really in my head at first i thought
i did but then i remembered i'd give it
to adam
and you joined the national guard right
yeah did you know the difference between
the national guard no i i don't i swear
to you i think maybe
20 percent of kids
at that time had any idea what was going
on
it's like small town utah has a bunch of
those
national guard recruiting stations they
don't know uniform says the same thing
you don't know [__] yeah unless you have
like a family member that's in or
something and then that's different
which my buddy who i enlisted with had a
family member that was in so that would
have been did they tell him what was up
did he know what was going on here's
what i think happened there
his
his brother-in-law
really good dude
i think was like
let's not get you guys sent over into a
meat grinder got it i think that's if i
had to get it little did he know yeah
right
and you know it's funny the guard thing
works out better for me because had i
been in an active unit with that [__]
mls i would have never did anything i've
been stuck in a freaking comp cage the
entire time yeah so
it kind of worked out yeah
so you did you go to boot camp in
between your junior and senior years no
you so you had to fully graduate yep you
fully graduated
delayed delayed entry or whatever they
called it and you so you fully graduated
at what point did you
know that you were going to be activated
and sent overseas i volunteered for it
so we i got to so i went through basic
training and then what'd you think when
you got to basic training
i'll tell you
so my recruiter
i always tell people like when you get
to boot camp you're not going to like me
anymore there's going to be two to three
weeks where you're like choco i hate
that guy if i ever see him i'll take a
swing at him because
almost no matter who you are when you
get to boot camp
you think uh uh oh this was a mistake
yeah especially that first three weeks
but then toward the end it starts to be
kind of right you're like this is cool
and so i went to fort benning but pogue
side fort benning and again you wake up
every morning screaming infantry and all
this [__] you know
and then so
um
my recruiter had also he put me through
maps with the airborne physical and all
this stuff told me how to airborne on my
contract all this [__] i get in the boot
camp and you know like two weeks before
when you're at banning they call up and
they're like everybody with airborne on
your contract come in here and line up i
come line up you know i go in there and
he's like what the [__] are you doing
it's like
what are you talking about he's like you
ain't no [__] airborne under contract
let's get out of here so
it wasn't even in your contract he he
went as far as to put me through the
airborne physical
yeah but it wasn't your contract yeah
like why go through the physical if it's
not like no one else does
um so anyway i felt like i got kind of
but it worked out you know i'm not
trying to complain but i do feel like he
i'm a little irritated so i'm
salty like almost 20 years later about
this
um but when you're going in when you're
going through boot camp in the national
guard to be a reservist you must also
that's like make it a little bit more
comfortable
because you can find some comfort in the
fact that like god well at least i
didn't go active duty sure whereas if
you're active duty you're like oh this
is the rest of my this is the next six
four years of my life is to be in the
surrounded by these crazy people yelling
and screaming because you think that's
what the military's like when you go to
boot camp yeah sure
yeah i mean i guess but i just want to
go the war man
so
as soon as i got back to my unit after
ait and all this stuff so you went to
boot camp ait were you kicking ass in
ait since you killed so many freaking
woodpeckers growing up were you like
did you were your marksman expert and
all that stuff i mean i shot fine you
know i don't think i was but but the the
triggers on those were really hard to
get used to the m16 triggered first but
i mean i shot fine what about
what about just like being out in the
woods yeah just feeling good about all
that that was great yeah did you kind of
kick ass
ait yeah especially like the ftx stuff i
mean
it was like nothing man it's like all
these dudes are all worried about like
three days in the mud
it's like camping man
the only time it sucked
is when it uh it banning on our final
ftx it rained which i think is true for
like almost anybody that goes through
benning but it rained for like the
entire time so all of our hasties were
like water up to our chest and stuff
like that you know in fact one time
during night guard my buddy you know he
had your ankles interlocked in hasties
or whatever
well he was he was sleeping and i was up
and it was his turn i turn around and
there's a wolf spider like this big
and i put that sucker on his chest right
here
and i just tapped him
his eyes were like
you know you can't make noise you know
i'm trying to get it off and [__] anyway
yeah um i was in fort lewis washington i
was going through seal tactical training
which is what what you do when you're a
new guy
and we there's
some pretty heinous mosquitoes where we
were and i had learned to carry a
mosquito i would just carry like a
like a
one yard square of mosquito netting and
that way if we laid up i could just take
that thing out and just put it
underneath my floppy hat and and tuck it
in my collar and i'd be good to go
well my my
the officer that was in charge of us
bought brought like a full-on mosquito
net like you see i don't know like maybe
in
some british
uh colonists would wear in like africa
in like
1875 or something you know this big
giant screen with the wicker uh bands
around it pushing it out
and so we're in this layup position and
this other friend of mine didn't have
any net and a lot of guys actually
didn't have any net
and so my buddy was sitting there
catching mosquitoes and putting them
into the stage while he was sleeping
catching mosquitoes
so the mosquitoes were actually trapped
inside this car
he woke up in the morning
i got a kick out of that one
that's brutal yeah uh
what were you gonna say though so you
you you put the spider on the door oh
yeah yeah it just it was just funny to
watch him spazz out when he knew he
couldn't make noise
[Laughter]
yeah
this mosquito was better though
so you're feeling good at ait and the
war is in full swing right now right so
what year is this uh this would be 2000
2003 i don't know uh what was that 2004
2003 probably getting you said you
graduated in 2003 yeah and you went
right to boot camp uh there was a couple
month break because i was doing concrete
so i did conquer so i must went to boot
camp around october
something like that so it's probably
2004. could have been well that would no
cause
no cause well maybe it was i can't
remember i'm sorry it could have been
2004. i'm just trying to think time
phrase time frame what was no it could
have been iraq
because we
shipped
oh [__] maybe i'm sorry i keep doing
this now now i'm thinking we shipped out
on january
21st of
uh 2005 for iraq so it probably was
2004. yeah
yeah so you got
when you got done with it it's like 2004
so the war is going but it's not gone
crazy yet in 2000 no it's still like
pretty low level conflict happening in
iraq
uh
then you got so you got them with ait
then what happened did you go home and
you would get attached to your unit but
you didn't deploy right away did you uh
it wasn't very long i can't remember how
long it wasn't very long at all i went
to the first drill thing
and i was like this is
horrific
um what going to drill it was just
it was terrible because you wanted to be
also just yeah and it's just like
sitting doing radio [__] and like in a a
like a office and stuff and
like no i'm not about it man
so
as soon as there was somebody deploying
uh they said they had they so i was in
drill
i can't remember which iteration drill
was but i was in drill
and they they said they had someone
downstairs doing srp to go or it was an
srp um
what's srp this is i'm trying to
remember
if that's the right thing well it's like
where you're getting all your checking
all your paperwork vaccinations getting
stood up to go out i can't remember the
right that's right acronym but anyway
they were downstairs doing that crap
and they said that they had slots and so
i went and talked to my first line
leader and i was like i want to go
you know i want to go on this
and he was like fine you know so he let
me go down there and
go how long did they do extra training
did they yeah who'd they attach you to
to get ready to deploy gronsky's 28th id
um they sent us to so after we
yeah and so that was actually yeah so we
went straight from there to
from utah to uh uh mississippi at just
north of hattiesburg what the hell was
that camp shelby
and we did a couple months at camp
shelby and then we did a month rotation
at ntc
and then we shipped
and how was that did you feel like you
were getting pretty well prepared yes
well because by then out they put us
they stood up an actual psd element and
so we had a separate training uh cycle
same cycle but separate training pathway
so other than like company live fires
and stuff like this we were all
getting spun up by and most of the ocs
were like rangers because the they were
the only ones that had really been doing
psd for real so we had good oc's i felt
like and training was pretty good it was
better training than i got anywhere else
so you immediately got attached to a
group that was going to be doing psd
which is
personnel security detail that's where
that's what they told you your job was
going to be yeah they pulled from within
the unit and developed a psd element
because they didn't have one
and then you went to
you ended up going to ntc which is in
fort irwin california which is freaking
awesome training i mean they have whole
cities set up and villages and role
players and pyrotechnics did they have
all that stuff for you guys yeah were
you feeling pretty good about it man we
were living in those circus tents
yeah like 30 days that part's not fun
yeah the training was good i feel like
yeah but the two uniforms for like 30
days in that circus tent was not my
favorite
now at this time ramadi is starting do
you know when do you find out you're
going actually to ramadi like you don't
know day before we shift
get south
they were just they just kept telling us
take this training series man because
you might have to use it you know that
kind of stuff and you'd hear like
grumblings sunni triangle you'd hear
this kind of stuff
all right
okay you're ready rock and roll dude how
old were you at this point 19 yeah
hell yeah just young and dumb man
yeah and so then you get done with that
now it's time to leave
did you freaking blow it out before you
went overseas
yeah we yeah we went
we spent some time in louisiana for a
minute
when you fee when you're leaving what's
your what's your parents saying
what's your mom saying oh my
grandfather's saying are they worried
sick yeah my mom for sure was my grandpa
just didn't say much honestly
um he really never did about any of this
but my mom was definitely terrified the
whole time for sure she wasn't happy and
i just almost i just like kind of
laughed a little bit i don't know
because i'm thinking you're 19 like
there's nothing else in the world you
want to do and your mom's just horrified
by the whole thing sorry mom and
honestly as a father now i got three
boys now i have a daughter and three
boys and i think about it all the time
i think it must be much much much worse
to send a kid off to war than to go to
war yourself yeah it would have to be
and i've also always felt that it would
be worse like when i was overseas i
think it was worse for my wife than it
was for me
because
i know what's going on yeah
if i die
it's kind of
like i mean i don't you know i'm not
really gonna
like care too much i mean i guess i
would be bummed for that split second
but
but you know my wife is gonna be you
know stuck with all these kids and
everything so
i don't know i always felt like uh it
was much harder for the people that are
staying home than it is for the people
that are going overseas yeah
but worse even still for kids i think
like the children of yeah
yeah i think my kids were actually too
young to even understand they were
between the ages of like i guess
seven
and
three
is that right yeah seven and three or
something like that so
i don't think they really even
comprehended
and i don't know you know like one thing
with me is i never i never like wore a
uniform home
in the steel teams you just don't you
just you know you got all your [__] at
work and you just put your uniform on
you get there when you get done you put
on shorts and a t-shirt and flip-flops
and you go home
and your kids just don't even know
what's happening they don't understand
any of it you know
um they just think you just go to work
sometimes and you travel i don't know i
don't think my kids really
connected it too much
that they were that i don't think they
had the mental capacity or understanding
to actually worry
i don't think they worried at all i
don't think they worried one
second not like my wife did
you know especially when she was going
up you know going to hospital visit guys
and stuff like that
um
i guess when the kids are a little bit
older yeah you're probably right about
all that though
yeah it's like when i think even now
when i go hunting for a week or so i
probably worry more than my kids or miss
my kids more than they miss me yeah yeah
i get home
yeah i had my buddy leif uh
you know he's got young kids right now
and he was talking he's like i don't
know how you
i don't know how you went on deployment
like with you know he feels bad when he
goes on a work trip for a week you know
and and i get it you know and maybe it's
because you know he's older than i was
at the time and and i guess i had
that like kind of mindset that was a
little bit maybe not super good
[Laughter]
uh so you find out a day before you find
out you guys are going yeah it was it
was either like a day or two before one
long i mean i don't think it was a week
did you know anything about ramadi yeah
i mean we were watching the news i mean
and yeah fallujah it happened about
eight months or so before something like
that
maybe a full year
one was phantom fury may yeah something
like that
so yeah about a year before fallujah
happened so we had you know we had some
idea uh-huh and ever all the bad guys
pushed into ramadi at that time yeah
at least that's a story we always heard
yeah well i think it was pretty accurate
just when you look at the level of
violence from fallujah
and then the level of violence in ramadi
at that time it definitely flared up a
lot
uh do you guys just fly over in like a
c-17 or something how did you get over
there no we flew over in uh like delta
or something it was like a civilian jet
to where to kuwait
yeah we flew into kuwait we yeah we went
from
mississippi and then fueled up in maine
and then from maine to shannon ireland
and then from shannon ireland to kuwait
and then you get to kuwait now they
throw you on c-130s to bring you into
ramadi or
i drove you drove up huh yeah we were
the whole unit no they flew them up but
our team
was security for the log pack and all
that and all that
so we drove up so i drove through
navstar
and so now it's
5. yeah now it's 2000. for what month
i think may now june it was june i think
june of 2005. yeah
you're rolling up so that's a freaking
transit right there yeah because
speaking of the sunni triangle
you're going right through that tree
that's the whole sob yeah
yeah we uh the first day was
not
i mean it was interesting you know once
you cross those gates in there it's like
oil whales on fire and stuff and bullet
hole cars here and there scattered but
there's really not like anything going
on in the south of iraq so for the first
day the first nine hours i i can't
remember if it was uh so we left beering
is where we rolled out of
in
kuwait and this was a scania might what
might have been the first stop um i
think scania was the first stop and
anyway so throughout that and like
nothing happened
and then but other than you know just
kind of taking in the culture and it is
it is a for real culture truck like
southern iraq you know you see anyone
who's spending time in mexico you've
seen poverty that's different than
poverty in america for sure like
but the poverty in the south of iraq is
a whole new level i mean dudes like
stealing pieces of tarps from americans
just like patch holes in their tents and
stuff
so that was kind of a shock
and then
you know kids coming up asking for water
and food and and this kind of [__] you
know that was like new or
if you get slowed down somewhere dudes
wanting cigarettes tapping on you when
no you know like so it was um
it was interesting to just sort of it
was kind of
it was in some ways it was good to get
acclimated but nothing really happened
on that first two days and then on day
three we ended up hitting uh
i mean it didn't detonate but ended up
discovering an ied the lead truck did
and this was between fallujah and and
baghdad and so that was like our first
real experience with
doing anything for real and country you
know how many vehicles like just
estimate like how many vehicles are in
this log pack is this like a 40 vehicle
it could have been more than that so
it's massive yeah it took like six hours
or so i can't remember three years it
took hours and hours to fuel up you know
all these i can't take a long freaking
time
oh man
so what so when did you finally pull
into ramadi how many days did it take
you to get there three three days you
pull into camp ramadi
and they
what's that like i mean settling in
you've got get moved into a barracks or
where did you where'd you guys stay at
no yeah city no they didn't have any of
that yet there was a big
there was a big mwr building at the
front and they just put us up in that
you know where they had that boxing ring
and that stuff and then okay they just
put us up in that in cots for a week or
two i can't remember
but it was easier i think it was easier
for us in some ways to transit for for
the people that were going to go outside
the wire i think it was easier for us
for the first like
mentally for that first week because
when we hit that
when we hit that uh or didn't you know
when i say hit it didn't detonate but
when we hit that ied it's kind of like
you know
uh
bathed in fire in some ways like you to
see all like what this war is really
about to be for the next year
you know it's like middle of the night
they ca the marines that were helping us
they came
you know tapped on the door and like hey
we need help you know and you want to go
i'm like oh hell yeah
so it's like 84 and you know like let's
go
and so is me and
johnny and these two marines
went out up this debt cord so what they
they'd found an ied and you know it's
like honestly after i'd been there for a
while looking backwards it's a very
obvious setup right there's ied
and then the student's prayer rug and
his driver's license was just left there
you know it's like or his id card no
driver's license but
um so we were told
we don't have time you know eod can't
make it whatever
just trace that debt cord and if it goes
into the house because it was going out
into this compound you know like olive
orchard type stuff
it's like uh if it goes into the house
just frag the house and come back and i
was like oh yeah
i was so freaking stoked man
so we we hit the edge of this compound
you know underneath and this is you
and then two marines and your buddy
johnny yeah my first line leader at the
time yeah well i guess he stayed my
first line later but uh before i got
promoted
um
and it was you know how they'd have
those big obviously you know but they'd
have those walls you know cinder block
walls well there this one had a gate
that was locked and then it had a you
could see there was a hole in the sides
where i will just go through the hole
so we go around and as we come around
that hole
you could hear a generator running uh i
just assumed that it was in the back or
something you could hear a generator
running and then this dog starts barking
like this little yappy dog
and we're like in my mind the only thing
we got going for us right now just four
men is
that nobody knows we're here you know
within this compound i don't exactly
want to take plunging fire in this
compound just four dudes very badly
so now i'm like i can't wait to blow
that effing dog up man
i'm trying to hit that dude with my frag
so i'm thinking that as we're coming
around
toward the front of the to the toward
the front of home
and then once we take the right uh you
know so we
skirt in the house here and then take it
right towards actual front and you can
see the deck cord going into the house
and i was like oh yeah man this is it's
about to be on
so
we go around the deck cord and then
there's a like kind of a half ass like a
stoop not a not a true porch but like a
stoop
and on that stoop was these sandals all
laid out in like succession you could
tell it's like
dad
mom you know son older daughter and then
baby daughter with like these little two
inch pink sandals
man that i had a
i had a little sister i still do but i
was very close to her at the time she
was like six or seven at that time and
man that hit me like a freight train you
know like whoa
you know it's not it's
you're not just killing bad guys all the
time you know so what ended up happening
we went up we went all the way around
it ended pretty good actually we went
all the way around and the debt cord
came out and went into his uh orchard in
the back so we traveled through it a
little bit and then one of the marines
said hey i'm going to pull the pin flare
out or pop a pin flare and johnny didn't
hear him
so i'm like over here getting a small
echelon and maureen pops out the pin
flare and johnny just hits the deck
[Laughter]
so i got a good kick out of it but
we stopped there for a minute and we
just see that the deck was going out
somewhere and there was two dudes up in
another home on a balcony smoking cigars
you know with aks was like
well
anyway depending on
the situation but
uh we weren't you know we didn't nothing
happened mm-hmm but so you just walked
back to the vehicles basically yeah but
the thing is like
almost guaranteed those dudes were
waiting to see what we would do like
almost guaranteed they were the ones
that set it up and everything
and i mean what are you doing smoking
cigars on your deck at 240 yeah i you
can't you unfortunately you can't even
answer that question because they would
be doing the most wild crazy like
unknown things that you ever have
imagined in a million years that's true
you know like like for instance 2 40 in
the morning i mean i had a guy approach
a target one time and my terps yelling
at him and
the guy's like got carrying a box with
him
and he's walking towards we're
assaulting a target this isn't baghdad
we're assaulting a target and this guy's
walking up looking super suspect
and
my terps like hey there's 50 cows
pointed at him and like like hey
and so finally i just like i just like
aggressively approach him
and or no we told him put the box down
so he sets the box down at his feet and
i get over i saw so i go like grab this
guy
and as i'm going to grab him
he like pulls something out of his
pocket and i'm so close to him i had my
weapon i like smashed his hand with my
weapon
and he dropped this little remote that
he was carrying
and yeah it sounds all cool here's the
deal though this dude was drunk
you know once we got to the bottom of it
he was drunk and in the box was a video
machine and he had been over at his
buddy's house watching porno and getting
drunk with his buddy you know he i
almost smoked him you know
you gotta deserve it but they do some
dumb [__] man and so you never know uh
so what you're saying is since you had a
little bit of experience driving up
there
the guys that the guys that arrived via
air
were sort of had to get used to going
out in town yeah they didn't they didn't
experience any of the culture
you know or at least even not
necessarily that we experienced but even
get a taste of it so their first time
interacting was maybe not the best day
yeah you know and we got to have kind of
ease into it a little bit
so then what was your date what was your
what was your mission so your mission as
a psd guy was to protect people
you know important people whether that's
a battalion commander a brigade
commander
support
i don't know support eod clearances that
was basically what you were doing
yeah well yeah but then
the command the our principles never
really left so we ended up
just doing whatever came down lots lots
of qrf stuff lots of eod support
uh quite a few like log packs those are
the most
miserable
missions on the entire you gotta drive
all the way around lake havana and
absolutely nothing's gonna happen except
for you're gonna get smoked with an ied
like they're just
yeah those were terrible because they're
boring and it's just like a crap shoot
yeah boring and waiting to die at the
same time yeah it's like the worst
so we that's like mostly what we were
doing uh and then we you know a few
raids come down here and there and need
somebody and we go do that stuff what
was your op tempo like
uh it's it varied a lot uh yeah it just
varied a ton it depended or like if we
were doing like prisoner transport then
that would be like a two day boring ass
thing same kind of thing with log packs
but then if we were back home and there
was none of that going on then we might
have a little higher up tempo
you know mm-hmm just whatever's coming
in now but you were basically work would
you say you're working every day yeah
for sure definitely working every day
yeah yeah for sure roll them outside
off yeah yeah i don't think we had a day
off until they brought in
i don't know if this you guys probably
not but
they ended up bringing in shrinks
uh i can't remember what month it might
have been december
i can't remember what month it was
anyway they ended up bringing in shrinks
to
like that the army was starting to have
a problem with ptsd stuff on at home but
they were still kind of pts back then i
think and so they brought in these
shrinks and it was like if you've done
this many missions outside the wire in
this amount of time then they were
pulling you off the line and putting you
like on a guard tower uh for how long
two weeks heading off the line
yeah and when they did that with us i
was telling my first song i'm like top
this is the stupidest [__] i've ever
heard in my life
you can't i mean
yeah you don't want to come in and just
get soft you know yeah like so yeah and
then also you might
start to not want to go back out again
because you know you get that
you get time to too much time to think
about it and honcho
uh was there any missions that you did
that stood out to you that were
particularly uh interesting or important
missions not really man we did like
i was a normal dork guy man i'm doing a
lot of cool stuff we did a raid with
we just supported first marine recon one
time on a raid between ramadi and the
syrian border they'd
someone once we got predator drones they
discovered this compound out there that
nobody even knew existed it was like out
in sand dunes and you call it a big wadi
farm i think i hope that's not
and oh that's not like some classified
[__] or something i don't know
but i don't think big wadi farm could be
that classified
if it is they need to work on their
freaking classifications well i thought
that's what we called it okay
so uh
yeah i mean that was cool watching recon
take that down was pretty cool but like
we just did normal like day to day
try not to get blown up
you know try to shoot the people that
need to get shot and not the ones that
don't
um
i mean just really it was kind of that's
why
when i was writing the book
you know i
i just like a very basic normal guys
soldiers story so i don't think there
was any for me it didn't seem like there
was any sense in going into all these
little minor you know this day we got
shot out here like the first time i took
sniper fire was for sure memorable
um
in fact i'll tell you that story really
quick we were out on do you remember
trooper recon it was just outside of the
north gate yep
before they had fortified that we just
had a
we just had like a big texas barrier up
there
and
we were just sitting there waiting i
can't remember where the heck we were
going but we were staged to go somewhere
yeah and
anyway we just take two or one round
first and then another round but it goes
right over my gunner's head who was
sitting in in the humvee on the gun you
know but he's just daydreaming you know
and it goes right through they had a
piece of camo netting it goes like right
through the camo netting and he hit and
he looked like uh when you if you ever
slaughtered a bull when you shoot them
that's almost like their legs come up
and they hit the ground like a cartoon
that's like what he did we thought he
was dead man like it sounded like he
just piled up in that humvee
and so i was
like where's he shooting from where's he
shoot from i was like trying to find
where he's coming from but also not keep
my head out for you know five minutes at
a time
so like moving from side to side up and
down just trying to peak and then
finally i said the only thing this could
be is this covert like there's nothing
else it could possibly be
so
we radio up and
we read it up we're like hey we're going
to go get this
you know this this is or we're gonna go
check this culvert it's the only place
we can figure that we get shot at from
now it's also possible that he was just
like out in the desert somewhere and
shooting further than we thought they
were capable of but when you see a
handful of iraqis shooting at you with
like aks with no front sight posts
you know not thinking they're pulling
off the 1100 yard shots so you're
looking at that culvert that's 200 yards
there he is
so
we the captain
is like i want to go out with you guys
i'm like oh my gosh
okay so we wait and we wait
it had to be 15 20 minutes had to be
waiting for the captain to show up had
to be could have been longer
so by the time he gets there we're all
talking we're like there's no way this
dude's still there there's no freaking
way he's just gonna lay there for 20
minutes like
he's
they're dumb but they're not that dumb
so the captain gets there and we roll
out and he's like okay
you know we so we got truck here truck
here on the side of the cover
and i was like i'll go in and i pulled
the flashbang out and he goes mccoy
don't you throw that flashbang in there
i'm like what are you talking about he's
like could be a a uxo or excuse me an
ied in there and i was like
okay he's like i want you to set this
ied off while we're standing on it i was
like dude i'm not going in that without
throwing a banger bro i think i'd much
rather have the flashbang set the id off
than mccoy
i'm like it's not happening man
and he
he goes uh if you if you throw that
flashbang in there i'll write you an
article 15. and i said get your [__]
hand out
i swear i know it sounds pretend i swear
to god
so i throw it in there and say you know
it's a true story because i throw that
sucker in there and i jump off johnny
comes in behind me we're going in and i
panicked myself so i saw my own banger
and i thought it was uxo so i was like
uxo uxo i'm trying to back out and
johnny's like what like you xo he's like
sure it's like [__] flashback
yeah whatever
unexposed or unexploded ordinance so he
flew his flashbang in there it went off
but there's still like little chunks of
it you know that are sitting there
backed out to get his freaking articles
yeah
yeah that's classic he
and that captain was a good dude he just
i don't know what he was thinking on
that one he didn't write me number 15.
yeah i mean man it's hard i'm assuming
that he was fresh in country as well oh
yeah he was young man you have no idea
of like
what's going on when you first get in
country you have just no idea it's hard
and a young guy like he was a 25 or
something 24 i don't know how old are
they roughly yeah he's probably
something like that probably maybe 20
maybe 26 something like that but yeah
he's not old takes four years takes four
years to make captain
or mako three so he might have been 20
yeah so he's like 24 maybe 25. yeah um
and he didn't know anything he doesn't
leave the wires you know he's running a
battery like he's
you know
you know uh just on what you said
earlier about hey you were just a
regular soldier all of my guys
we all just
we all looked at you all
like
damn because you guys were out going out
there like you said every single day
you're going out there to do random
searches of culverts where you're just
taking fire from it just like [__] like
that on a daily basis
and yeah uh
we we just held all you guys in the
highest regard for what you guys were
doing every single day you know we'd
come back and we'd go on and off and
come back and
we had good chow and a place to chill
out a little bit
and if a guy was like tired it's like
okay you know and you guys are just
getting that tasking every single day
there's another thing i've talked about
where it's
like
i don't know which one of these there's
there's a different psychological impact
a lot of times army guys like we'd be
working with army platoons and they're
like oh this is what we're getting
tasked to do we're gonna go out and
patrol this area we're gonna go out and
clear this this block we're gonna go out
they're just getting tasked with what
they're gonna do they don't have any
real say in it
and we had a complete we had complete
control
like oh this is what we want to do then
we'll go do it if we didn't want to go
do it we wouldn't go do it
like pretty much we just made up what we
wanted to do and there's
pros to that because
you know you can say hey i don't think
this is a good time to do that but also
when something happens it's 100 because
you said
hey this is what we're gonna do so
there's a different uh psychological
impact
depending on who you are
of how it ends up in your brain because
for us anyways on that deployment we did
what we wanted to do we picked and chose
exactly what we wanted to do
we watched army guys getting tasked hey
you're gonna go out you're gonna you
know that road you got ied on yesterday
yeah you're going down it again today
you know the one you got ied two times
before that yep you're going down that
one as well and
guys just had to
grit their teeth and
oftentimes just that was the mission
they go execute it we had more
flexibility but then again like i said
that means when something does go wrong
so there's only still it's 100 on me as
yup that's my mission i'm approving it
let's go
um but yeah you guys you know you
talking about you just being a normal oh
i didn't do it didn't do much no big
deal um going out there every single day
into that city is
a freaking salute to all you guys
uh how often would you say you you were
taking contact when you guys would go
out um we we didn't there a lot of guys
got way worse than us we didn't take it
a lot um
we really didn't take a lot because we
would also end up on dumb ass like log
pack [__] you know like i'm saying so
then we're way out and
to quantum but even on stuff like that's
like ied every single time or every
other time or something uh but in town i
mean i don't i don't know if
i don't know if anybody didn't at least
get shot at everything like
you couldn't you sure as hell could not
go down route michigan and not at least
have someone shoot at you all right
i had some guys over at in eastern
ramadi and i was briefing
the kernel of the siege soda awesome guy
and i was just briefing them on what we
were doing how we were doing it and i
said you know sir
my element that's out in eastern ramadi
they've they've been con they've been
contacted by the enemy the last 23
operations in a row
and then my intel guy or my
talk guys came in like while i'm saying
that they're like sir just to let you
know troops in contact and the guys in
the house like i said sir make that 24
times in a row uh so yeah you were
definitely going to
the enemy was there
yeah the enemy was definitely there well
it didn't help that everyone was just
retaking the same ground every day
i mean
and every every idiot on the line was
saying that you know this makes
absolutely no sense what were we doing
you know we eventually ended up starting
setting up cops and stuff like this but
in the beginning it was just
essentially glorified presence patrol
after present patrol
it's just very stupid stuff
but yeah i mean like i say other guys
are doing way more than we were too it's
like way more so
um
from a leadership perspective what do
you see from the good leaders that you
work for what did you notice about them
what made you want to follow them
uh
for uh integrity is huge when somebody
from a leadership perspective it's inter
when actually maybe integrity is not the
right word yeah
if when you start seeing your
like your brass
[__] in you
you know
it's you i mean it's really hard to get
that trust back like just don't [__]
me tell me what it is i mean i don't
want to name anybody or even tell
certain stories but there was a couple
where it was like man
what are you doing you know um
and here's just a little warning for
leaders
if you think that your frontline troops
don't know when you're lying to them
you're so wrong
you tell that frontline troop that hey
they'll know this is no don't worry
because we're going to do this later or
this is what's really happening
everybody can see right through it
so if you're lying to your people
they're gonna know you're not smarter
than them they know exactly what's
happening and you can't [__] these
guys um so don't try and do it yeah like
one time one of them came up with this
plan uh i don't want to say who but he
called it operation decoy
and we had a apache gun ships for the
day you know but it was like supposed to
be two weeks out or something
and the plan was that our team would
just take our trucks
and roll through until like ieds went
off you know like hopefully you see them
right but
we're like listen man
you're going in lead vehicle [__] like
what is this you know like you're just
happy you got some helicopters looks
like you're just
yeah
yeah we ended up not having to do that
one but that was legitimately the plan
and yeah my my nco was like nope you can
bust me we're not doing this
check
um
with that um
that kind of covers uh some of the stuff
leading up to anything else you want to
cover leading up to glass factory no
that's fine all right
let's get into this book man again book
is called the glass factory you're going
to hear me read parts of it that it has
got
it's great it's great story you're a
great storyteller but
the internal dialogue that's going on in
here of what your thoughts are the
progress you're making as a person is um
it's just an outstanding book so get the
book
here we going the glass factory
starts like this the whole recruitment
push had gone smashingly thus far but we
were on our fourth day of this same
drive and we had already hugely
surpassed our initial goal of 200 new
recruits
the men of ramadi had lined up in droves
for the opportunity to become one of the
guys chosen to fly to jordan for the
high speed training the u.s government
had funded for them and later returned
to their hometown to clean it up
in fact we had processed hundreds of
candidates already the catch was this
was going to be day four of this
particular mission and we
had only been promised three peaceful
days
the problem was all the spots that we
had for these future iraqi police had
been filled days ago this was all just
for show
no one on our team felt like it was a
good idea to put ourselves at risk for
almost nothing but we were soldiers and
that's just part of the job
or so we are told
when we got into our home v i cracked a
joke well let's go get blown up boys
i was just trying to cut the tension
probably mine more than any others
but i'm not sure it had the desired
effect
um
actually talking to general gronsky on
here you know he talks about the fact
that as he looks back he's like i
that four days no didn't need it
shouldn't have done it you know that's
that's his that's what he feels um
that's what he said
and you know you're not i mean
hindsight's always 20 20. yeah um
well i know why i did it though
we
the the thing that was frustrating for
us was
day two
they had shot us i mean they missed
wildly but they shot at us with rockets
and then day three and that's just i
mean maybe they were just shooting a
camper monitor but like i said they
missed wildly day three two dudes sat at
the bus stop for like four hours and we
reported it up like i mean who's first
of all
what are they waiting for
you know
um so anyway we reported that up and but
the reason you know to defend gronsky
here the reason that he went on with it
is we had guys process and clear up
until like midnight and it was dark and
we turned away
a couple hundred people got it
so he didn't want them to feel like they
didn't have the opportunity even though
no one was having the opportunity by
then but just the show of that at least
that's that was my take and and then
just from a strategic perspective here
the goal was to have the local people
from ramadi
join our ramadi police and then police
up their own city so they could they
could fight against the insurgents there
and as you said there's hundreds of them
that showed up so that's pretty awesome
that's a pretty great feeling as all
those people are showing up you want to
help them
and the call was made try and get these
guys in there
um
you actually and again i'm not reading
the whole book right now
let people get your audiobook but you
had an uneasy feeling about this op
yeah
yeah in fact you wore like your winter
your shitty winter warfare boots right
those boots sucked
yeah because you knew they were gonna
get cut off you at some point i mean
that's the that's what you're thinking
anyway you know at least if you're gonna
live i you know i want to keep my good
boots
uh yeah i mean there was just too many
things
and then i i do i don't know if it's
premonition or what but you
i just i just felt like i knew
just knew
fast forward a little bit we put our
team members in their places inside the
glass factories walls and went outside
and went out ourselves
i was oddly calm as we walked out the
gate not that i generally feared of
being among iraqi people it's just in a
situation like this where you're
surrounded by roughly a thousand men
whom you have no ability to directly
communicate with things can spiral out
of control very quickly the otherwise
peaceful crowd could be overtaken by the
chaos of the mob in an instant and that
should be frightening to anybody
up and down the line of iraqis we walked
checking the crowd for threats as we
went we stopped frequently to
interrogate iraqis who looked eager
agitated or uncomfortable honestly most
of them looked nervous and unsettled
which was perhaps the most reasonable
way to feel in that moment these guys
knew they were in danger just as well as
we did after all they lived in the city
that we fought in
the danger of terrorist attacks had
become just another part of daily life
to the citizen of western anbar province
at one point a man approached us
uneasily instantly causing my blood
pressure to rise he stood close to me as
he began to talk too close back up i
said he has something to tell you carlos
and carlos is the nickname that you guys
gave to your interpreter
carlos leaned in and told me defensively
grenade you found a grenade our
interpreter continued the conversation
yes the man responded a grenade with a
wire carlos relayed to us in english
you got to be [__] me i said there's
a [__] tripwire out here somewhere
ask him where the hell it is carlos
carlos turned to the man and asked but
we but they were having a hard time
communicating because the guy was so
scared it was like watching a
kindergartner tattletail on his
classmates on the playground
god damn it we are out here in a cloud
of a thousand unpredictable iraqis and
there's a [__] booby trap somewhere i
said allowed but to no one in particular
so there's uh
this is just and i'm only again i'm only
reading chunks of this thing um but this
is a this is a rough situation to be in
how many people you guys got like
uh we had 12 that day and then
yeah we had 12 and then they had um the
one seven deuce had an abrams on the
road
and
then the marines had a
little bit of security i mean we
probably
anyway our team had 12 people how many
tall what do you what was the total
coalition forces probably 40 i bet
and there's a thousand yeah something
like that yeah something roughly yeah i
mean you know that that joint
recruitment checkpoint up the road by
the bridge from the glass factory
i don't know it's like
it's got to be
a third it's got to be a third of a mile
or so maybe even a half a mile or maybe
it's a quarter mile anyway you know it
might have changed too yeah yeah they
could have took it out that's true
um anyway they were lined up damn near
to like damn near to there three three
deep i got pictures of it i should send
you but there's a lot of people there
so
you're
at this point you're trying to locate
the ied you're kind of like you're
focused on that you go of course you
can't just totally focus on that you got
all these other guys walking around
you're asking questions
and then uh going back to the book i
heard a strange sound to my left
followed by the report of rifles and
bursts from the machine guns set atop
the abrams tank that had been positioned
to a block of street i dropped to a knee
and began to scan for targets bang bang
bang crack crack crack the rounds
sounded off as they hit struck their
target
men began shouting in two different
languages the confusion of combat sets
in rapidly iraqis were running around
frantically screaming in high-pitched
tones and flailing about in the streets
others stood frozen as if in fear and
curiosity had stiffened them still
scanning for a target that i could
possibly identify and engage but but
coming up with none i was getting
worried that i was missing some obvious
ambush coming from the buildings to our
south
then i saw it a semi truck had crashed
through our perimeter a few hundred
meters away our fellow soldiers and
marines had immediately recognized the
threat and eliminated it before it could
do any more damage to our position
that's one hell of a v-bit i thought to
myself the acute problem had been solved
i hoped for all i knew that thing might
be filled with explosives but an even
larger threat now loomed a terrified mob
civilians were running around horrified
shoving each other climbing over the
jersey barriers screaming lost in the
confusion of the moment
it did not take long to decide that we
could not allow them to get any more
riotous
it was time to start wrangling
non-combatants
johnny was within earshot so i asked him
what the new plan of action was he
radioed the talk and briefed them on the
current situation our commanding
officers verified that reinforcement
troops were now in route
all we could do in the time being is
keep the iraqis contained until we had
enough help to reorganize them
so there's a big vehicle approaches
machine gun on the tank the coax or
something stops that vehicle yeah yeah a
couple yeah we had um we had a machine
gunner set up in a position kind of a
blocking position too and so they were
that was in you could you know hitting
the engine block and disabled it and it
ended up turned out it was just a you
know iraqi being an iraqi and he just
drove through our concertina but you
yeah well you can't i mean in a
situation like especially when you're
told all morning that's a v-bad yeah and
and by the way that means there's
constantine wire that means there's
signs in arabic that say don't pass here
deadly force will be used there's
several layers of that stuff
um
which is why i was saying earlier like
you could never imagine that someone
would do that and and oftentimes also
they're well and in this case likely
true and probably a distraction to get
right people distracted from what else
was happening so
they maybe they didn't have time to
build a v bid
and so they just sent this guy in there
to start the distraction which is
what it looks like to me
um
going back to the book we started
yelling at the civilians to get back in
line as carlos translated for us a few
listened but most pretended not to hear
what he was saying or just plain too
afraid to move we ratcheted up our anger
a little and looked them dead in the eye
and let them know we were still in
command of this circus but it was of
little use
whether we wanted it to be or not soon
became apparent that we were going to
have to be more forceful some of the men
had to be physically dragged off of the
the tops of barriers
some had to be shoved others conformed
when they saw that we were no longer
messing around still others ran away and
escaped the scene altogether
fast forward a little bit two of our new
marine friends were there asking whether
we wanted them to get their dogs roger
please do
these two marines were canine handlers
and by reputation damn good ones one of
them was sergeant kan
he had already deployed to iraq before
this round for him had started at a
small base out in western iraq near the
syrian border but that area lacked the
action he longed for so he had requested
transfer to the hottest area of the
fight ramadi
he was a true badass warfighter and in
my experience the military has no better
tool for safely changing the minds of
stubborn iraqi men than a canine warrior
at london of a leash and a cocksure
marine at the other
so you got dogs on station now
um
at one point you sort of lightened your
load a little bit mm-hmm
where what did you go back into the gate
to do that yeah yeah
to the man gate and just started off
because there was so many
grab hands going on we were so
undermanned and i started worrying about
especially my smoke up here getting hit
with flak you know i just didn't want to
burn the [__] on my face
so i started offloading the stuff and
and then i chose to keep my shotgun
which i still
it's still weird to me that i
but i didn't know like my shotgun was
what i really needed in the moment
for the crowd but you know what if we
had to push out and anyway i talked
about that a little bit in there so it
was i mean if you had to push out maybe
you just go go back and get your rifle
you know like um
[Applause]
but you but you made yourself a little
slicker this is basically what you did
so you could do more crowd control
without worrying about one of these guys
grabbing something
um
there's some iraqi policemen with you
yeah oh yeah and these guys started
getting they're generally they started
getting hyper aggressive
that was the best one we had by the way
that the one that this one this one
that's going off here here you so so
this guy like basically is
pointing his point his ak at everybody
you know he's getting ready to freaking
looks like he's getting ready to start
shooting people well when i found him
they had him encircled
and he was in the center circle and they
were hollering back and forth i don't
know what tyler's saying mm-hmm and then
i see him jack around after that
ghost [__] man he's about to light these
dudes up and
i mean i i don't know i didn't i don't
know if i'd hated him for doing it in
that moment you know i was pretty
frustrated everything i didn't want him
to shoot him yeah make a joke but
yeah he was he was scared you know they
they don't respect other iraqis and
there's a really weird customary thing i
don't know if this was throughout the
whole of iraq but for sure
in ramadi where they're really like not
afraid of aks you pull out a pistol and
those mofos get all kinds of like
you know it's an attitude changer huh
and i've always heard that maybe it was
because of like hit squads and stuff
like that
but yeah so if you just have like an ak
pointing down they're like man i've been
doing that to my brother since we were
five you know like not even
not even worried about it you know
so that he was like jacking that round
in and be like no i'm seriously going to
shoot you
you know
so then all of a sudden hey
i heard yelled at an authoritative and
powerful new american voice we don't
[__] act like that around here that's
saddam's tactics we don't pull that [__]
lieutenant colonel mack had arrived and
he was not pleased with the behavior of
our iraqi comrade apparently colonel
mack had heard that things were getting
out of hand and had decided to gather up
his personal security detail and come
see the mission through with the help of
mac's team the dog handlers we began to
and the dog handlers we began to regain
control the crowd we separated civilians
into three lines heading east and west
along the large concrete wall that
formed the outer border of the glass
factory
fast forward a little bit the entire
morning my good friend and medic whom we
affectionately called z had been
hounding me to have him relieved of his
post he was manning our 50 caliber
machine gun within the walls of the
glass factory which we had set up to
defend us from the crowd and from
potential attacks
for me though
the problem at hand was a personal one z
was oh so he's he's like requesting yeah
he's gonna get out of there he's been
hauling me for an hour by then and your
basic thought was
don't come out here you just want to put
hey he's the medic if something happens
you don't want him to be involved in it
um so you're you basically you're
basically like okay just a minute just
hold on and you're basically just trying
to put it off until the yeah man i've
told him no for hours and you just want
to shut the hell up and i'm like all
right man just give me a second give me
a second
try that tactic slow rolled him
um
[Music]
fast forward a little bit hey corporal
mckay mccoy get over here lieutenant
colonel mack yelled at me i'll be right
back you know what to do i told rick
before i jogged over to the colonel and
again this seems a little bit like
stilted when i read it maybe you don't
recognize all these characters that's
because i'm not reading the whole book
so buy the book
um hey mccoy you got any dip yes sir
mac was a commanding but warm leader
you could not help but feel a little
stronger when you talk to him he was
straight to the point it would
and i would not use the word friendly
per se but he was certainly not the
typical overbearing massively insecure
curmudgeon that some officers or even
ncos for that matter can be he was a
warrior a man you respected and admired
he went on to give me some
a new set of instructions that i cannot
quite recall and then sent me off
each of us heading back to our positions
about 50 meters apart when i got back to
rick and stood in front of him with my
back turned to his direction and picked
up instruction right where i had left
off
then z called me on the radio again to
say he was on his way out there because
he had found relief
i reached up with my left hand to key
the microphone
on my left shoulder and bent my neck to
respond raj see you out there
suddenly there was a loud bark followed
by a violent growl coming from somewhere
just in front of me i peered under the
brim of my helmet to figure out what was
going on next still bent to the radio
mic
sergeant can's dog
bruno had grabbed an iraqi man in the
midst of the first line by the arm and
began to shake him violently sergeant
kan threw himself at the guy
boom
deafening blast rumbled out back to back
accompanied by two rapid white flashes
a burning stinging sensation shot
through my entire body
it was as if i'd been struck by
lightning i felt my muscles and bones
contort fiercely almost like they had
flexed in succession so swiftly that
their mere compression had been enough
to shatter my skeleton
then
followed an
unimaginable pain
it felt like every nerve in my body had
been set ablaze at the same instant
then
blackness
it's you have a pretty good memory of
that
yeah surprisingly up up into that moment
i think i have a pretty solid handle and
then afterwards
uh
it's a little
looser for a
period
because
when johnny
and i talked about it he had said that
he thought he got to me
within like a minute or so which would
is totally plausible given the distance
but to in my mind it seemed like it was
quite a bit longer than that
uh so i don't know after getting your
head bell rung that
you know it's hard to but uh my
psychologist told me that the reason
that that's actually not uncommon
as far as like leading up into something
it's called a flash bold memory or
something like this your brain like
imprints
you know uh
like one moment in time yeah
like apparently this often happens to
people in violence situations i think
it's called a flashback memory i'm sure
i'd had my phone on google it but
yeah i and so and again like it's only
as accurate as i can be
i'm sure there's mistakes yeah yeah well
no i mean i've got friends that got
blown up and they don't literally don't
remember anything i mean it's just they
don't remember anything they don't
remember you know they maybe remember
15 20 minutes before it happened and
then
just blank until they wake up in a
hospital somewhere
um that's interesting
yeah and that's you know
from that moment that's where i started
the podcast you know when you were faced
you wake up
face down in the in the
in the sand and covered in blood
um
going back to the book here
fast forward a little bit you say when
the blast went off they had thrown
dozens of men including me some tens of
feet
when we had all landed i met up at the
bottom of one of the piles of dead and
wounded
johnny pulled the bodies off me as he
continued to shout
corpses lifted one by one i believe
there were three bodies on top of me
the weight lessened
i could move a little more freely then
when one of the corpses was pulled off
of me
i saw the mangled parts which had
blocked the view to my own hips leave
with it for the first time since the
initial blast my waistline was exposed i
was able to see that my hips and at
least my the upper portion of both of my
legs were still intact
i had not been cut in half after all
great news in the darkest of moments
but
i still could not see below my knees
johnny grabbed my body and rolled me
over i realized my legs were still fully
attached and fully articulated from feet
to hip
the pain was extraordinary but things
were looking up
my friend kept on talking to me as he
patched me not my now exposed wounds he
assured me that both of my legs were
still there
and that they were not missing any
joints
which i thought i saw with my own eyes
but his reassurance sure didn't hurt
anything
he did his best to keep me calm and
relaxed i did my hardest to tough it out
for him
on every mission i wore nomex gloves
which i had the fingers cut out of early
on deployment
because my right hand was so mangled
johnny and lyle another soldier who had
who was helping administer first aid
thought it best just to get the bleeding
stop so they banished my hand right over
the top of the glove
they had my right hand elevated and
bandaged up by the time i saw it but
both bandages and the glove quickly ran
through with blood
there was a three inch long gash across
the top of my right forearm just above
my wrist it had been opened up so wide
that it revealed the bright white bones
and my warm and pink
muscle fibers which twitched on either
side of the wound as it bled
there were approximately seven holes in
that arm and eight more in my left
they were all leaking
hot thin looking blood traced ghastly
lines down each arm from shoulder to
hand i had still yet to see what my legs
looked like under my uniform but it was
obvious that even though all of each leg
was still attached the situation was
dire
every time i shuddered convulsed or
worse yet was bumped by someone else i
grunted and moaned in agony
otherwise i either gritted my teeth to
get a handle on the pain or babbled
incoherently i'm sorry johnny i'm trying
not to be a [__] but this [__] really
hurts i know it does bro you don't have
to apologize
when z our medic finally reached us he
looked over at me and said mac i've got
to go help a marine he's worse off than
you are i'll be back as soon as i can
his voice was stricken with panic i
heard it but i felt a deep sense of
pride at how well my friend and teammate
defeated that trepidation and did his
job right
z stood up and hustled over to sergeant
kan's side to begin treating treatment
on him
z was worried about my future
as any close friend would be but a basic
army medical procedure had a very strict
rule of progression a medic is to start
with the american who is most gravely
injured
and you gotta
one thing that's cool about this book
you got a bunch of footnotes in there
where you kind of just add some detail
and i don't know how many of them gonna
read but this one is pretty pretty cool
uh pretty interesting anyways i just
want to reiterate this point it could
have been upsetting to watch a close
friend walk away while i was clearly on
the brink of death especially since he
left to go help a warrior who had almost
surely already passed away but that's
not how i felt at all all i remember
feeling was a deep sense of respect and
the strength of character that my friend
had just displayed he had been forced
into an extremely uncomfortable and
complex situation with nearly no time to
think it over and he had demonstrated
the courage to put personal loyalties
aside and do the right thing
just imagine the world we would live in
if more people had that kind of
fortitude
yeah because he's like your boy yeah
mm-hmm
and
and he has to just be like hey i'll be
back man yeah
and the and my buddies that were there
trying to pat i mean you could tell just
from reading that that are not exactly
medics you know if you couldn't get
hands to quit bleeding you know i mean
they're doing their best yep
they're just like wrapping
gauze over open like you know you gotta
hold all the way through my hand right
here and then all the way through my
knuckle and my thumb and you know i mean
i couldn't move my finger like so it's
like this is all mangled and they're
just like wrapping gauze around like
we're going to work out or something you
know what i mean
like i mean they're trying but you know
what i'm saying and then like this one
up here you know that was all opened up
they were just like wrapping it you know
and that was from just a ball bearing
and just ripped the you know what i mean
so they just didn't really know what
they were doing and so it's not like
zane could what i'm saying is not like
zane couldn't see that when he first
looked you know
and the one thing i i can't remember if
i wrote about it but i will say is the
compartment syndrome part
which maybe which maybe you might read
but
uh with the way the legs sucked up
probably saved my life really because
it's like creating an internal
tourniquet on your femurs you know so at
least my but my legs
were not bleeding as badly as they could
have been in that moment tell us about
that compartment syndrome
so when uh your femurs break
especially if they break in multiple
places but if any anytime they your
femur is always at risk of a compound
fracture any time it breaks because your
glutes and your
quads are just strong
so this my femurs were broke in multiple
places so they just folded like a
you know almost they just folded up
anyway and they went beside each other
like this and then you're just cutting
all kinds of blood vessels in there and
potentially arteries and all of that but
so that creates some internal
uh
swelling and pressure and then you get
like blood that gets locked
into in between two
like the it can't go above or below that
spot so it's like a
blood that's trapped in an area but it
was almost acting like a tourniquet yeah
you basically you got lucky yeah in the
fact that you had compartment syndrome
that's swelled around your arteries and
shut some of that bleeding down yeah
because otherwise
yeah
um
at this point z's back working on you
and you say my clothing all removed i
could finally see the multitude of holes
in my legs clearly as he began to patch
what he could but they were even worse
conditioned than my arms were each leg
had more than ten different holes in it
some of which were nearly two inches in
diameter
most were not that big they were the
size of
they were about the size of a small
marble on average but they had gone
straight through both sides of my
quadriceps
at this stage the wounds were not
pumping out as much blood as one might
have expected it was more like a steady
leak
she said as i lay there watching them
bleed for a while thinking to myself
holy [__] saving private ryan really got
it right these wounds look exactly as
they do in the movie
um
so they are now packing you up and
they're trying to get you onto a onto a
damn litter eventually they get you on
the litter
um
they get you on the litter now it's each
time the truck would bounce in and out
of potholes my bones would rattle rub
together the pain at this stage was so
intense that when combined with my heavy
blood loss it caused me to pass in and
out of consciousness but because of the
condition i was in z was doing
everything in his power to keep me awake
mac mac don't you go to sleep he yelled
i moaned a response as best i could and
then forced my eyes open
this is fun
when we finally reached the rear
entrance of camp ramadi we ran into a
whole new set of problems
our own soldiers ineptness we rolled up
only to be immediately stopped by the
soldiers who ran the gate they would not
let us in because we did not have a
convoy number
you can't make this [__] up that's 100
true
yeah z was losing it on those boys at
that point
um back and forth our driver argued with
the gate guards until eventually z
standing in the bed of the truck lost
his cool we don't have a [__] convoy
number i can't let you in without one
this isn't a [__] convoy you idiot we
got a wounded american here eventually
the soldiers at ogden gate let their
better sense abilities take over when
allowed to enter our own home
and the
the evac that we were using by that
point medevac was a five ton
you know it's like so that's where you
earn you in the back of a five ton yeah
that's a comfortable yeah
it's like riding on a brick with wheels
yeah
so there's that like the litter stretch
between those two benches
yeah that was it was misery and then
some start major had this you know
bright idea he was gonna he would you
know too many guys were rolling over i
guess i never heard of a single person
rolling over uh i mean maybe they did
but anyway he put speed bumps
all the way then you know so it was like
speed bumps all the way to the damn uh
charlie men each one of those freaking
personally built for brexit
sometimes i wonder if any of those guys
ever read some of this late these kind
of books that come out later on you know
and just think man maybe that was stupid
i remember well when i first got to
baghdad this is like 2003
and there are all these potholes on like
the road around the base
and like deep potholes are kind of
jacked up and then they filled in all
the potholes
and then they built speed bumps in no
way i was like bro you you had it and
then you filled it in
and now you're building speed bumps come
on man
um
yeah
going back to the book i began to pass
in and out of consciousness so
frequently that i was having a hard time
telling the difference between reality
and whatever dream world i was off to in
between
once they carried me the medical
facility they realized there was an
another problem it was already filled
with wounded iraqi men and one side of
charlie med
we went
one in one side of charlie med and right
out the other
down the road a little ways another aid
station which belonged to our brigades
engineers so we headed there once inside
the first thing they did was was only
start transfusing blood in the beginning
they only had lines containing a quart
or so a piece into each arm but
eventually i had to stick an iv into my
jugular and start pumping in fluid that
way damn yeah they put a pick in
after establishing a steady stream of
flesh fresh blood into me
they fixed as many bandages as they
could and rushed me out to the plz to
board a medevac flight containing
several other wounded people bound for
balad
while in route to balad the flight crew
decided that because some of us had lost
so much blood in emergency landing and
fallujah was necessary to save our lives
mine included
i was passing in and out of
consciousness again my grip of reality
if you could call it that anymore was so
slippery that it was like i was that was
like trying to squeeze a wet fish the
harder i tried the worse it became the
darkness that awaited me each time i
passed out was becoming more and more
welcoming
i was exhausted
all i wanted to do was sleep
to put it into a sentence i was starting
to give up
[Music]
what will death be like
everyone always talks about a white
light near the end of a tunnel but i am
not seeing [__]
yeah man then it was cold too
this is january i know like it's ramadi
but it's still cold it's like 65 or
something and one's been 120 for eight
months 65 feels cold as hell you know
and then you run out of blood so you're
just even colder
it was
at that point i was i was pretty close
to just saying health that you know
whatever that means i don't i don't know
if you really have control of that or
not but
i think i do have some level of control
of it i mean i've heard plenty of
stories of people that had that will to
survive and are able to stay alive and
you know you know what i actually think
of that the most is hearing stories from
guys that were in prison of war camps
and the difference between someone that
lives and someone that dies it's like
this person was just like i'm gonna make
it and this other person said i'm not
so i think there's definitely something
to that
um
you get here where guys are braxton
braxton stay with us i know it hurts but
we've got to stretch your legs out again
or you're going to lose them
okay i'm owned then i passed out again
blunt stained tears running down both
cheeks i'm not sure how long i was out
for and i was not fully awake but the
next thing i distinctly remember was the
sound of my flesh tearing under a
scalpel scalpel
the surgeons were slicing the side of
each quadricep to relieve my compartment
syndrome blood and pus practically
spewed out of my swollen legs split wide
open i will never forget the way that
cutting sounded inside my head it was
reminiscent of a muddy zipper being
forced open
some things stick with you forever
hearing your own flesh being cut apart
is one of them
yeah that [__] sucked man and it's it's
knee to hip on both sides like pointing
the knee all the way up to the point of
my hip
and they split and then they
once they got me in that traction splint
then they put in these wound vacs it's
like a big sponge
uh and then they wrap it so it's like a
big spongy looking thing and it's got a
vac set up across the back that like
pulls the [__] out of the sponge
so i think this is the way it works is
the sponge sucks up the you know
moisture whether it's or you know the
liquid whichever liquid it is plus
internal like water from your i don't
know what that is blood and all that
and then the vacuum sucks out of the
sponge i think so they cut you open and
then they slip that in to the wound and
it's like it's like this big you know as
far as width wise
and then they just they put like a
plastic thing over it and then just pump
that
yeah you got some pictures on your
website of like your legs splayed open
like that it does not look
doesn't even look survivable i mean how
much they cut you open it's freaking
crazy it was
crazy yeah
i'm just wild i
my i.t bands are still
like you know your your i.t bands are
like supposed to be one band right and i
got like two of them or four of them i
guess
because
yeah
what did they like did they cut the it
band open or do they down just stretch
open no they had to cut through it to
get to the to be able to get that wound
back in there at least that's my
understanding of it you can stick your
finger through it like you
come all the way to muscle
yeah it was it was nuts man
and you were conscious during this yeah
well no we weren't doing any morphine or
anything by then i was starting now once
they got me stable then they could start
hitting me with stuff but in ramadi they
weren't going to give me anything
because my blood pressure was super low
and i just didn't want to you know zonk
me which i think is probably a good idea
i'm glad to be here
yeah we'll take it uh whatever call got
made apparently it was the right one
yeah and i so you know i think probably
what happened is i had been another
thing is i'd been
i don't know if gronsky's talked about
this but they had i was one of the last
people getting evac because they just
it was just a wreck
and they had a bunch of iraqis
that were already in charlemagne by the
time they got me there and stuff so they
just screwed up
the triage
um so i think probably the call was made
because i had been quite a while before
they got me in there so they were like
well if he's
you know making up like one i'm just
like why risk it now he's made it this
long without it you know and so then
they they i'm sure they hit me with it
in fallujah because i don't really
remember fallujah to baghdad or i mean
blood hardly at all
and all this i'm still pretty hazy you
know
yeah you say i was put and wrote in
route to the big air force base hospital
in bilad i guess i'm still alive i
thought the question became a common
theme throughout the following hours and
days
um and like you said you know you write
about in the book you're you can hear
doctors talking but you're like
partially coherent you're tired you
you're just like in and out of sleep um
for a while
that's pretty much your memory of balad
is just you know in and out of
consciousness little bits and pieces
you say awoke to loud rumbling of an
airplane engine i was being pushed
across an airstrip towards a c-130
medevac flight headed for
launch duel germany
fast forward a little bit i had to read
this part because it sounds freaking
horrifying later i woke up choking in
sheer terror i felt like i was drowning
but how instinctively i tried to turn my
head to one side to get a breath but i
couldn't because it was so tightly
fastened to this bed i wiggled as much
as i could gagging hacking trying
desperately to dry or still unsure of
what was happening left and right i
moved my head only managing a centimeter
or less in either direction i groaned
for help still too tightly restrained to
move help i screamed inside my head i
desperately needed to breathe i couldn't
hold my breath much longer yes you can
toughen up my thoughts ran wild help i
gurgled aloud this time it was
completely unintelligible because my
mouth and nose were filled with water
fear turned into anger
inside my head i had screamed a series
of idle senseless threats and cuss words
suddenly
i felt the strap loosen my head shifted
to one side as soon as i felt cleared i
coughed and hacked out all the fluids
that were lodged in my throat
i was still in a daze but at least i
could breathe i gasped for air and
muttered thank you to the nurse who had
just saved my life
inside my head i was calling this flight
and all the unwounded people on it every
combination of curse words i could dream
up
yeah i
i i think i probably threw up
you know while you're
and that just woke you up as you
probably drowned in your own vomit yeah
like probably like i thought about this
later on and that's probably what
happened
and you know they strap your head to
that that litter
so you can't move and then being on
drugs and in the air
and she's who knows how many you know
people she's attending to i mean i can't
see [__] except for the roof of the
aircraft you know and you're all drugged
up so you're barely even coherent anyway
and
yeah i was not that's scary how old are
you are you 20 yet turned 20 over there
yeah turned 20. i turned 21 back home
and you had gotten married when was like
did you go home on leave and get married
yeah i did yeah
oh man
that's um
always a tough
but
understandable call that soldiers can
make from time to time
everybody in the whole world tells you
not to do it
but you're like oh man i know what i'm
doing yeah
of course
i have personally given that advice to
many many young men over the years and
have almost never been listened to
uh so was it you went for you went home
for two weeks to leave
during deployment yeah and that's when
you got married yeah
um world series and the deer hunt
check
later on a surgeon came and told me that
they had planned on trying to put rods
in my femurs while i was in surgery
there so now you're in germany but the
doctors thought it would be best to wait
for the infection to clear up he
explained as i lifted as he lifted the
sheets and showed me my legs for the
first time since i left iraq that they
had instead placed external fixators on
each one of them these metal cages were
implanted just to get me stable enough
to be flown back to walter reed army
medical center in washington dc he told
me i was headed there that night
so they put these freaking external
fixators on your legs to try and let
them heal up mower before they would
eventually put internal rods inside your
legs they're trying to get the bacteria
out
uh it's there was uh some bacteria that
they had discovered that guys were
coming home with from the sand in iraq
some
freaking bacteria yeah so when you yeah
when you get to walter reed if you have
that they put a blue
like a blue label on your door or
whatever
so they can't put a a rod in your
femurs while you have an infection
because it could it risks introducing
the infection to the inside of your
femur and then you're really in trouble
so
they had to get that cleared out and
then they could get rods and end up
taking like a month or something to
get everything
oh sorry really quick and the way that
those things work is it's like the
external fixators yeah it's like a big
cage like you're saying almost like a
series of halos
but then those halos have a
uh like rods that come out of them and
those rods have screws like drill bit
screws or drill screws wood screws on
the end looking thing more like machine
heads or screws and those are screwed
into your bone and to keep your bones
stable and then they go back out through
that halo and they bolt into the halo so
it's like that thing's actually screwed
to your bone yeah
i had a friend of the family
little girl she was probably nine years
old and she broke her femur she had an
external fixator on her femur
you don't even think if
you don't think that seems like a good
idea right like if you're a if you
didn't know anything about medicine
which i don't and you told me hey what
we're gonna do is we're gonna screw rods
through the skin into the bone
and have a whole contraption on the
outside you'd be like you're an idiot
yeah
it doesn't make any sense it's true yeah
like it's crazy it's a crazy idea you'd
think you'd just it'd be infected yeah
yeah that's freaking crazy um
this is you you go into talking about
little like what's going through your
head at this point i'm going to fast
forward a little bit this feeling of
helplessness and confusion lasted in
varying degrees for days if not weeks
during this period i had surgery nearly
every morning to clean and irrigate my
wounds and change the bandage that
swathed my body
from what i un from what i understand
the doctors had to put me under for
these daily hygiene sessions because the
sheer number of open wounds and their
depth made scrubbing too intrusive and
time consuming to do while i was awake
i had a dozen or more wound channels
which were through and through the term
used to describe a wound that starts on
one side of the body and passes through
its other side exiting entirely usually
on a limb i i also usually on a limb i
also had dozens more wounds caused by
projectiles which had penetrated my
flesh but it stopped in something more
dense like bone or thick muscle
what do you think they this this uh
s vest was just like filled with ball
bearings or something and that's what
you got shredded with man i'm packing
like
eight or ten of them still how big are
they
uh are they all the same size yeah so
it's like a uniformed kind of
professionally built s vest
well
so we found some before where
they were just filling up water bottles
with wheel bearings
so and then just taping those that those
water bottles to the front of the
explosive so i guess like professional
yeah trained by the iranians i think
probably
yeah i got one in my ass that really
messes with me when i'm riding horses
sometimes
like try to get them to cut it out but
it's
like too deep i guess
um
you say this i spent the next few weeks
in the same bed lying around and
thinking about what my new life was
going to be
when if i got out of the hospital
when i was not caught up daydreaming
about what my long-term recovery was
going to look like my mind was on my
brother's back in ramadi i knew the
morale crushing war that they were
living every day and i had begun to feel
an enormous amount of guilt at the
thought of them facing those trials
without me
the thought was only made worse when i
considered that they were doing it while
i lay safely in a bed back in the states
i felt grief as i think anyone would for
the memories of lives lost and my role
actively or passively in their deaths i
also felt guilty for being the one
for being one of the people who survived
i could have should have done more i
often thought
by this point the story in my mind had
cleared through to recall
the scene at the glass factory in detail
i remembered seeing sergeant can and
bruno confronting the suicide bomber i
remembered z telling me that he had to
go check on the marine who was injured
worse than i was i remembered almost
everything from that morning including
the courageous action bruno and sergeant
can had taken yet somehow ridiculously
and unfairly to sergeant kan's heroic
memory
i had saddled myself with the guilt of
his death
it was not in any way my fault that he
had chosen to give his life trying to
protect the marines and soldiers around
him but that was but that is much easier
to right now with the rationale of
hindsight than it was to convince myself
of it in the hospital bed
that's like the
the the
they interview all these wounded
soldiers you know and they also just
want to get back to my unit just want to
get back to my unit just want to get
back to my unit
um
did as you so as time went on your
memory of what happened did it become
more clear
uh
as far as the suicide bombing i i don't
think not really
it's hard it's hard to it's really hard
to know because i i got into psychology
for a minute and now i know that your
bot your brain often like rewrites
stories backward or backfills you know
so
i
i don't know
it's like it's one of those questions it
seems really easy to answer but if
you're
you know if you're being honest with
yourself about the way the human brain
works you really it's really not that
easy of a question to answer you know
because you do backfill
uh do you backfill with
memories that are subconsciously there
you backfill with like sort of what you
assemble
from what you can kind of put together
logically as to what happened yeah it
could be that and then also talking to
your friends and hearing their version
of stuff over time
uh and then maybe your brain just fills
in gaps and i got i don't really know no
that's that i actually do
we i did a podcast about that the way
you're
the way you can hear part of a story and
part of a story and your mind will
fill in the gaps they will fill in the
gaps with things they'll kind of just
figure it out and take the best guess
and then you'll kind of you can very
easily believe oh this is what happened
this is what i saw yeah and
you know i can't say that didn't happen
because there's no way for me to know
but
i feel like i don't
i don't i don't know that it really ever
changed i know that um
you know i talked to johnny he's
before we ever put this out and he's
like yeah man that's how i remember
you know sans this or that detail
the one detail i know that i absolutely
did lose was a friend of mine casey was
out there and i don't even remember him
being there we were just driving to
texas through a long-range course the
other day well a couple months ago and
he was like dude i was there i was like
well i knew you were there later he's
like no man i got you quick it's like
he's like i was to you in like minutes
you know and i don't remember any of
that so i know there's got to be
problems you know with my memory oh yeah
well it's also everybody's memory you
know there's
everybody's memory is different from
witnessing the same things i know
you know leif and i have memories of
things that we did where he literally
remembers something and i literally
remember something else
and we were both there and our viewpoint
and there's no reason it's not like
there's no reason we should remember
different things but we just do yeah um
people just have a different perspective
of what's going on and that locks into
their memory
yeah
and then you can only store so much [__]
and true that freaking hard drive gets
filled up yeah
so if you do a whole bunch of dumb [__]
when you're young man you're gonna be
you're gonna suck it like this stage of
your life you're gonna lose all the good
stuff
uh
fast forward a little bit you got
surgeries you got doctors you got
psychologists uh physical therapists
just lots of things going on and again
i'm fast forwarding through it not
because it's not a really interesting
read
because there's all kinds of i was
learning all kinds of things and
and
you know the the story itself is just
it's an awesome i hate to use the word
awesome idiot i don't know what other
word to use it's a very well told story
uh so get the book i'm gonna fast
forward a little bit to where
you say these new training aids or
you're doing this physical therapy your
these new training aids were useful and
they did help me pass the time but at
this stage in my recovery the only lofty
goal i had left to look forward to was
getting ex getting the external fixators
removed and moving into a wheelchair not
more than a month before i had been a
young man a warrior in his prime
now i lay in bed doing my level best to
avoid sleep and my grandest physical
aspirations were to have the cages
removed from my legs and be fitted for a
wheelchair
20 years old
yeah and because like my hand was messed
up i only had one hand that way my left
humerus was broken so i had like a
plastic
they didn't cast it because they wanted
to leave me with a limb that would was
like still functional so i'd like a
spiral fracture here and they just put
like a plastic
almost like
i don't almost like the stuff motocross
guys wear you know it's like didn't
really i don't know that really did
anything but other than like remind you
your [__] was broken i
don't know what it was doing
but so the
the what was the occupational ot or
occupational therapy they they bring
like these tools and you learn how to
like
pull a sock over this
kind of conical shape thing and it's got
a couple of strings hooked to it and
throw that [__] at your foot and so you
can pull like your own sock on and get
started or
yeah they'd bring like this
kind of
conical shape deal with buttons on it
and zippers and try to learn how to
manipulate stuff with one hand
and i don't know if they were doing that
to prep me because they weren't sure how
much my hand would ever work again that
i mean that could honestly be possible
but
i don't know so i'm saying i don't know
if it's routine i don't know if
everybody does this but they brought me
all these aids that i was
you know try
trying to learn how to do [__] with one
hand which
anyway that was like how i was passing
my time that and watching like dukes of
hazzard on a dvd thing and seinfeld and
[__] by the by the time you were aware
of what was going on were you was it
seemed like pretty solid that you were
going to keep both your legs oh yeah it
did
for sure by that point yeah
going back to the book here fast forward
a little bit i laid in bed for the next
few days a little more beaten down than
i was before i raised the sheets now and
then with my left arm my only limb that
sort of functioned and wondered whether
this was finally going to be the thing
that took my legs from me i was
physically tough and was tolerating pain
but the rollercoaster of emotions
and the all-around uncertainty
surrounding my life was starting to get
me down i was nearing that breaking
point again i spent most of my time just
watching the yellow green pus ooze out
of my thighs
they look like swiss cheese that had
been aged way too long and the smell
radiated throughout the room this was a
gnarly infection that you had
yeah getting green
that was that was like my third
infection too
and i don't know if you're like i'm not
trying to throw wall to read under the
bus but right around that time was when
cnn did that
uh
that or maybe it was right after that
when cnn did that uh
like an expose
deal
um and i remember some perhaps
unsanitary stuff but you know the wall
three was like loaded with people at
that point there were a crapload of
dudes there so like i don't want to you
know i'm not trying to throw anybody
under the bus but there was definitely
some stuff
that was not being like there's too much
infection going around to not be having
some procedure
something's being screwed up here yeah
so
um
but they reschedule the surgery um
they get done they take off the fixators
and then they put rods inside your
femurs
remove the freaking
spongy vacuum machine things no
let the wounds close um hundreds of
stitches you say staples
and and you had been in bed at this
point that you so long that you had a
bed source yeah like gnarly bed sores
yeah they're still scarred god
you know
and when they put those rods in they
uh because of the way the brakes were
on my right leg
i think they called it a retrograde nail
but they went they flip your kneecap
over and come up through the bottom and
then it screws up into your hip but on
my left leg they put a rog and a rod
excuse me in my left hip as well
so they put that rod through the hip
into the femoral head and then it has
like an eyelet at the top and then they
put the other rod through that eyelet so
it's like tied together and then that
one screws down into your the head of
your femur on the bottom head i don't
know what the proper i felt anatomy but
it
down here so they went both directions
so it's kind of
like
like my hip sucks and my right knee
sucks like at this point you know so
they gave me everything they gave you
one of each yeah one they went from the
bottom one they went from the top down
yeah
yep but they didn't put a rod in my my
right hip because it wasn't broke as bad
so
um
at one point your uncle
justin comes to visit you uh
and you call him judy that's his
nickname
he says to you uh one of the days he was
there he discovered some information
that had been kept from me hey bro i
need to tell you something okay i said
expecting the worst
colonel mack died
nobody wanted to tell you because they
were not sure how you you were
whether you were healthy enough to hear
that how
he was killed by shrapnel from the
suicide bomber that hit you
oh thanks for telling me i said slightly
in shock it was particularly devastating
news i already knew that sergeant can
have passed away but colonel max seemed
impossible
but he he was way too far away to have
been struck by any significant amount of
shrapnel i thought
as it happened he had been quite a ways
away and he had only been hit by a few
pieces of shrapnel but those ball
bearings had hit him in the back of the
head killing him virtually instantly
survival in war is random i have learned
yeah
yeah that won't tripped me out man
he was he just seemed like long ways
away like 70 yards or 50 i mean it
seemed like a long ways i don't know how
far it actually was but
it seemed far
and you know i was a 20 year old kid
trying to really have [__] to lose you
know and he had three kids at home
probably probably like the age i am now
is probably how old he was then you know
i think back at stuff like that and i
don't know if i'd had that kind of sand
at this age
you know with all that to put that much
on the line especially when
you know you're a light colonel or
you're the lieutenant colonel out there
with a bunch of e4 z5z and the highest
ranking
is the e6
i mean
that's quite a gap yeah
um yeah no i even when i got there
because i got there this was in january
i got there in april and people talked
about him
like totally revered him as a leader and
what he was doing and what he's making
work and the effort that he was putting
forth i mean he just was everybody
revered the guy
um
you say learning of the death of colonel
mack was another psychological set back
in time rife
with them
my bout with survivor's guilt was
getting more aggressive by the day i was
still having serious trouble sleeping
and my overall emotional well-being
while awake was so fragile
that even i was beginning to recognize
it
this was roughly the time i began to use
physical recovery as a distraction from
mental anguish
i have often heard the phrase fake it
till you make it i'm not exactly sure
where it originated but i was about to
take my term at the strategy and would
do so for years to come flagrantly
unsuccessfully
um
yeah i think that fake it to make it
[__] it's [__]
it's complete [__] man
you gotta fix your foundation you know
that's the problem you can't just fake
[__] yeah you gotta go all the way to
the root and start working there yeah
yeah i think you know when someone's
talking about going to do some job
somewhere
they think they can fake it till you
make and it's the same thing i said
earlier i wrote about this in leadership
tragedy tactics if you don't know
something
and you're trying to fake it everybody
can see it
like even from a leadership perspective
it doesn't work but then when you start
trying to put together your
your psychological well-being by faking
it it's not going to work out good right
it's not going to work out good
um
the
physical therapy you got this guy you're
working with named solomon
um i'm fast forwarding now you're you're
starting to you know you're starting to
heal up a little bit
uh hey man when do i get to walk down
those bars my remark was said purely
ingest because i'd already been told
several times it would be 18 months if
ever before i was going to be able to
walk again
you're going to use them right now he
said obviously seeing through my lame
bravado i can't walk solomon
i said coley coldly yes you can i'm
gonna help you i was starting to get
irritated at him because i knew i could
not walk i can't even stand for hell's
sake i was frustrated and embarrassed by
the whole situation i was frustrated
because i thought that this guy i liked
and admired assumed i was capable of
more than i actually was and i was about
to let him down
does he not know how badly injured i am
i wondered i was embarrassed that i
couldn't dress myself embarrassed that
even if i could have i could not wear
clothes that were not several sizes too
big because they had to fit over my
casts and braces i was embarrassed by
the fact that i could not do up a button
on my own underwear or use the bathroom
without help throughout the entire
process i was literally unable to wipe
my own ass as they say
little more than a month before this
moment i had been a roughly six foot
tall 190 pound warrior in the prime of
his life proud and full of all the
arrogance of youth
but there i was a few months later
sitting before a man who wanted to help
me deeply wanted to help me but i just
physically could not do what he was
asking
then there was the fear fear that if by
some miracle of the imagination i was
able to stand up and try to walk i might
fall
and if i fell i would surely lose all
the independence that i had fought so
hard to achieve it felt like an exercise
in futility to even speculate about what
it would be like to walk again already
then saul loosened the braces on my
chair bent down in front of me and said
are you ready
i reached out put what i could of my
arms on his shoulders and lifted and he
lifted me out of the chair my heart
raced as i stood up for the first time a
feeling of anxiety fear and triumph
washed over me though they were hardly
supporting any body weight my legs
shivered beneath me then we started
walking we only covered a few feet
distance but i could hardly contain my
joy as saul half dragged me over to
those parallel bars
the instant the cold stainless steel
touched the fingertips of my left hand
an invigorating dose of adrenaline shot
through my body even though solomon was
bearing most of my weight i had to
overcome an obstacle i had not at all
anticipated
i don't know if it was because of my
brain injury or just because it had been
so long since i had last walked but i
couldn't make my muscles move my legs
like they were supposed to i knew how
walking was supposed to be done you just
lift up and step out
in front of your lead foot then repeat
on the other side
i could have drawn you a picture or
describe what walking is supposed to
look like i knew how to do it but i
didn't know how to make me do it
each confusing attempt at the process
sent intense bursts of pain to my brain
that i was quite that i was not quite
ready for but the torment mixed with the
excitement of discovery kept releasing
more of that ever intoxicating
adrenaline
that's gotta be freaking weird when you
was weird you but like your body doesn't
know what to do it was it was weird i i
still don't know how to really describe
about how that fell it is weird and yet
you have a guy like solomon there who i
still to this day admire he was he was a
really freaking neat guy i'm sure he's
still alive but you know that out of my
life because thank god i'm not still
there in the hospital but
um
yeah and you got a guy like that with
you that you really care for and yeah or
uh respect or whatever you want to
do as good as you can and and you know
your body's just like not not working it
it's almost
it's almost like you know when you put a
limb to sleep sitting on something yeah
but like do it bad not just kind of a
little bit of sleep but
like fall down kind of asleep yeah i've
done that before i was like i'm gonna
fall down exactly that's kind of how it
was like i knew it was supposed to work
i just couldn't or you know you could
feel i don't that's the best i can
describe this was if it was something
like that and the muscles are not firing
properly
and then the
my right quad had a real good hole
through it and
that one
even my physical therapist that i got
later on as a civilian was not quite
sure if that femoral or excuse me uh
which head is that anyway if if the
actual head of that part of the quad
would ever fire again because it was
just not
like the muscles were not going around
the way they should have that it does
kind of now but
so there could have been like some
muscular damage involved too i mean
there was much fewer damage wall but
that could have been part of it too
i don't know
wow freaking crazy um
it's hard and you know that it's not
like uh
you're you're making progress but the
progress is so slow that you still feel
like you don't even know if how how much
you're gonna be able to heal
and at one point you're talking to your
cousin
judy again and you say uh
you say judy i meant i might never walk
again and if i do i'll probably be
assisted in some way i don't want to
push around a walker for the rest of my
life i can't help hunt elk on a cane
i'll never feel that icy mountain water
roll past my waders as i cast
flies at fall browns i'll only have
memories of sliding into a saddle on a
crisp october morning when at dawn you
can see your breath and by noon you're
you've swept through your hat band
i've done my last bow hunt no more dirt
bikes or bull rides
i basically just started up my twilight
years in my early 20s
i'm in a [__] nursing home for
soldiers right now and i may always be
i was being a negative whiny child there
was no doubt about it but i was trying
to explain to him everything that made
me me was gone
those were not just activities that i
liked to do that was my identity i
hunted fished cowboyed and soldiered
those were my essence if i was too
broken to do those things that
distinguished me then i was too broken
to live as far as i was concerned
yeah
just everything you like to do
yeah i think i think you may do never do
it again yeah i think a lot of guys go
through that
and even i think some
you like you look at guys when they're
getting ready to retire from mma
you know they feel like everything's i
mean maybe not in the same circumstances
there are some guys that are in similar
circumstances with their brains but
you know maybe not exactly the same kind
of circumstance but they're going
through a similar like period yeah like
everything that they are is in some
sense being taken away from them because
father time is undefeated right
it's a similar
you know i think it's similar and so i
i'm definitely not alone in having
experienced these sorts of feelings but
it's a it's a really weird place to find
yourself in for sure yeah and i think
the fact that you're 20 at the time you
know at least an mma fighter that's
retiring or can't fight anymore and he's
37 33 whatever
you know that's that's a different deal
um
this is a real important conversation
that you have here
fast forward a little bit a member of
the surgical team which monitored my
progress walked in near the tail end of
this conversation he was just there to
do routine checkups and to introduce
himself he was a young guy who seemed
very well put together in high speed i
ch he checked my limbs one by one for
circulation and feeling
judy put a question to him hey doc
braxton has been told that he may never
walk again he thinks he is never going
to be able to stand in a river to fly
fish or hunt or hike or ride horses
again can you talk to him
i concentrated on him hoping to read his
expressions for tells of lies
he proceeded to give me all the reasons
why i may be able to do those things
again he covered every angle including
some caveats such as i may have to use a
cane to hike or limit the distance that
i traveled and only fish shallow holes
etc
but
he was telling the truth
then at the end of his answer he said
the most important thing i have ever
been told either before or since
braxton
i think you can walk again but you are
going to have to do it soon
you have too much soft tissue damage to
risk allowing your muscles to atrophy
any further
if you don't start now you may never
walk again at least without the use of a
cane or a walker
even in everyday activities
it is all up to you
it is all up to you i repeated
it's all up to me even in a situation
like this one my body may have been
badly bruised but it's one spirit that
determines the outcome of a tragedy not
a doctor's prognosis that was exactly
what i needed to hear in that moment i
needed decisive language and a kick in
the ass not some sugar-coated version of
what may or may not happen there was
probably not anything that young surgeon
said which would which i had not been
told before
but i'd never heard that truth until
right then the words he said the order
he chose to use and the conviction with
which he said them were as perfect for
me as if the universe had handcrafted
that message
it's on you
i can see how you know when someone when
someone says well you know you could you
know it could happen
you know you could walk again or yeah
you might be able to do this and it's
almost like people are inviting you just
to leave it up to fate yeah
well it's almost like they're they're
trying not to tell you that it's not
possible you know like almost like how
women will sometimes do with their kids
you know like oh yeah you you're great
you draw great that's beautiful
man we might send you to art school you
know it's kind of like that kind of uh
it feels like that a little bit
especially coming from a primary care of
a surgeon or something yeah yeah you
probably can do this because there you
know that they're pushing it off on to
the next guy they're pushing down the
timeline you know so when you get a guy
that's like nah man you can do it if you
want to do it you can do it you know
just figure it out
it's really
which is the truth i mean
it's true of virtually everything in
life you know i mean if you're
if your spinal cord severed
you know you're in a different
circumstance you know but if it's not
you can probably get out of that
whatever the circumstance you know
whatever that health situation is you
can probably change
so
at this point i'm gonna fast forward a
little bit you're still you're still not
it's not fast forward and that far
but you go
to arlington cemetery
and and you're not really truly walking
yet
um but you go there
and you decide you're gonna you're gonna
walk
you say my my legs trembled underneath
me i saw another sign that read simply
silence and respect
my arm shook as i pressed into my canes
to grind myself forward another step it
felt like my bones were going to explode
under the force of my body each time i
transitioned my weight
we trot on slowly
we made our way by the rows and rows of
heroes sacrificed on the altar of
freedom at a snail's pace but with the
same determination they had brought into
combat
i was either going to walk the entire
way or die trying
i don't know how far we walked that
morning exactly but it was at least a
mile from the gate to section 60 and i
had trekked every step of it
my arms ached and shook as my quadriceps
just quivered their way through the
steps
the rest periods between legs of the
journey grew longer as we went along but
i never went back to that wheelchair
when we reached the sign that said
section 60 i did not want to stop
anymore
braxton you should probably take a break
here don't overdo it no i'm okay i
responded the sweat pouring from my face
when we were inside section 60's brown
boundaries it must have taken us another
hour to reach
sergeant cann's graveside
along with the slow pace we traveled due
to my fatigue the weak and the weakening
pain threshold i read nearly every
headstone i walked by on the way each
one adding more time and new
significance to the journey
but also giving me a little more fuel to
feed the desire remit the desire to
remain erect
every step made me miserable
pain radiated from my hips to my knees
the agony had grown so immense that
several times i thought that i might
throw up because of it but we never gave
up
i trudged every torturous pace of that
march out of respect for sergeant can
and the 250 000 fallen warriors he lay
with
when we finally reached his graveside
and read
adam lee can
sergeant united states marine corps
january 25th 1982
january
5th 2006
bsm
with the purple heart operation iraqi
freedom
i lowered myself to a knee and wept
not because of the pain i was
experiencing but because i had the nerve
the flat out audacity to complain about
it
these hundreds of thousands of heroes
had given their lives to provide me with
a safe place to recover and all i'd
thought about
up to that point
was how hard my time had
been whatever i'd given in service to my
country and my brothers paled in
comparison to what they had done
who was i to feel so sorry for myself
who was i to complain about my situation
i was above ground
there was not a soul laid to rest in
that holy shrine who would not have
gladly taken my place if they could have
it became clear to me in that moment
that i really did have nothing to
complain about
and every time i did complain it should
be seen as a slap in the face
to far better men than i will ever be
when i had finished fang paying my final
respects to sergeant kan and the men
immediately surrounding him i stood up
on both canes and began my long walk out
of the cemetery
a brand new sense of urgency to recover
a new found pool of motivation to draw
from i was going to beat this thing i
was going to fight to take my life back
again not just because i wanted to
but because i had to
because they couldn't
now
that pledge
was not an easy uh not an easy pledge to
take not an easy pledge to keep
no
um
even coming back from that i mean you
you you know you're you started swelling
up everything started swelling up from
doing that long walk um
later on you say oddly enough just
sitting there trying to knead the pain
from my legs did help ease the
frustration a bit i stopped thinking
about the things i couldn't do like open
a cab door on my own and started
thinking about what i just accomplished
walking some real distances distances no
doctor who had operated on me had ever
imagined possible how did i do that i
wondered
it took me years to get to the bottom of
that question
the truth is that the only reason i had
walked that far in that condition was
because i had read a sign that reminded
me that arlington was not about me
i didn't care enough about myself or my
future to grind through that kind of
torment
self-gratification
nor self-improvement was enough to
motivate me my own ego was nowhere near
big enough to carry me through that
i had done it because i did not want to
dis disrespect sergeant can or any of
the rest who had given their lives at
war
i made that journey because i had a
reason bigger than myself
i needed to cling to that maxim
when i read that and that's one of the
one of the points in this book when i
when i'm talking about these sort of
internal thoughts that you've had and
things that you figured out along the
way
i i was thinking about the fact that
oftentimes
we don't mind letting ourselves down but
we just wouldn't want to let down our
friends our teammates i mean i know for
a fact
in the military and the seal teams the
worst possible thing you want to have
happen you know look if you disappoint
yourself okay that's bad that sucks but
you don't want to let down your
teammates
and to me
that you know you said it took you years
to get to the bottom of that question
and that helped me get to the bottom of
that question
of how what is it that these guys will
do anything for their friends
they'll do anything for their friends
they'll take better care of their
friends
than they will
of themselves
which is which is a a crazy thought i
mean i know you uh you listen to some
jordan peterson and read some jordan
peterson and one of the things that he
says is well it's like treat yourself as
if you were someone that you would want
to take care
of it's a similar thought oh yeah it is
and i guess i i'm probably where i got
it and just hadn't ever put the two
together actually yeah
yeah i think it's it's also true like
anytime you're doing anything hard
like if you're ready to quit
if you can find something
you you know like find some other reason
it'll put like your ego is just only so
big and it's also really easy to be like
man no one's even gonna know i quit
right now rationalize
and no no one knows that bull's-eye down
there i'm the only one that knows that
pulls in that canyon you know no one's
gonna know if i don't hike down there
you just gotta find something to force
you you know
like for me it's like i gotta go home
and tell my buddy that i pulled that
bull out of that canyon you know like
it's like you gotta talk [__] to my
buddies too you know like just as much
as you love them it's like it's kind of
like that give and take of the
relationship yeah on both ends
yeah that was a that that was a moving
uh
section of this book man
that whole section was uh rough to read
um
and those canes are the ones with the
four ends on them you know not like a
regular
cane i ended up getting regular canes
later from walter reed but
those were the different kind and so it
gave me like a little bit more stability
i think on a regular can that probably
fell a few times for sure
um
and you know that road is it's like a
good good road and everything so it's
like the walking wasn't that bad just
it's pretty busted up and
and yeah and i had never
i'd never been to arlington before i'd
never seen it and
there really is
i don't know if spiritual is the right
word or what but it really conveys some
sense of reverence especially once you
get into the actual grounds you know the
the the tour center is one thing but the
you know once you actually get in there
it's a very powerful moving place
and then you start to realize like every
one of these stones is an actual person
not just like a picture you saw in a
movie or something you know it's like
here's his name and in many cases here's
his wife on the other side right
you just see like generations of
dudes who've died you know and and and
women too now and
yeah it's
it's it's really it's one of those
places in the world where or in this
country where
you just have to go experience it
and there's really no i don't think
anyone can write powerfully enough to
explain
what it's really like there
yeah and i think um
you know when you know guys
when you know guys that are buried there
and you can kind of relate
relate that individual when you look at
all those graves
you just you know that every one of
those
is
like you said a person it's like that's
a that's a mother a father a son a
daughter it's
like like
someone that was known and and i think
it's easy to follow it's easy to just
call a soldier a soldier right and not
remember that that soldier's a person
and i think when you know
when you know
some of those people in those graves
it's easy to expand and connect that uh
personal side to each and every one of
those gravestones
um
[Music]
the the sacrifice isn't just somebody in
a uniform it's a person like i said it's
a
brother a sister a father a son a
daughter a mother and it's
freaking heartbreaking to be in there
um
meanwhile um
as this is going on you still have
um
you know you're still working through
like your
physical issues
and it sounds like your hand was just
like
like i can't when i look at your hand
now when i was reading this
i i didn't think your hand was going to
be in the kind of shape looks pretty
good pretty freaking good to go
when when i read stuff like this large
this is from the book large chunks of
skin were falling away from my hand they
were not thin and dry [__] strips like
those shed from snakes but thick and wet
like scales floating away from a rotten
fish that's washed up into the shallows
i couldn't help but feeling like this
part of my body belonged to a corpse
the visual is bad and ramadi but that
day it looked as if it were dying this
day it looked like the hand was already
dead
like it was foreshadowing all that was
to become of me if i were to succumb to
my wounds
and though i was still doing much better
the fate of my
i was still the fate was still far from
out of the question
i still had an infection in my body
blood clots in my legs an ivc filter
that could break apart at any minute no
one's addressing my brain injury yet
even if i did live through the whole
ordeal i would be doing it with most of
the function without most the function
of my right hand
all that i had ever done in my life
which i had found worth doing whether it
be shooting working weightlifting boxing
wrestling cowboying bull riding or even
war fighting had required not just two
hands but two strong and capable hands
this hand which had once defined me now
looked as if it were gone forever
i had not given it permission to give up
yet
yet there it was
and sat crippled atop my wrist a symbol
of not just what could become of me
but of how little control i had over my
fate the futility of resistance can be
maddening
yeah and it's that's another thing
that's interesting about this book is
you can tell a freak you can tell it's
not a hollywood movie because in a
hollywood movie it's like there's some
point where everything turns and
everything's that good now you know they
write the book with that perfect story
arc and this ain't a perfect story arc
it's like up down up down up down
sometimes the down is way lower than the
up
uh and that's one of the things that
makes it powerful is this freaking
it's like realistic
and it's also makes it powerful because
like every time i rude read something
and i'd be like oh yeah there it is like
i'm i'm like uh brainwashed by hollywood
you know i'm reading it like oh yeah he
went and visited the grave here's the
turnaround and then no
you know we're like oh you know this
happens and we're gonna hit some more of
those but that's life right yeah that's
the real thing yeah there's a couple
even after the book was over that
happened too but
that's that's gonna be in the second
book i guess yeah i don't know
uh
dude what about this one section where
this physical therapist is is
she comes in to bend your finger
yeah she she says hey i'm to bend your
finger and you say don't it's fused yeah
and she says no no it's not we just need
you need to just suck it up
but you're trying to get me to do this
church and steeple thing uh-huh do this
but this finger this knuckle doesn't
move
she's like pulling on it so you're
telling me you're telling her it's fused
it's f it's a funny part of the book
dude how bad did she feel
i i think she felt pretty dumb i was i
was sitting there waiting like for it to
break yeah you know when you got a cyst
when you were kidding your grandpa's go
get the bible and whack it with a hammer
you know i was just waiting for her to
come hit it with a book or something
whatever i can't really feel it worth it
[__] anyway
oh man um
yeah yeah because i my right here in my
wrist is where that median nerve was
transected so i really couldn't feel
this part of my hand like hardly at all
at that time so it wasn't like really
hurting
i mean a little kind of sort of
like
the boy the way you describe it she's
like getting tired she's like she's
getting tired
cranking on your freaking nose oh she's
she was like this big now
yeah and
yeah she was and kind of attractive too
so i was just like hold on like go for
it oh there it is
soccer
you're going to get all kind of sympathy
when that thing
[Laughter]
you end up getting this deal where
they're gonna send you the
community-based healthcare organization
which is which is
you get to go back home basically to
heal up yeah i think they've since ended
the program but
but
it seemed to you at the time
like freaking awesome you didn't have to
be stuck out there at walter reed
anymore you could you could head home
and um because it's so i'm sorry to
catch you off the traditional path that
walter reed is you're inpatient and then
you're an outpatient but you stay on
walter reed campus and like you know
these barracks and stuff and then you're
just doing all of your outpatient work
at walter reed so guys are there for
like two three years sometimes yeah
they're going through all their
outpatient and so the army is like let's
just send them home do outpatient care
at home yeah and that's kind of how the
i mean
i
you were stoked you were stoked to get
the hell out of there hell yeah i
couldn't go back home freaking hate
cities man
get me out of this place
uh you got some again there's so many so
much stuff uh that people got to get the
book for as you're as you're making
progress and as you start driving across
the country and as you know you get a
new car you get in some situations that
are all in here that are
good reading man not always the not
always the most positive thing but it's
at least it's good reading
smartest kid
uh
fast forward a little bit now you're
driving across country or getting home
even in the dark at night the green
agricultural fields of homes seemed to
glow as our headlights shone on the
little mountains in the valley it was
too late to see my family they were all
in bed long before we arrived for most
of our drive i've been communicating
with my two closest friends dan and josh
they had planned to meet us at the house
when we arrived i hope they were still
awake i sent them another message we're
just getting into town
the words welcome home corporal mccoy
were written in big block letters across
a banner that spanned the two rain load
on the or two two lane road at the
northern most end of town at the
southernmost end of town home at last i
belted out through a grin
the steps of my house had been covered
with a homemade wheelchair ramp
engineered by my stepfather my wife went
to the door opened it and carried our
bags inside
another bit of my pride died as i
helplessly watched her do the heavy
lifting
i reached across my body and jerked the
lever which bound the vehicle's door my
right hand was still too weak to perform
the tasks
so of course what's the smart move at
this juncture start drinking with your
friends which is what you do
yeah opioids and every other kind of
thing in there yeah um
you start drinking with your friends
and this is again when i talked about
like one of the things that makes this
book so good
is just the fact that you're just gonna
tell the truth of what you did and how
you did it
and this is one of those things where i
was reading i was like okay
check
um so you're drinking with your friends
literally the first night you're back
and finally someone says you know so
what happened how did you get hit
and you say in the book i started the
story with why the why my team had been
at the glass factory in the first place
i tried to inform them of the political
climate in ambar and how the arguments
at home were shaping the battlefield
over there i gave them as much backstory
as i could hoping to give them enough to
gather a layman's understanding of our
experiences then i got to the to january
5th and the build-up to the explosion
that crippled me and killed our brothers
i had been descriptive and honest up to
that point but for some reason that i
may never fully understand
i started lying i said that i acted in
heroic ways after being wounded by the
suicide bomber when i didn't maybe it
was just the whiskey maybe it was
insecurity maybe it was survivor's guilt
screaming in my head that i could have
should have done more
whatever the motivation was exactly i
will never know but i there i stood in
my kitchen pants down to my ankles
leaning awkwardly on my canes pointing
at the scars covering my limbs and lying
about battlefield heroics i never
exhibited
yeah she makes a cringe still um
but
i is true so
you want to hear my assessment
sure of this situation
i think this is what happens to dudes
you what when you're trying to tell
somebody a story what your goal is
is to make them feel what you felt
and so
if i'm looking at you and i'm telling
you a story and i want to tell you that
like
a mortar
hit
let's say a mortar hit
50 yards away from me
which mortars have hit 50 yards away
from me it's scary yeah and it scares
the [__] out of you it goes bob you're
like whoa and like it can kill you even
50 yards away it can kill you but it
didn't
so if i'm telling you a story and
especially if you're a civilian
i want you to know
i want you to feel what i felt that
freaking explosion scared the [__] out
of me
so when i tell you some of the details
i think there's a tendency to say this
freaking mortar hit five feet from me
and
i'm just trying to let you feel what i
felt in the best way that i can
so
when i'm thinking you know even going
out like
going outside the gate going outside the
wire walking out there trying to capture
what it's like it's hard to convey those
and you want someone to feel it so bad
what you felt
i don't know i think that drives guys
sometimes to say things that maybe
aren't 100 percent
on point they're not 100 true
the spirit of what they say is true but
the
but the facts aren't you know so
i i think that's some of it you know
just when you when you rattle through
the like you're not really sure why you
did it i think part of it is because you
want people to feel at least some of
what you felt
and you know we're not always the best
at
conveying the feelings and especially
when people are looking at you
and you can see that they're not quite
getting it
you know and you go
some you can see the look on some
civilians face that's like 50 meters
away that doesn't sound like a big deal
you know i'm looking at echo right now
he's kind of like 50 meters what are you
kidding me no crosstalk the football
field yeah yeah half the football field
are you kidding me what a joke
um
so that's what that's one of the things
look the cool other other nikken are
sure but when i've talked to guys
um when i've heard stories from guys
where i'm like
um when i'm suspect i usually just take
into account oh they just want me to
feel what they felt they just want me to
feel what they felt and i think that
adds to it a little bit that's a really
interesting perspective i've never
considered yeah
um
and this is what's weird and you this is
what you say the lies and embellishments
i was telling were chipping away at what
was left of my pride even as i spouted
them but really what did i have left to
be proud of
that see that's the other crazy thing is
like you're talking to civilians like
you you don't
you don't need to say like you're like
hey
i got blown up man like that's good
enough of the story as you're gonna get
you know
uh
[Music]
i was a shortened pasty frail and
morally compromised shell of whatever
kind of man i had been once before
pride what pride could be expected of a
man who's forced to urinate in a plastic
bottle next to his bed because he's too
weak to walk to the bathroom at night
so again in your mind you think you got
to build up like yourself but
bro i mean
anybody that's sitting there looking at
you like hey man you obviously freaking
you know got after it
or
in front of it or something
[Laughter]
yeah man i don't know you're right i had
really never considered that yeah you're
right yeah
yeah it's weird when there's civilians
involved too because they literally have
no idea you know yeah like
it's only in your head you know it's
only in your head that you think
maybe you know i need to tell them that
i did this they're they're
bro you went to iraq these people were
sitting around in freaking utah whatever
drinking beers you know
well i i've been you gotta remember too
i've been in the hospital living in my
head 24 hours a day for months at that
point because they can't really talk to
anybody even though they're army nurses
and stuff they're they might as well be
civilians too they never i mean they
just work in hospital i'm not saying
they don't do
power powerful and great things i just
mean so far as like being able to relate
or understand
they can't you know they can't relate
and the
when i was in the neural world at walter
reed the
a kid got a kid not a kid a soldier that
was like my same age got put into a room
next to me that got shot through the
throat in afghanistan and once he got to
where he could talk again at least every
once in a while we'd be able to bull you
know shoot the [__] a little bit but
outside of that and he couldn't talk
you know he was struggling i mean he got
like a 54r i think it was through
his neck but
so yeah so you're also just constantly
living in your own head so maybe when i
was home
like that perspective that you shared
earlier i'd never considered maybe i was
doing exactly that
but to myself you know
i don't know
um
so i'm going to fast forward a little
bit again um
you go to visit your
you go to your mom's house and your
grandma and your granddad are there
and
[Music]
you know you make it in your your
grandma's there she's like glad you made
it home
um
you are you're you know hey where's
grandpa
he's over on the couch she pointed i
popped down beside my childhood hero and
clung as tightly as i could manage his
arms felt weaker than they once had but
not a thing could diminish his
mountainous stature in my eyes we sat
there for a while and embrace
i almost felt like a kid who had fallen
down and scraped his knees i just wanted
to hear him tell me it was going to be
all right i'm so proud of you he
whispered i love you grandpa i'm sorry
tears welled up in my eyes
he told me that he was proud of me just
like i had hoped he would but it didn't
make me feel good i didn't deserve that
accolade and i knew it when he said he
was proud of me he was talking about who
i was as a man not what it accomplished
physically
i knew that
the very night before i had demonstrated
a lowly character why should he be proud
of me he wouldn't be if he had known
that i was the kind of man who lied to
his friends
oh you dummy what the hell are you sorry
for knock it off before i kick you right
in the ass grandpa responded i buried my
head into his once broad and muscular
shoulder trying to hide my shame i don't
know how long i stayed there for but i
would have stayed longer if you'd let me
i spent the better part of a week
building that damn wheelchair ramp but
you didn't even use it my stepdad
quipped
i'm never getting back in that goddamn
chair again i bellowed braxton watch
your mouth mom yelled watch it or i'll
sock you one grandpa joined in
um
fast forward like many other soldiers at
war my my home front had changed
considerably during my absence my
great-grandmother whom i had been very
close to passed away but she had written
a letter while i was in ramadi saying
she expected to go soon her death was
not so unexpected my step-grandpa never
seemed to age a day in his life before i
left for the war but while i was gone he
developed prostate cancer
the chemotherapy aged him dramatically
in just one year but even this was less
jarring than the sight of that
wheelchair everyone's life has an event
horizon my grandfathers had just come
earlier than i anticipated that was all
there was to it
i just wasn't ready for the sight of my
hero the man who raised me when no one
else wanted to crawling into a chair
and that's because he's you know
basically he's now in a wheelchair yeah
and i'd watched him battle his back
injury for
since i was like
14 years old
and he just kept working because he had
to pay for his family you know
and so i knew exactly how he ended up in
that chair so it it kind of hit even
harder you know
um
so the whole reason that you came up the
only reason you were able to come home
was this community-based healthcare
organization uh it's two and a half
hours you had to drive to get there
kind of checking in here corporal mccoy
how the hell are you a deep familiar
voice boomed out from behind the vehicle
i'm rolling along top how you been it
was sergeant it was first sergeant k a
senior nco that i knew well in fact he
had been the guy that approved my
request to volunteer for deployment to
ramadi i've been well cowboy
i want to introduce you to your new
platoon sergeant master sergeant
dillinger
hello sergeant i said extending my hand
he grabbed my hand and proclaimed young
man i expected me to soldier in a
wheelchair you seen him around anywhere
uh yeah well i'm doing my best to stay
out of that damn thing sergeant
he's a grizzly old bastard corporal most
of us around here just call him bulldog
first sergeant k chimed in master
sergeant diliger bulldog was a short
stocky combat veteran of the vietnam war
usually he paced around bit briskly with
a cigarette in his lips looking for
someone's ass to chew he didn't beat
around the bush about anything if he had
a font you were liable to hear it but he
cared about it the men in his platoon he
played no games especially the armies
later on in our relationship when there
was a mandatory formation
upcoming that he didn't think i needed
to drive up for he simply called me on
my phone and asked me where i where i
was and whether i was okay
then he told the commander that i was
accounted for over time i developed a
deep admiration and respect for that man
the kind that no rank or ribbons can
earn he sounds like a character he was
so funny and
and just the best guy he got me my first
job after i
after i got out and he's just a really
good guy i ended up dying
a couple years five years ago six years
ago just lung cancer but he was 70 or so
by then
yeah he was a healthy guy and he was he
was kind of
he was the kind of leader that
expected you to do whatever you were
supposed to do but he would really
shield you from
nonsense that you didn't need to be
involved in you know yeah
you say in the book here uh
corporal i know you've been through a
lot of [__] in the last year i'm old
enough to know what what this [__] is
like i did my time in nam our war wasn't
squawk compared to yours sorry i
interrupted shut the [__] up mccoy cut
me off i've seen plenty of war it's all
the same [__] our wars might have been
different but you did your time in the
[__] you don't owe me any you don't owe
me or anyone else a [__] caveat
understood i nodded what i'm trying to
say is this unit is different this is a
medical holdover company we're not a
line unit but don't get it wrong this is
still the army there's still enough
[__] here to pack
ten five tons i will do my best to make
sure you only eat the [__] you have to
but i swear to god if you [__] with me i
will have your crippled ass on the next
[__] flight to dc understood
roger sergeant i will call your cell
phone anytime i feel like it if i want
to and if you don't answer you better be
dead dying or in the middle of a medical
appointment understood yes sergeant you
call me first thing in the morning i
will know everything i will know about
every medical appointment on your
schedule and if you leave your house for
any reason i don't give a [__] if it's
just to go outside to piss on a tree you
will ask permission first copy roger
sergeant all right now get that pretty
little wife of yours home and let her
relax corporal you're free to go
roger sergeant i'd only made a few steps
when i heard his voice call out again
corporal mccoy yes sergeant
welcome home son glad you made it
thank you sergeant
so there you go man freaking it's
just done stud stud
again
you know that sounds all cool i'm all
happy i'm reading that part i'm like oh
here's the good turning point
uh then you fast forward a little bit i
told myself that my none of my behavior
was an overreaction when taken in
context after all these little bursts of
extra pain may have been slight when
considered on their own but when piled
on top of the constant and never ending
aches i endured they seemed excruciating
i heard every second i was awake and
nighttime brought me no reprieve
when i lay in my bed at whatever time
seemed appropriate that evening i didn't
sleep what's more i never expected to
sleep how could i sleep when i hurt so
much
what have what had i become i was being
weak i had once thought my mental
toughness was as sure as the sun coming
up in the morning but i was broken down
again
before i was wounded i used to claim
that i had never quit in my life and
nothing could make me but i was wrong i
had hit many many breaking points during
recovery
the internal dialogue whirled about my
head in an endless cycle i was being
soft and i knew it but rationalizing the
pain was so damn easy to do
i had made it all i had made all sorts
of excuses over the course the past few
months and although it should have been
the last time i had made such
justifications it wasn't
so
you mentioned in a brief moment um a
little bit ago opioids
scary thing they've been in the news a
bunch
you say on the question of addiction
many of us had little to say to begin
with this is an interesting point
i didn't choose to be addicted i didn't
even understand the degree to which i
was addicted there was no true first
time so to speak i never had the an
opportunity to debate the potential
pitfalls of drugs with a sober mind
the fact is
like with so many other soldiers my
addiction was little more than the
tragic side effect of healing
i left walter reed taking a hundred
taking hundreds of milligrams of
oxycontin a day
one civilian doctor told me that i had
been prescribed dosages in multiples of
what he wrote his terminal cancer
patients i didn't choose that
neither did thousands of others
thousands of other men and women who
found themselves in similar
circumstances
i did however make things much worse
and that can't be hung on anyone but me
this caveat to the story is meant to be
read as a sort of table setting not an
invasion
of personable personal responsibility i
have learned many lessons through my
journey probably the most important of
them being taking ownership of one's
failures is the best way to avoid making
the same mistakes in the future
if there's a way to rationally place
blame on another
or on fate itself that is all the more
reason to look inward for a culprit
because that nave is the only one you
can reliably alter
a little bit of extreme ownership going
on there
yeah
yeah i i took that from you
sorry man i probably need that by all
means you can't take what's free
it is true though it's one of those
deals i'm sure you've
i know i know you wrote similar things
in in your first book
um
there is a way to view this these sort
of situations where you can look at it
like well
sure maybe i was forced into this and
that wasn't my fault
but
the only way i get out of this is if i
just
control the parts that i can control and
i can't i can't do that without taking
ownership of the things that i'm
screwing up
so you you almost have to just say okay
the first play doesn't matter anymore
now it's you know third and ten and
i gotta figure out how to crunch these
yards that's it that's it
that's it and i you know you say you
stole it from you actually talk about
you you give credit to uh
extreme ownership the book in in this so
i appreciate the the shout out and i'm
glad that it was able to something that
you were able to connect to
um
so that's sort of the opening that you
give on this dealing with oxycontin and
whatnot you say the hardest part of
managing pain was not dealing with the
sharp often crippling surges it was the
constant aching in retrospect i think
the most profound effect of the
oxycontin was on my sanity
the continual never-ending dull aches
that engulfed my lower extremities spine
and right hand were psychologically
torturous
it wasn't exactly excruciating but the
utter lack of respite was brutal
and that's um
you know you you kind of go into that
but i wanted to highlight the fact that
you say a couple times like it was just
absolutely constant unending pain all
the time mm-hmm
uh
you think about that
what would this is let's say the soviets
had the ability to inflict this
kind of thing like invisible
damage i mean it's not invisible but
like let's say they could make invisible
damage and chronic pain
that's the that would have been the
preferred torture mechanism you know
because i think it could send you back
into the real world and be like whenever
you're ready we can push the button or
you know remove the device or whatever
and make the pain stop yeah but you got
to do what we told you to do yeah
but that's how a lot of these guys are
living for months and years at a time
and i think we don't really
i don't think
we don't go deep deep enough into the
psychology that often enough when we
tell our own stories we just sort of
kind of gloss over that achy you know
dull
almost maniacal
pain and a lot of dudes even just like
construction guys are living like this
for sure you wonder why they're drinking
like 30 pack a night or whatever just
because their
backs jacked up or they're whatever yeah
or something and like you said they
still got the bills to pay the family to
feed
yeah and speaking of drinking at this
point you say you're drinking a half a
fifth of bourbon a night
on top of the painkillers
um
at one point one of your
friends i guess
yeah teaches you how to snort oxycontin
yeah some things had changed while i was
gone and um
yeah i mean i'd like
seeing this kind of stuff done as a kid
like you'd see people
you know get a party something you see
people like roll up a dollar bill or
something you're all just drinking but
there's like a whole process to
be able to snort oxycontin and that was
that was news to me but
you when you so you do it
this guy kind of shows you what's up
teaches you how to snort oxycontin
once you do it you feel it you feel like
you're gonna puke he tells you to go
puke you go puke and then you say from
the book after i vomited i felt better
than i have ever had in my entire life
yeah
when i was speaking at schools for a
while i used to tell
teachers and like the worst thing you
can tell a kid is that it's not fun
because then they know you lied to them
oh
like because it is it's it really is
like the most invigorating
it's it's really is bliss
uh it's a it's it's honestly it's
difficult to put into words how good it
feels it's like euphoric
but if you if you lie to people and say
drugs are all terrible and
you know and then their first experience
is like what have you been hiding from
me dude like this is amazing you know
then they're more likely to
you know like it's much better to focus
on how bad things can get rather than
tell them it's not fun you know same
thing with like drinking i mean i mean
how many preachers daughters end up
you know
doing preachers daughters things
the guy i knew um a friend of mine told
he he ended up in jail and whatnot but
he said the first time he ever did
crystal meth it was the only thing he
ever wanted to do for the rest of his
life like it was just like
so
he just loved it very first time done he
was done he was addicted and he ended up
you know addicted until he went to jail
[Music]
you say my desire to continue on was
eroding
many factors were contributing to this
like the impossibility of finding
refrain from the physical torment but my
inability to come to terms with the fact
that my best friends were still in
harm's way living in the hell that was
ramadi in 2006 without me and my own be
poor behavioral choices were the worst
of them
once i had scrawled the timeless
military mantra death before dishonor
death before dishonor on the walls of my
hooch in iraq now here on the home front
where that code should be easiest to
live up to i failed and i continued to
fail every day over and over the surest
form of justification ran through my
head
what does it matter anyways
once i started abusing pain medication
my mental health went downhill rapidly
but i didn't care i felt nothing
even chasing the dragon became a sort of
mundane routine
doctor appointed visits doctor
appointments visits with specialists in
physical therapy sessions were too
similar to tell apart the only piece of
me that had grown was my opioid
addiction
and it had metastasized
in the morning i'd wake up wheel into
the bathroom
grind up another oxycontin and eagerly
devour it as if it were the cure to
rather than a cause of my self-hatred
after my usual half days work at the
hospital i stopped by the liquor store
and picked up a fifth of bourbon often
times feeling safely away from the
presence of a local law enforcement i
opened the bottle the moment i exited
the freeway
most days i drove right past my house
headed for the nearest solitude i could
find i long for a place where i could be
alone just me and my thoughts
my thoughts nearly never left ramadi it
was almost as if i still lived there in
my mind i'd become bitter and angry i
hated everyone and everything around me
don't any of these [__] realize
we're at war right now good men are
dying in ungrateful countries half a
world away what the [__] is everyone
smiling about
the only people i still loved were
thousands of miles away and i had no way
to talk to them
i slid my way out of the truck placing
most of my weight on the cane in my left
hand and the le and the rest on my left
leg as i had become my new normal pain
shot through my body
my hip wobbled
it couldn't handle the redistribution of
weight i let out a short groan [__] this
[__]
i yelled aloud broadcasting my complaint
to god the universe and whatever else
may be listening
i emerged from my home a short while
later with my semi-automatic 45 caliber
handgun and a fresh bottle of pills in
tow
i climbed into my truck yanked the lever
into reverse and started from my
favorite little mountain valley in those
east hills
i pulled my truck back up to the edge of
the valley in front of the old cabin
hoping that someone might find me before
my decomposing corpse began to bloat i
didn't want my mom to have to deal with
that image for the rest of her life i
retrieved my lighter bill credit card cd
case and oxycontin
i was ready to get on with it
i kept pounding whiskey while i crushed
up my narcotics i was anxious to feel
the warm blanket of euphoria
their imperceptible chains would bring
lines spread across the cd case placed
in the middle of my center console i
rolled up an already chalky bill and
snorted the first line i feel better
already i thought to myself as i chased
it down with another swig of the bottle
i was holding between my knees
my pistol sat on the passenger seat
beside me
i reached over with my right hand
wrapped its two working fingers around
the grip and pushed the frame into my
thigh to stabilize it
then i racked the slide with my left
hand
the gun now mane ready
i set upon my lap muzzle toward the
front of the cab
never point a weapon at anything you are
not willing to destroy i took up the
bottle again and had another slug i
retrieved the loosely rolled bill and
tightened it back into a cylinder then i
placed it at the tip of my other nostril
leaned over and softly breathed in the
last of my respite
calm
i stared over the dashboard at the
valley that it once held many of my
fondest memories
the world around me slowly closed in my
eyes darkened i fumbled for the pistol
in my lap
i longed desperately for the bite of its
cold barrel on the side of my head and
the hot lead and delivery it could bring
every ounce of my soul begged for its
one-way ticket to anywhere but the
nihilistic hell i lived in
my eyes opened sometime later
a near empty bottle of whiskey on the
floorboard and the song i just got back
from hell by gary allen reverberating
throughout the cab
so thankfully
you passed out yeah
yeah it had a
i had this mix that i'd made that truck
just had a cd player so i'd had like
this
mix of songs and that they were all
those kind of songs like
and i drove up to this valley that i
used to go
you know go shoot rabbits or hunt snakes
or party with girls and this kind of
stuff and
i just wanted to be done with the just
frustrated and
done
and luckily like as you said i passed
out man
she could have been really bad
and luckily i didn't you know
like
get
acute liver failure or some [__] from
opioids and alcohol and
um
and yeah like physical therapy every day
yeah i just set back after setback and
then you know my entire
recovery was like set back after setback
and
everybody was in ramadi
and i was on like all kinds of [__]
drugs
and you know psych drugs and opioids and
every other you know and my body didn't
work and i was just i was just over it
man
i was just completely over it
didn't that you know it wasn't like in
the best marriage at the time which how
could you be
you know when you're
like how could your marriage be good
when you're behaving like this every day
right so just like everything is it like
spiraled down the toilet
um
and that's
it's not an uncommon it's really
unfortunately not an uncommon occurrence
uh this is kind of why
eventually that i wanted to write the
book in the first place was i was
reading these
other books here and there and i just
didn't i didn't feel like i didn't see
anybody that was going
it was they weren't being like the the
stories weren't reflecting everything
that i was seeing you know in my own
life and my friends and
you know some guys were doing great and
other guys were really not doing great
how is it that no one
like saw i mean if you're drinking that
much and you're free are they not blood
testing you to see how much opians or
opioids are in your system or [__] like
that so i was getting blood tested every
day for uh i think i can't remember if i
was off of blood thinners by then or not
when i was on blood thinners i had to
get tested every day but they don't test
for anything but like the
i don't know if it's viscosity or what
but however like how thin your blood is
and so then they just adjust your blood
thinner medication to that
so no one was like
piss-testing me for alcohol right and
you're not talking to any freaking
therapist or psychologist or chaplains
or anything like that just just they
figured oh he's fine
yeah i mean i i was probably i mean i
was definitely trying to bluff everybody
all the time but no i wasn't you know i
had to speak to a therapist i can't
remember if it was three times a year
it was something like that
it was some very that might have been a
va thing i can't remember there's
anyways there was at some point there
was a requirement to speak to a
therapist like three times a year
um
and
that was i was really uh
yeah and
i don't i wish i really wish i knew why
it got that bad
but it did well you just kind of breezed
through it and i i'm reading through the
book i mean
i've skipped through a bunch of stuff
where the daily grind of what you're
doing you're missing your friends in
ramadi you're how you're not healthy the
way you want to be the
the downward spiral of
oh i'm addicted to this [__] and the
only way to stop feeling shitty about
feeling addicted this [__] is to do more
of this [__] that i'm addicted to yeah
uh
so i think you you the way you lay it
out is actually
very helpful
because people might be able to identify
where they are on that
downward spiral yeah and what for me
what finally got me there i'm saying i
wish i knew what was at the very very
bottom of it but but the final catalyst
was i injured my leg at physical therapy
again and i was just like [__] man
you know i can't like i'm i'm done like
this i've had enough roller coaster at
this point you know
so i think if you're if you're one of
these people that's going through
addiction and you're
what they call like functionally
addicted whether it's heroin or like
there's only a handful of drugs that
people can really do it on
alcohol mostly if you're one of these
like functional addicts you should
really know that
you might hit that one
catalyst that sends you to a whole
another level of it you know what i mean
because maybe you can ride that for a
while
but eventually something goes wrong and
you're going to turn to
that substance to help you get over that
and that's going to go you're going to
be at a whole new whole new level of
addiction
because now you just conquered another
thing you know with it so
and yeah like you know back to your
other point thankfully i didn't shoot
myself
i'm pretty happy about that now
you know i've said before like uh
when people get in these modes in these
situations like there's like a storm
cloud around their head that they think
is the whole world is a storm cloud and
like anyone on the outside can look at
it and say
bro you're just it's just around you
like you come over here you'll be okay
you'll get out of it but from the
perspective that you're in at that time
all you see is just freaking darkness
everywhere yeah
um
going back to the book here the 15 mile
drive back home dragged on this is after
you got your ship back together um
my thoughts drifted back to arlington
the last place
in time where i felt strong and
accomplished i remembered again how it
felt to recognize how minor my
complaints truly were in the grand
scheme of things my sacrifice were so
little when compared to those
to what those heroes had given
i was kicking away the blanket of
freedom and security that they provided
me
it is my duty to live for those who
can't i'd once said who am i to be so
selfish i was going to throw away my
gift of life due to a little suffering
who among them would not gladly trade
places with me i said to myself hoping
that it would sink in again my
commitment to those heroes rekindled
shame the right kind of shame the kind
that expedites transformation washed
over me not long ago i had stood above
their sacred resting places offering
whatever small vicarious redemption i
could yet i had failed at that promise i
had tried to quit my duty in its infancy
never again
i renewed my vows to them before god and
whatever else was listening i promised
never to give into the darkness again
now as i write this today i wish so
desperately that i could tell you
honestly that i made good on this second
oath but i can't
that was not the last time i failed them
in fact it was just one stumbling among
a multitude i was starting to feel a
little better about myself i had made a
grave mistake but luckily it hadn't been
final
i've got to get my [__] together i said
so
you um
like you said you
you redo this valve kind of thing
and you know and then again
you freaking uh
fool me into thinking like this is it
this is it he made it out of the
darkness i'm like cool we're good
and you do you know you go up you start
squaring some [__] away
fast forward a little bit these cold
fronts and winter weather kept me shut
up inside day and night in my waking
hours i stared out the window at dark
and frigid skies when i lay down to rest
the freezing world around me was
replaced by 130 degree memories and
nightmares i felt as if my life was
constantly on the brink of an
unforeseeable but impending doom
depression brought me back to the
blanket of the bottle and the brief
bliss of medication my hospital visits
were shrunk from five days a week to
three but physical therapy was virtually
non-existent the only thing that got me
out of bed each day was my hatred for
the sheets
i did nothing but watch movies play my
guitar and drink whiskey rock bottom is
a slower and softer landing than one may
think
that's why we keep chiseling away at the
bedrock
does some good writing it's freaking
depressing writing but it's good writing
um
another good good piece of good writing
right here if there's such a thing as
the christian's concept of the devil
opioids and alcohol are some of the best
tools he employs to capture weakened men
the instant euphoria softly whispers its
lies to the heart there are no problems
i cannot solve
addiction snags you at your weakest
times like the wolf kills a buffalo the
wolf waits until the bison's gate is
crippled or the snow is deep enough to
entrap him then he pounces usually he
hamstrings the animal first then slowly
and methodically he gnaws away the flesh
until his prey expires
fast forward a little bit more when i
returned home it was about noon and i
was already an inebriated mess i walked
through the door canes and bourbon in
tow
the smell of whiskey radiated from my
pores hey braxton i have something to
tell you my wife said
she must be leaving for good this time i
thought she's unemotional this time it's
for real am i okay with that i've wanted
her to leave dozens of times but am i
really okay with it yeah i think i am
how will her family take it
i will remain friends with will i remain
friends with her brothers her dad no
maybe they already know that we fight
all the time they must
thoughts swirled about my head i think
i'm pregnant she said
what
i'm pregnant aren't you happy about that
she said smiling of course i am
i acted as if i were
i took another shot of bourbon
i wanted to be a father badly god only
knows why i wasn't fit to be one
still i was indeed very happy that i may
be fulfilling that wish but was this
really the best time was i with the best
person for me or the best or was i the
best person for her
the answer to both of those questions
was clearly no less than a week before
we had been fighting nearly every day we
told each other that we hated one
another and we meant it
each of us had uttered the word divorce
aloud
now we are going to have a baby
check
you couldn't predicted that one when you
wrote it early on though right no
no
it's uh
yeah
it's
yeah rough man rough yeah um you guys
were married young and then you go
through all this like you said it's hard
what what you just said you know it's
hard to have a good marriage when you're
drinking yeah bourbon and you know doing
drugs and all that yeah um
yeah you can't you can't put the blame
on her for this that's the way i look at
it anyway
um
but you know the cliche answer which is
the real one though is that i have my i
got my daughter out of the deal
and she lives with me and
life's great you know i mean this is now
14 years later yeah but
uh but yeah it sucked their first
stretch and
it is it's just really easy to get back
down in that hole especially when you're
you really still don't you still feel
like you don't have anything to live for
you know that's why i always say that
like gratitude
you really got to cultivate gratitude in
your daily life
when i read that part well when i read
this like part where she's actually born
and you know
she's healthy
and um you say it's amazing how much a
parent can love a child i already loved
her
i would have to i would have happily
died for her i still would but in that
moment as i sat there watching
them i realized something was still
wrong not with her with me
so like i'm like okay cool here we go
you know we're gonna
kind of
make it through this
um you talk about ptsd you you bring it
you bring it up earlier than this
but this was the time
this is where you started like kind of
conveying your thoughts on it you say
previously mentioned other times when i
thought that i may have been afflicted
by t ptsd many times my subconscious
registered a symptom of the disease that
i'd read about or my therapist therapist
had mentioned who could miss the
unwelcome memories at in
opportune times or the never-ending need
to suppress unprovoked anger or the
nightmares or the illogical moments of
panic i denied the existence of my
illness for many reasons but most
important was that i just did not want
to be associated with many of the others
i had seen at the va pensions for the
disease or sorry uh had received va
pensions for the disease i knew of a guy
who had worked in the laundromat in iraq
he got a rating of 80 disability for
ptsd for what experience exactly i
wondered another guy had heard of had
been found 100 disabled from the trauma
of answering radio transmissions from
soldiers in combat
how could a person be so soft that they
were damaged by the sounds of combat i
wondered bitterly
during my transition there seemed no
less noble an act than claiming to
suffer from ptsd it wasn't just that it
wasn't just seen as an illness that
plagued the weak it was in many cases an
illness claimed by liars whether they
were weak or not was unimportant i had
made many mistakes and acted cowardly
and lied many times in my life but i had
no desire to have those descriptors
permanently enshrined in my records at
least that was the way i saw it back
then
um
interesting thought i mean it's a very
it's a very interesting thought you know
that you're having because you're a
freaking tough cowboy
and
these guys that are saying they have
ptsd because they worked in the
laundromat in iraq you're like no
[__] yeah right
yeah
but but i wasn't a lot of guys thought
that at the time well i mean and because
it's a lot of truth to it you know i
mean dudes really gained the [__] out of
that system and we all know it
i understand that the va's in a tough
position because
you know how do you really weed out
people that are gaming it i i get it
but from a soldier's perspective i
didn't want to be still to this day
really don't want to be labeled in that
same way like i'm happy to talk about
you know pts and working through stuff
and acknowledging that it's definitely
had profound impacts on my life and i
would like to try to help people through
whatever
suffering they're having but i don't
necessarily want to be associated with
it and that's for that same reason today
you know um
i mean luckily
i don't have to
you don't have to worry in a lot of ways
i don't have to worry about being
associated with that crowd just for
obvious reasons
but yeah it's
i you know but people talk especially in
the veteran community we want to
de-stigmatize the term ptsd and
i don't know
um
i i think we need to de-stigma
stigmatize mental health for sure
but ptsd sort of took on a life of its
own
and so like maybe it's time to just shed
that label and go with something new and
or stigmatize the [__] out of it and
tell people who really really need help
don't want to be associated with it i
don't know i don't know the right answer
i don't know either
as you're working through that [__]
uh
you and your wife end up getting
divorced
yeah and
initially
you her and her and your daughter leave
for
her home which is like
middle of the country 1300 miles away
yeah um
yeah
and then you say if you thought the that
the heartache of divorce and the
departure of my beloved child would have
caused me to take a long hard look at
myself you'd be wrong
because hedonism and self-indulgence
provide immediate gratification the
russian excitement and euphoria make it
difficult to dig in one's heels and
change course and why would you want to
change your lifestyle if you've got no
respect for your future
the simple perhaps sad truth is of it is
that debauchery can be good old plain
fun for a while for about seven years
i lived in hell and sometimes i relished
in it
you you
basically um
you basically went hard yeah for seven
years
yeah i mean not so much on drugs but
alcohol and partying and chasing girls
one one of those times i've seen san
diego actually
uh
yeah
we went
out of friends that were a bachelor
group and we were all doing okay making
pretty good money and we're just like
we're just gonna party yeah
yeah um
the evenings like my descent always
started out in an exuberance and ended
shamefully i was not myself i didn't
know who i was
all i knew is i didn't like the man i
saw in the mirror give and given the
option i would destroy him my chief
mistake was that i didn't realize there
was a cure for my illness
the truth
had i only been willing to accept that i
could have been freed of my hide
as in jekyll and hyde much sooner
there were more girls and more parties
than i care to remember not that i could
remember them all if i wanted to my
first steps onto the slippery slope were
enjoyable it can be great fun to lose
control momentarily but once that on
that slope i couldn't
keep myself from careening to the bottom
i hardly had control of anything in in
my life let it let alone my alcohol
habit
i had ripped the moral substrate out
from my under my world and descended
into nihilism
nihilism is not without benefits though
it simplifies life
there's a problem with nihilism
it leads to depravity and uncontrolled
chaos
if nothing else matters then that's that
why care about health for the future
unbridled pleasure was the closest thing
i could find to happiness
i sought only hedonistic satisfaction
which i think is the logical conclusion
of nihilistic ideologies
it's important to note that my life
wasn't all that bad either
it rarely is that's what makes it so
hard to crawl back up the slope i was
still making very realistic very real
physical milestones i'd abandon the cane
altogether i still stretched every day
and did light workouts my physical body
was healing and aside from the
infrequent brushes with the law i was
having fun
the most dreadful part was that
somewhere buried deep down in my
subconscious in the land of all that
shadow was the truth it was all my fault
war no war the problems i faced were my
own creation and i knew that
yeah
i think sometimes we use these things
uh some people
will use these things as a way to
escape from the shame of knowing that
you're not what you could be
you know like people talk about
potential all the time and no one knows
your potential better than you
you know like you know who you really
are way down in there
and so you just come up with
distractions like useless and senseless
distractions parties and
you know girls and
or whatever other venture just to avoid
becoming what you're you know what you
could be
and you said you were making money at
this time what were you doing i was
working an outreach for a not-for-profit
company but you were getting paid they
were paying me pretty good
and and then
at some point um
you kind of realized she said my life
was falling apart my credit score was
tanking my job was on the rocks
every close relationship but i had once
depended on was virtually demolished
i was having too much fun to see it you
decided you quit your job
yeah
there was and you wrote about that in
here um
it's an interesting
basically
there was like an integrity issue with
the place you were working for yeah and
you
at one point you're talking to a medal
of honor recipient
and you just couldn't
couldn't lie to him basically well it
was just such an obvious flat out
[__]
lie like straight up and not like one of
these white lies or stretches it was
just a straight up falsehood at the
expense of
you know other veterans and this you
know trying to fundraise essentially you
know like the live was attempt to raise
more funds and so yeah i quit
and you quit so you quit your job you
still have i mean obviously you're
getting your disability pay and did you
get medically retired till you get your
medical retirement you don't get both
though oh you only get one
yeah
but at least that was enough money to
survive on yeah especially in cow town
utah
man my freaking mortgage was like 700
bucks
i was doing fine
so you quit that job and you want to
talk about unexpected didn't see that
coming was uh
are you know where this going now what
comedian yeah so you started doing
stand-up comedy you know
yeah well
like i was going to college and i was
like i've always wanted to try it so i
started doing it
and you must have done all right you did
it for a while i mean it's still utah
even in salt lake it's like
[Music]
yeah i did it for a big fish in a small
pond
utah comedy scene a medium-sized fish in
a very small pond
yeah i mean we did okay i and i got to
be buddies with a guy that was really
good and so that helped you know i mean
i was terrible like everyone is but
i got you know it was fun i did enjoy it
um
but it you know looking back even
even the jokes that i would write and
stuff were reflective of like a
different person than i'd ever been
because i was like
and especially like as a young open
micro and then you progress like a
middle act and stuff you're you're just
really reaching for stuff and you're
just saying horrific [__] sometimes you
know just like shock value yeah and i
look back at some of that stuff and i'm
like completely embarrassed by it you
think you're able to take a crack at it
again come out of
retirement i live in central idaho
just go post up at the bar in idaho
falls or something
look you're making us laugh man
you got it still got it
one of the best things that happened
was you actually ended up meeting a girl
and the girl that you meet
she has a son
who was a few years older than your
daughter but
you but he's like playing baseball and
you didn't think that the baseball was
really getting him what he needed so you
signed him up for wrestling
and
it turned out that his wrestling coach
was your communications professor in
college yeah and he knew who you were as
a wrestler is that right yeah well and
then i coached at millard for a while
after that i was an assistant coach oh
okay so he but he knew you had a
wrestling background so he basically
said hey if you don't freaking coach
wrestling it's gonna hurt you're great
yeah he's straight near straight up
yeah
so
you you start coaching and as you're
coaching him
wrestling in season ends then he's going
into baseball so you decide you're going
to coach baseball too
um
and then this happens it's pretty cool i
flipped the pitch so you're coaching
these little kids i flipped a pitch to
the little batter he softly he hit it
softly in the air i lightly trotted to
it and reeled it in another pitch he hit
a hard ground ball a step to my right i
fielded it with ease somewhere in my
subconscious the thought rang dang that
felt good
i served him another this time he hit a
hard ground ball about three steps to my
left my glove hand side i sprinted to it
and scooped it up with a spinning motion
a smile as wide as montana creased my
face holy crap you just ran his mother
shouted i know i couldn't contain my
excitement i started charging at every
ball he hit even the ones i didn't need
to
a rush of love filled me i'd forgotten
how good it felt to be somewhat capable
and likely never would have run toward a
ball if i hadn't been tired and losing
focus the lack of attention allowed my
subconscious mind to unshackle the
chains my conscious mind
bound my legs with
on the next pitch he ripped the line
drive over my head i tried to jump for
it nope still can't tell me
well i guess basketball is out of the
question i i yelled grinning widely
we called it quits and i immediately
grabbed my phone
out of my ball bag i sent out several
text messages that read i just ran in
all caps a few war buddies who received
it called me later that night demanding
to hear the full story when i re
reiterated it to them
he cried
pretty awesome discovery right there it
really was
yeah i wonder how much sooner i would
have figured that out if i wasn't
screwing everything else up
you know what i mean if i had just been
dedicated to
working on my body i could have probably
had five years that i lost
you know
partying
near the end of his baseball season at
about 4 p.m
got a message grandpa was just rushed to
the hospital by ambulance read a text
from my mother that would alter the my
course forever i called her on the phone
to get the details and comfort her if
there was some way that i could she was
clearly anguishing what can a son say to
a mother who's witnessing her rock wash
away
that night sitting on the balcony of my
apartment in west jordan utah staring at
my tomato plants i wondered what i would
do in a world without him i wish to be
away from the bright lights and noise of
the city sitting by a morning campfire
drinking coffee with him again
i knew i had long since begun to
rediscover myself but could i stay
properly aimed without him
i had started hunting and fishing again
i went back to my roots i read a little
a little young
became
and became convinced of the importance
of symbols
not just
in a socio-cultural sense but personally
i had begun to wear my cowboy hat in
public instead of only on the weekends
when i was away from the prying eyes of
onlookers
still though this was a positive step
backward
i had not truly
returned home yet
and i didn't know exactly what that
meant i only knew that the answer lay
somewhere in my history somewhere in my
roots
i think of it as
i think it is true that clothing does
not make the man but a display of what
it is inside the heart a cowboy hat may
have been a trivial thing but before i
had descended to the underworld i had
worn it with pride it was a symbol of
honor hard work and respect of heritage
it had been so closely attached to that
symbol that i'd worn one nearly every
second of my life before i strayed as a
boy it was no strange event for my mom
to remove a hat from my head as i slept
my hat was the first thing my ex-wife
brought to me when i was in walter reed
recovering i wore it nearly all the time
after that it was not a fashion
statement but a symbol of all my grandpa
believed in
i thought a lot about all that my
grandfather had taught me as a boy
he thought there were concrete skills
and lessons required of a man from the
west
and he made damn sure that i learned
them
and in your footnotes you say by by the
west you mean the rocky mountain west
i remembered his knuckles pressing into
mountain mud to show me how a mature
mule deer buck's weight causes
depressions much different than a young
buck or doe does he showed me how to
read the difference between an elk track
that had just slid down a wet muddy
hillside and one who was on a dead run
he tied his own flies for catching trout
out of our mountain creeks rivers and
lakes all of which were different flies
and weights of flies by his estimation
and he made sure i could do that too he
taught me how to skin an animal by
showing me
how he did it
but he only let me practice on the lower
legs of elk and deer he killed he taught
me how to trap and clean fish and game
he spent time on more abstract things
like what it really means to be a man
that's a much harder concept to pin down
on paige
on one deer hunt when i was about 10
years old he handed me a raw liver from
a buck he had just killed he told me
that taking a large bite of it was the
only real rite of passage to manhood
when the metallic tasting fleshy
substance filled the entirely entirety
of my mouth and thick warm blood round
down my ran down my cheeks and neck
he let out a deep belly laugh
i realized the joke was on me he was
trying to teach me two lessons there one
that no single physical act makes a man
and two not everything an authority
figure tells you is worth believing
sometimes you're just the butt of a joke
you say that
the positive step backward normally when
you think step backward we think of a
negative connotation but for you
like the cowboy hat
was going back to your roots in a
positive way
yeah not all progress is progress
it's a good note
a couple days later my girlfriend and i
were back in my hometown at the church
where his funeral would be held
the hallways were lined with pictures of
him and my grandma the love of his life
and his best friend
he believed that family was the most
important thing in life there were
dozens of pictures of him and his
brothers his kids and his grandchildren
to prove it
table sat on the other side of the doors
to the chapel where his service would be
held each was decorated with his prized
belongings his fly fishing pole flies
that he had tied and his hunting knife
on one table atop a rack that held his
recurve bow and leather quiver filled
with wooden arrows rested his brown
cowboy hat
if it is true that you can tell the
character of a man by the company he
keeps then i think it equally true that
you can tell the type of man by the
possessions his company believes he
values
i stood staring at the hat for a while
i remembered asking him if i could wear
it around our deer camp when i was a
young boy
he dropped it on my head and smiled
i spent the rest of the afternoon
walking around with that hat like i was
like it was a crown fit for quick for
the king of kings
my great uncle uncle john grandpa's
younger brother came up to us while i
was daydreaming and asked how i was
doing
john was a combat controller in vietnam
he had seen more than his share fair
share of fighting
i knew intuitively that the question was
meant to get it something deeper
than how i felt at present
i answered it honestly getting better i
think i said how long have you been back
now
about seven years or so
give it 10 and you will be fine he said
you may be a mess for those 10 years but
you'll be okay after that
it will always be there it doesn't go
it'll go away but one day all of a
sudden
you'll have it under control
okay
thank you
the host called the children and grant
grandchildren up to the casket to pay
final respects
reluctantly i walked up and put my arm
around my mother
she was sobbing uncontrollably
between gasps for air she whispered
aren't you going to say goodbye
no
i'd rather this not be the last image i
remember him by
she grabbed my hand and dragged me up to
his body
up until that point i had hardly shed a
tear
grandpa taught me
that men ought not to cry anyway
i tried to keep my composure
when i saw him lying there
hair combed perfectly bodied body
dressed in his sunday best i broke down
in a way
i never have before or since
the flood of grief and despair twisted
my face i felt like i had been struck by
an avalanche of emotion
it seemed as if every little bit of
anguish i had collected throughout my
lifetime welled up at once
i raised my black cowboy hat up to cover
my face and wept
this was a different kind of pain than i
had felt before
the kind that a person only encounters
when he knows he had failed another that
he loved and revered
for years after returning home from the
war i had lived less than two blocks
away from grandpa and grandma but i
seldom visited them
when my mother asked me why i wasn't
going to see my grandpa
when i
more often i always game that gave the
same selfish pathetic excuse
it's just too hard for me to see my hero
withering away in a bed i don't want to
remember him like this
i think the full gravity of my
selfishness hit me at that moment
it should never have been about me
what an ignorant wretch i was
as for the excuse that i had been using
to avoid the situation that was only
half true anyway the whole truth was yes
it was hard to see him like that but i
was running from everything in my life
after the war
i was running from my emotions from my
responsibilities as a man and from my
own mind
my mistakes as happens to all of us when
we fail were too often thrust onto other
people i loved most around me sure i was
paying for them too but so were
they and they had done nothing to
deserve it
i failed a man that i loved more than
life itself
my my selfishness had hurt him when he
needed me most and it was too late to
make up for it
all i could do is weep
and that's all i did
well
it does seem like the um
these these moments throughout the book
that um
when you read them you think of this
this this is this the one is this the
one that's going to kind of
get you up on step get you to kind of
transition away from this this negative
path and it certainly seems like
this one had a big impact
yeah
yeah i definitely wish you could see
where we're at now
well
i wish he could have seen you when you
walked into my gym today um down here in
southern california in san diego
sporting a cowboy hat i'm sure he'd be
he'd be hella proud
yeah and he loved his grandkids and i
wish he could see my kids you know
so good life is now
obviously i can't you know i can't go
back and be there for him when i should
have been
but
well one thing that is another thing
that's positive is
someone sitting here listening right to
this right now i guarantee
at least one person i don't know how
many but i know at least a minimum of
one
is gonna is gonna make that move and go
and spend time with people they care
about that they should i hope so so
um
that lesson that you learned
now gets passed on
you um
as you as as you go through that you
start to realize
that
you missed
what like the various things that you
missed about being in the military the
various things you missed about being in
combat specifically
and
you
realized you missed even training and
getting ready and preparing which are
really positive things in life
um
you say you say in the book i i miss
training i love the feeling of
conquering a particularly difficult day
at work
the kind of satisfaction that one only
gets when he thinks it improbable to
overcome the challenge before he begins
that reminded me i did run a while back
maybe i can run a full mile now i
decided to call up my old friend and
first line leader johnny i knew he had
been running marathons and triathlons
since he returned from iraq surely he
would love to be there when i ran my
first mile since the suicide bombing
crippled me i called him up hey bro i
want to run a mile
uh
you you so you go out
you do it um
we finished the mile loop in about seven
minutes and 30 seconds i was proud of my
pace but something else struck me after
we finished my eagle was the problem i
discovered that i was the root of most
of my psychological problems years
before this and i had taken some
measures to get better what i hadn't
realized was the role ego was playing in
all my suffering
i started to look back at every
ill-advised decision i had ever made
every argument i'd ever been in and the
grudge against the army that i had held
nearly all of them could be traced back
to my ego
and you you you talk about those i mean
just like the an example is
you're pissed at the army didn't keep
you in no
and yet you say in the book you're like
hey i wasn't capable i couldn't freaking
you know like carry a ruck i couldn't
shoot a gun right now how are they gonna
keep me in yeah but in your mind your
ego was like they should have kept me in
yeah yeah i mean how stupid can you
possibly be but i
yeah
i don't know what i thought
other than that i was pissing them
yeah i mean you're right and it it's
and i think it's really easy to
and it is 100 of your ego but it's
really easy to start doing that thing
where you're like wow the army just
treats me like a number and all this
stuff and i was like well yeah man they
got like a half a million people that
they got to bro if i could go what do
you want to write you a letter
yeah but yeah really it it's it is
everything is ego even still today when
i screw something up which is you know a
daily occurrence it's almost every time
my own ego like almost every time
yesterday i got pissed at something
uh i don't even remember what it was now
about a half hour later i was like yeah
that was me that was me too
the path is not an easy path
uh
was my wife's birthday today oh and
she's she's overseas right now and uh i
like woke up in the morning so she's in
a different time zone right i woke up in
the morning and like i got
[__] to do right you know what i'm
saying i got i got to think like a
work-up workout so i wake up and there's
a family group text
and it says um you know
happy birthday it's from my daughter
that's overseas with my with my you know
happy birthday mom
group family group text and i'm like
okay cool you know i'm hey cool but i
you know i'm not gonna like i didn't
text at that moment in time
right
so i wake up
work out uh
you know do my morning stuff go for a
run ice bath right dude the whole nine
yards
and i look at my text and there's a text
off the family group text
only from my wife
oh boy it says thanks for the birthday
text today yeah he deserved that one by
the way
that's not the end of the story bro
so in my mind i was like oh that's
interesting i was kind of a little bit
surprised and i was like and here's the
funny thing so in my mind i was like
i just got home from a trip or from a
work trip
i was gone for four days i worked
how many hours of date am i working at
the muster
16. 16 hours a day at the muster
uh just constantly on the go talking to
people shaking hands but
delivering up on stage doing all this
stuff get home from that
i got to finish reading your book
braxton
then it's father's day what do i do on
father's day prep this podcast so that's
what i'm doing on father's day and then
i wake up i did i got i know i got to
record this day i had another call a big
call in the morning
and now i'm thinking my wife is like
texting me like oh you know she's on
vacation
[Laughter]
but you know what i was like you know
what
just i'm just gonna you know just text
her and say hey you know sorry about
that i was you know
and then
before i could even respond because i
was gonna sit on it for a little while
breathe you know take a breath
then my wife sends me a text on the
not the family group text just hers
and it says
that was rana my daughter so my daughter
tricked she tried to drink
i laughed about it
i was like yeah i knew
i said allegedly i oh yeah i knew i will
say i was kind of so it was kind of
strange that she would have written that
that's why i was kind of surprised
like was out of character yeah it was
out of character i thought maybe
something bad had happened like some
annoying thing you know like whatever
made braxton mad something like that
something that made her mad
but but luckily i didn't respond imagine
if i would have responded in anger yeah
yeah don't do that that goes to [__]
that's ego gotta keep that ego in check
i kept the ego in check is what i'm
saying yeah but it sometimes can be
tricky good good thing you uh relaxed uh
looked around and made a call just step
back yeah step back from where you go
and check but that's the thing what was
causing my like all that little that
little trail of thoughts that i had i
was doing this and i was doing that i
was working so hard and you're making it
was just an ego ego eagle ego so before
i even respond i was just like okay you
know what
and you know what i thought to myself
and i do this a lot good
i want my wife to be at a point where
if she can be on vacation
in a foreign country by the way that i'm
paying for it
and she could be mad because i didn't
send her a birthday text at 4 34 in the
morning when i woke up that's a good
thing that's a good that's
when you know things are good for her
so i was kind of a little bit stoked
but you got to watch that ego man you
got to watch that thing it's ready to
bite
this is cool
this is where we start going man you say
from that point forward my life began to
morph rapidly when i was a younger man i
thought courage strength and tenacity
were traits that made a man worthy of
the title but
by exercising each of those traits at
different times during and after the war
i realized they were not enough they are
important highly important but they are
not sufficient enough to make life worth
living i realized that what grandpa had
been trying to teach me all along was
that a good man and a good life are made
of balance growth and selflessness
if those three things are a person's
substrate everything else will take care
of itself strength is important but it
must be balanced with caring
selfless selflessness as hard as it may
be to spot erodes that purveyor
or sorry selfishness as hard as it may
be to spot erodes the purveyor the
victim and all those caught in between
if a person is focused on growth no
matter the challenge he or she will
always come out better than they were
before the impetus a mindset of growth
helps us internalize our mistakes and
craft better strategies for the next
bout of trouble
if we can do it without crushing our
spirits under the weight of our own
self-judgment that is
here's where we get rocking and rolling
i decided to quit smoking cold turkey it
was difficult but no by no means
excruciating i limited my drinking to a
couple days a week
and started each day at 5 00 am this
latter bit being the key to squashing
loki alka his alcoholism most abruptly
the change in my habits helped expedite
what was already the most rapid physical
change my body had gone through since
walter reed every morning i stretched
out then i ran a mile soon that turned
into two miles i was lifting weights in
my garage
every morning and doing a 30 minute
workout at night i couldn't exercise
enough to satisfy my lust for health and
vigor once my body was strong enough to
endure a little hiking i set out looking
for the teacher who had taught me the
most valuable lessons in my youth the
mountain
each mile up those blustering ridges cut
through my delusions the mountain is
indifferent to our existence we are
nothing but another speck upon its rims
no more or less important than the rock
beneath our feet or the deer we chase
ego is no currency in the wilderness
that's a lesson we can all stan stand to
learn i rediscovered god or at least
or at the very least you could say that
i had rediscovered meaning
but i think that's a distinction without
any real difference in the vastness of
the wild the indifference of the rockies
humbled me humility and truth
set me free
i'm starting to feel pretty good about
this book now
uh you started speaking
and you had been speaking yeah but you
know what's weird you talk about when
you're speaking you kind of felt like a
fraud like you'd be telling people like
yeah you can overcome anything and you'd
be like i'm full of [__] yeah 100
those people hopefully claw back their
money come and get their money back well
that was for uh that was for that
not-for-profit though so they weren't
like paying me
got it
uh
you doing corporate events you were
talking to you know professional
athletes then you went to this summit in
vail there was a bunch of academic
people there
one of those people was a monk who
taught ethics at mit you say this he
taught us the most valuable lesson i had
ever learned
life is suffering it is only by
accepting that fact that we can lessen
it i had been saying something close to
that in speeches for years but he helped
concretize it for me
i was done laying my problems at the
feet of others i got online and searched
for any information i could find on
brain injuries i found that i had
demonstrable signs of tbi i remembered
that the va sent me a letter listing all
the most common symptoms of both brain
injury and post-traumatic stress
disorder
i wasn't going to read these but i
actually am going to just because
it's important for people to know these
things common symptoms of ptsd one
re-experience the event over and over
again you can't put it out of your mind
no matter how hard you try you have
repeated nightmares about the event you
have vivid memories almost like it was
happening all over again you have a
strong reaction when you encounter
reminders such as a car backfiring
two you avoid places or feelings that
remind you of the event you work hard at
putting it out of your mind you feel
numb and detached so that you don't have
to feel anything you avoid people or
places that remind you of the event
three you feel keyed up or on edge at
all time you may startle easily you may
be irritable or angry at all all the
time for no apparent reason you are
always looking around hyper vigilant of
your surroundings you may have trouble
relaxing or getting sleep
and then this thing that you looked up
goes on to talk about tbi common signs
of brain injury difficulty organizing
daily tasks blurred vision or eyes tire
easily headaches are ringing in the ears
feeling sad anxious or listless feeling
irritated or angered feeling tired all
the time feeling light-headed or dizzy
trouble with memory attention or
concentration more sensitive to sounds
lights or distractions impaired decision
making or problem solving difficulty
inhibiting behavior impulsive
slowed thinking moving speaking or
reading easily confused feeling easily
overwhelmed change in sexual interest or
behavior
and then you say this the last 150 pages
of this book and the decade it took to
live it look in retrospect like an
aggregate of those symptoms played out
in one person's experience
i had long understood that the va wasn't
taking my brain injury very seriously
but after reading that paper it became
immediate that i
it became immediately apparent that i
had not taken the brain injury i
incurred seriously enough
yeah and i'm pretty sure that was
actually straight from the letter that
they had just mailed me
like that's the
the chart from or whatever the memo
isn't it kind of interesting to take all
those symptoms and just send it to on a
letter to someone that has these
symptoms like you won't be able to do
exactly what it says like it makes no
sense whatsoever like you wouldn't even
be able to read this thing because you'd
be irritated you'd be confused you're
having trouble like organizing [__] they
want you to do all this what's wrong
with them
it's freaking ridiculous
um
you know this is important section
what was i to do with the fact that my
brain the organ we used to process
reality was permanently damaged i didn't
want to blame my own personal failures
and there were many this is such a key
point i didn't want to blame my own
personal failures and there were many on
something that was out of my control
i knew that was too simple an answer the
temptation to use this new information
as a scapegoat was strong but deep down
in my core i knew that taking that path
would only lead me toward more suffering
i wasn't going to do that again
i decided that the best i could do was
accept that i had incurred an injury
that had made and would continue to make
my life harder than it was before it was
time to move forward with that fact
fully internalized scapegoating would be
another cop-out more cowardice i was
done with that road
so you had a realization that okay you
read through all this stuff and instead
of saying well okay that's why i've been
behaving this way it's like no
no no no scapegoat
yeah i mean you can't you
i mean you can maybe you can give
yourself a little bit of a
like because i tend to carry a lot of
i tend to place a lot of burden on
myself like for [__] i've done in my
life and maybe it makes it a little
easier to be like all right whatever you
know let some of that stuff in the past
it makes it easier to let things in the
past
go but you can't use you can't use it
moving forward or you're just [__] your
life up mm-hmm
you have to just
accept that this is a thing
and really like even like let's say the
impulsivity stuff or the trouble
organizing well you get to find a
workaround yeah yeah that's so that's it
and just think if you if you think to
yourself well
oh i have uh ptsd and tbi that's why i'm
impulsive now you're just like oh and
i'm cleared hot yeah to be even more
impulsive exactly yeah we don't stand up
again like a month
yeah or oh i have trouble organizing
things that's why i'm late to the you
know whatever that's why i didn't turn
in this thing
like yeah you can use that excuse or
like you said you can say oh i know i
have trouble organizing so i gotta write
stuff down i gotta make a plan i gotta
put reminders there whatever yeah
freaking actually
take ownership of it
um
a good friend of mine in a green beret
we call preacher stopped over around the
time i discovered this problem while we
were visiting i shared with him my new
world view about the importance of
humility and acceptance and how i felt
the mountain could teach a man both
things
then he tells you this there is a
forbidden mountain hike on the big
island of hawaii that you have gotta do
you have to start your ascent around
midnight so you can reach the peak
before sunrise the view is incredible
echo charles i don't know which one not
from talking about
and he was being totally full [__] it's
not he was just trying to get me to go
it's not forbidden
oh he just called it that yeah he just
he was like yeah there's this trail it's
illegal man you got to just jump on it i
was like all right
i'll tell you something about mauna kea
that's the first time i ever saw snow in
my life
mauna kea
what's the altitude do you know the
altitude 13-3 oh it's 13 3 damn
yeah it's hot and there's like at the
very top
it's hard there
you know there's there is there's like
nine or ten different peaks like small
ones you know whoops
like so because it's a volcano right so
there's like lots of little
like extra
it's hard to tell which is like the real
peak i mean there's the observatory but
yeah but then there's all those i mean i
don't know i'm looking at you like
you're [__] you're like a little bit
he knows a little bit he's from hawaii
yeah well that's what i'm saying oh
that's why i'm still not an expert i'm
on a kid though
uh
so you get this goal you start freaking
training cause you're gonna go climb the
forbidden mountain yeah
uh
on your way there
you you you get on the the dating app
and you swipe right
and on on a on a female a girl named
randy r-a-n-d-e
that's why you're sitting in the airport
at salt lake
and then you land and you find you land
in kona
you find out that you had she had
matched
dude i did this i'm i'm too old
for all that like i mean i was married
and i'm just too old i missed that whole
that whole thing
or the whole thing
to think back in the day
you had to just randomly meet a female
out of all the millions of females yeah
and now you can just literally go on and
access yeah upon access access upon
access
well in the problem
kind of a pre-screened access too like
hey
like it's you you're writing about
you're looking at her little profile and
she's like shooting a bow right yeah and
like whatever she's
got a dog she's shooting her bow yeah
you're like jack
pre-screened hey i want someone that i
want a female that this brunette knows
how to shoot him shoot archery he's like
good to go
absolutely but i cut you off are you
gonna say no no no it uh
i had you know i tried like the bar like
if you're in your mid mid mid late 20s
i mean i don't know really where you
meet chicks you know it's like
the bar or the grocery store
and so like i tried the bar thing that
shouldn't work
so i was like willing to try just about
anything at that point and a lot of
people say like go to church and i guess
that's probably a good answer but i
i didn't go to church so but i mean even
if you went to church you could meet how
many girls at church nine right yeah you
know maybe like 20 20 13 i don't know
yeah but you go on the app and it's like
you can meet how many a million a
million girls right echo charles
i know you don't know either but i'm
saying because you're the technical
expert here you're the tech guy
i would guess one million yes
right sure am i wrong i don't know it's
got to be a lot right a lot of people
got it
it's gotta be a lot
you know what i actually do know you
know why because i got friends that are
kind of in the game still okay and
they'll be like bro
there's a lot there's a lot it's a
million
well those millions you swipe right on
the bow hunter yeah and or at least
archery
and you land there um
you end up sending her like a just a
text back and
then you end up climbing this mountain
um
i'm gonna fast forward past the details
of the climb it's pretty cool to read
about the climb and what what happened
on that you have another like you have
some more
uh
let's say
moments of discovery
in that
and and
i'll say this you say the forbidden
mountain allegedly forbidden mountain is
the gateway to the grandest sunrise on
earth
i reflected on my life atop that volcano
all 29 years of it
and um
i'm gonna i'm gonna fast forward now
to the to the
kind of the
i guess it's this a little bit of the
summation of
what you talk about towards the end of
this and the things that you figured out
and again i'm hitting the highlights
this is a book
almost 300 page book of lessons
for for anyone for any human being
filled with lessons for any human being
here are some of them i spent almost a
decade suffering things in my youth
i never could have imagined some caused
by life
some were caused by associating with the
wrong people
other bouts by society but most
can be laid directly at my own feet
so many more so many of our problems
it's a lot more than we think
the problems that we caused the problems
that we
initiated
yeah look like you said life's gonna
bring some at you
some some people are gonna bring them at
you sometimes sometimes society's gonna
bring these problems to you but way more
than we think
are because of us
back to the book when i was wounded i
made a clear choice one of the few
choices i ever made that i'm deeply
proud of i decided that i would rather
put my flesh in harm's way than have a
friend of mine put at risk for reasons
that i did not think were worthy
when i was lying on the ground bleeding
to death i was in a great deal of pain
torment that you cannot imagine if
you've not endured it but it wasn't
suffering
i was serving
my country my family and my brothers
i didn't truly suffer
until i started lying to myself
and to others about my problems with
nightmares stress and sleep
those lies built into other lies and
those lies built into more until one day
i was a suicidal nihilistic addict
i created my own hell
and it nearly destroyed my soul
you continue on a little bit further you
can't hide from a dragon or he will burn
down your entire village and all that
you love and care about with it you must
face him
when i ran from the dragons my life
crumbled the spirit split apart and
burned it was like my soul itself was
fractured
then one day i decided i would face my
problems one at a time i wanted to own
them
when i did or at least started to i
improved almost instantaneously
then more popped up more dragons
i think this is why we feel overwhelmed
when we try to take on our problems
there are always dozens more than we
thought there were and it's not until we
emerge from our cowardly little hiding
places that we can see them all clearly
this overwhelming feeling can crush us
if we had not stiffened our spine for
combat that is why i think it's
important that we crush our most
pressing physical obstacles before we
try to take on the mental ones
if we can stop eating terrible diets
that we know are killing us if we can
run when others say we can't walk if we
can put down the bottle that is drowning
our soul then we know we can do anything
the lessons we learn on the physical
journey will steal our resolve for the
longer much harder fight for our mental
and spiritual health
sometimes when we first emerge and feel
completely overwhelmed we run back to
our hiding places we see so many little
dragons that we are afraid of the
aggregate of issues that will demolish
us
maybe that isn't the worst thing
sometimes armies must retreat in order
to regroup and acquire some help before
they fight another day
we can use this philosophy as well but
we can't make it a habit we must go back
into the fray again the moment we are
ready and again
then we become practiced we have dulled
our swords on so many small dragons that
we understand their weaknesses as well
as we do our own this gives us the
ability to take them out more easily to
see them for the minuscule issues that
they often are fear makes the wolf
bigger than he is
the best antidote for fear is experience
the first step then is to get the
physical body in order no matter what
that takes no matter how steep the climb
may be the next is to stand up for truth
in your own life all the time
i swore an oath to my brothers in
arlington i failed to keep it many times
and probably will fail again but i am on
the course right now those failures will
happen less and less often as i gain
more and more experience
you may not have a national shrine to
cling as your guiding light but maybe
you're a mother or father
you have your children and their futures
certainly my kids are the centerpiece of
my life now
what better thing could you do for them
than to get yourself together to lead by
example to face your mistakes fears and
the chaos of life with a steel spirit
and selfless heart
what better thing could you do
nothing
teach them to manifest courage integrity
honor and selflessness in their own
lives by living those virtues so fully
that they cannot help
but to see them displayed
slay your dragons
or they will consume you
slay your dragons or they will consume
you have you ever read my book mikey and
the dragons no oh god okay i'll be
giving it to you shortly
it's how old's your youngest uh my
youngest is eight months old
uh my daughter's 14 years old and
my sons are three and four okay cool so
eight months we got mikey and the
dragons candidates there
so
the book is just outstanding um
so like i said so many lessons learned
in there you did did you did you go to
college
i went for like
a minute what'd you study
um it was all like the
you like the stuff that you have to do
to pre-wreck stuff
you know like your two years how long
did it take you to write this
like
eight months here or something
i wrote a lot of that out of a backpack
in a leather i wrote the whole thing in
a leather bound and two leather-bound uh
journals with a fountain pen because i'm
a [__] nerd and then
i
transferred that onto a computer
leather bound notebook and a fountain
pen you still have that oh yeah i got
both of them
so that's pretty legit that's pretty
cool that's pretty cool i don't have any
cool stories like that
like a like uh sitting there with a word
processor i have no none of that stuff
you talk about a little in the book
but what made you
decide to start writing this
i started writing it at first
like almost
right after they retired me but it was
just bad
and i just like knew i wasn't ready
like what i don't know i just knew i
wasn't ready and
um and then when i was doing all those
corporate gigs uh
you know you're always constantly
getting prodded to write a book and i
was i kind of thought like why for what
like
i don't know i just didn't feel like
there was a story
in there and then a good friend of mine
kept pushing on me and i finally thought
well maybe i'll give it a shot and
kind of looked around and
the
you know the other the other stories
that were around just didn't seem to be
feeling that
they just didn't seem to be conveying
exactly what i was seeing my friends go
through you know like or me i had some
friends that were doing really great
and then i had some friends that were
going to jail
and some
you know one committed suicide you know
and i just felt like no one was telling
the full story and i also didn't want
it felt like the two genres of
iraq war book were either like
heroism
or super whiny crybaby [__]
and i'm just
the heroism stuff is great and
i mean every culture is always done
that's great and that should continue
but like the super whiny [__] we just
there's no reason for that but i
understand the attempt
to kind of try to write something
different i said well i'll just try to
tell my story and hopefully we'll fit
somewhere
not on the whiny [__] scale
you know
and like fill that other gap
and you know i mean i knew that i
couldn't be the only guy that had
i got gotta think that there's at least
ten thousand guys from the g watt that
have had similar stories you know maybe
not exact same wounds but yeah they're
they're definitely out there
so then
so you finished the book this got
published in 2017. yeah yeah
and so what are you up to now so
obviously you married randy how do you
say your name was randy brandy so you
married randy
you got kids
um and what are you doing
i start colts um full-time i'm a colt
starter
and hold on can really quickly before we
go on i just want to point out that i
did say in the book that he bullshitted
me that it wasn't really forbidden on
the hike oh i just want to clear that
out oh
yeah sorry anyway that that was eating
at me no yeah no so wait wait when did
he say that
when did he tell you it was [__]
that it wasn't for britain before you
hiked it he didn't have to tell me once
i got oh
there's a big trail
so it was before you got there he said
it's not really forbidden no no no i'm
saying i put in the book that he was
bullshitting me
does this make you sense what i'm saying
is i just don't want someone out there
listening thinking that i was calling
this a forbidden height because people
would be like oh what was he talking
about apparently the only person that
thought was a forbidden hike was me
no yeah so
uh but i'm a cold starter so i train
train horses start colts and and train
some horses and i've been working on
another book for a while
uh nothing to do with me to do with uh
the roots of um
like america
um
the best way i think i would articulate
it is
when people when you ask somebody
what it means to be american they have
all these ideas
of where that
that sort of ethos came from
and my contention is that it was born on
the pioneers
in the actually on the american frontier
by pioneers from you know kentucky all
the way to california
i mean like you can point to like let's
say like this if you were to ask an
american to describe
what it means to be an american they're
going to talk about [__] like fortitude
perseverance
loyalty dedication love of family
country
you know spirit right
mean you can point to like valley forge
and maybe a couple of battles but other
than that
the eastern seaboard was like pretty
much europe 2.0 you know i'm saying it's
glorious
lots of war glories there and we fought
our forefathers fought hard to
steal europe 2.0 from them
but everything that happened on the
frontier was new and had never happened
and well hadn't happened in 10 000 years
anything like that before
and so that's why america felt so
different because it really had a
totally different
birth than any of these other nations so
i've been working on that for a while
uh and then you know like say right
colts and then i run this bunkhouse deal
where i take guys out once a month to
train on different things and like last
weekend we were doing
some advanced home defense training in
utah with a green beret dude working on
in shoot houses and
stuff like that and we've taken dudes up
hunting and
uh we run i i just facilitate all these
courses but we've done field med courses
and uh
yeah we've done long-range precision
courses with some guys and
yeah we just so anyway these are
basically my main focus and uh so far as
work goes and then after that it's just
family how big is your your ranch i so
as a horse trainer
i can only ride
well it used to be i could ride about 10
a month but now i have kind of too many
other things so now i can only ride
about six a month so i keep about 15
head of horses in my house any one time
and then once they're ready i sell them
and move on
and and what's the name of the company
that does all like the tactical training
uh bunk house it's the bunk house llc
but it's not just tactical stuff like
i've taught basic horsemanship with them
i i did a
back country navigation course with some
people
uh
talks of how to hunt basics course to
people like how to hunt the mountains
basic stuff
so we try to spread out
like jack of all trades type skills as
much as we can kind of become more
generalists
who are your clients
these guys well it's all it's just a
membership deal so it's memorable and
then they just come and we just take
them out
and every wednesday we have some expert
for somewhere come on and
uh we'll just do a quick zoom call and
they'll have an hour
like usually me and that guy our girl
will just have a back and forth and then
we'll open it up and they can ask
questions and
cover different you know whatever how
many people are members of the bunk
house we don't have a lot like 350
something like that so it's easy to get
into courses you know it's super easy
but yeah i do that's kind of like a side
passion project thing and if people want
to do that where do they go to sign up
for that bunkhouse.braxtonmccoy.com
yeah so you said that's your side
project what's your main project run
calls
that's the deal huh yeah that's my jam i
love that [__] it
it i love it yeah
so i've always loved it but now
i think it's really good for me mentally
now too
because you can't like young horses
you got to stay present and focused you
can't you can't be thinking about other
[__] or worrying about other [__] you
got to be on that horse
like with him all the time so i think
it's good for me too how long does a
transition take before they're ready to
go out
to to before you're ready to uh give
them to somebody else or sell them to
somebody else it depends a lot on the
horse uh it depends a lot on the horse
so if i'm riding like an outside horse
would be like a client's horse i'll
usually ride them for 60 to 90 days for
them and then send them off but i only
do a little bit of that now because i i
wrote so many for people
that they would take them and then just
not ride them after they left
and the problem is like you get a
two-year-old that you put 60 days on and
then the owner goes and just parks it in
a pasture for like six months and then
goes to try to get on it the next spring
it's like the horse doesn't even
remember anything you know
so now i only ride colts outside horses
for for one big ranch it's a neighbor of
mine they they run a big old spread but
i'll write them for them because they'll
take them and use them as soon as they
come back
but so the average i would say it
depends on what you're asking that horse
to do but if you're trying to build like
a safe trail horse
you could get a lot done
depending on the age of that horse but
you could get a lot done in a summer as
long as the other person won't take them
back and use them now if you're sending
it off to somebody who's
like good and knows what they're doing
then usually they'll ask for 60 or 90
days riding on them and then take them
but like my stud horse
i bought him from that ranch i was just
talking about because i was starting him
for them
and i'd uh well dwight hill probably the
best horse trainer in the country
came out to help me with him rope him
for me that first day he wanted to show
me some tricks
uh and so we i wrote him that day i put
that first dwight roped him for a bit
and then i wrote him and then i took him
out roped him myself the next day and
then i rode him two more times and then
that fifth time i took him out moving
cattle for like 12 miles for that ranch
yeah and him when he's a two-year-old so
it really depends on the horse what you
can get done now he wasn't he sure as
hell wasn't broke by then but
he was
he was easy compared to a lot of other
ones he was getting there what about
your hunting uh
i mean what's september looking like i'm
i'm hammered september i got a new
mexico buck tag that i'm super excited
about i got a a friend of mine
gave me actually
he's a
mutual friend of micah and i
gave me a
wine cut bull elk tag
so that's i'm soaked for that and then
obviously i got my el [__] in idaho and
i got one buddy coming up to hunt naido
that i promised i'd take for a week so i
really don't have a day off in september
is that is that all bo yeah for me yeah
freaking awesome
uh what else man what
does that get us up to present day does
there anything else you need to tell us
about
no i mean no
so a couple of things did happen that
weren't in that book that ivc filter
that
it's like up in your being a cave a kind
of behind
behind your kidneys essentially
yeah just so everyone i didn't read this
part but they they had to put like a
filter in your body to prevent clots
from getting what to your lungs yeah
and it's a some kind of mesh filter that
they put in it just prevents
blood clots from going through that
screen it's basically a screen and they
had to put it in and so you've had that
in you for
what freaking
a long time 15 years yeah yeah well i
had it in for 12. um
and that
i went in
so i was running endurance races for a
while doing really good and
actually like competitive in every race
i should have won the first one but how
far
the first one i ran was a duathlon so it
was a two mile run or it might have been
a yeah it was a two mile run
and then i think a 20 mile bike ride and
then a two mile run it's the first one
and then i was training for an ultra
when i had this issue with my heart
and
i went in and they said i had a heart
attack i was like whoa that's great
so then i i had to quit training because
you know heart attack
well
it ended up that it wasn't a heart
attack which is great so i go up to the
university of utah oh
and this the filter the way this filter
ties in here
is the i could get that on my hands what
the [__] um
my doctor is like
it's there's a potential that your
filter is just like releasing protein
into your blood you know because like
like i guess the way
like it's damaging that blood vessel in
there and it's
releasing protein because i guess the
way they attack a heart attack is
protein in your bloodstream a certain
type of protein
and that's what they had detected
so he's like i said can we get this
thing out then you know because i'd
really like to do this whole ultra deal
and he said no you're stuck with that
it's been in there for too long there's
no way it's coming out so i came home
and got you know on google start looking
and look like probably right like you
probably couldn't get it out
so then that's what i do when the doctor
tells me something to go home and google
it yeah what up this dude don't know
what he's talking about exactly
google son webmd what
so i went and got on jstor
and started looking for any article i
could find in a turn or any paper rather
i could find and then turned out there's
a doctor up a radiologist i think he is
i'm pretty sure up in penn state that
had done had removed like three or four
of them or some [__]
at like
i forget seven or eight years in and i
was over that but
you know so the max that i could find
that had been the length of time that i
could find that had been removed
was like seven or eight years
so meanwhile i'm doing all this hard
[__] in between trying to figure this
out well finally my my wife was like why
don't you just call
the university of utah and just ask the
radiology department i was like those
pictures they don't it's like i can't
find anything from them in the jstor
like what do they know you know
so she calls
and she's like hey they said that you
can come up for a consultation on
wednesday and that they do this all the
time they can get it out i was like
okay
so we go up there
and meanwhile i'm still waiting on all
my heart prognosis stuff right
and we go up there and meet with the the
radiologist and he's like yeah come in
on friday we'll take it out
i was like
why is it a radiologist uh because the
way the procedure works is they have to
keep you awake and they put some [__] in
your
uh in your blood so they can track it
yeah
so he he's like coming on friday and
meanwhile my primary care physician told
me he's like man you know if you try to
get this removed your vena cava could
rupture and you know like you there's no
way to plug that and so i'm not like
stressed out
damn bro you can give me like a week to
think
so it ended up getting pushed off until
the next friday
but i went in and they got that sucker
out it was
like i guess the way the way this guy
had done it was
so that the top of that deal there's
like a little loop
and i mean that's how it was designed to
be able to be removed
if so they push this thing onto it and
try to squish it together like this
because it looks almost like an umbrella
without a skirt on it
so they would push a deal over it to
kind of squish the umbrella together and
if that doesn't work then there's a loop
on top of the filter and they would try
to hook a thing on it and pull it out
with that
but if that thing the reason that people
weren't able to get them out is if that
thing straightened out now you just have
like a sharp thing in there and like how
to get it out so what this guy had done
he must have grew up like blue car or
something because he was like i'll just
put a damn alligator clamp on there and
just shove that [__] down so that's
what he did he invented like this tool
anyway he got that out which was great
uh
i mean it was like my arm was stuck like
this for a couple days because they go
down your jugular to rip it out
um
so that was good i just wanted to like
update it was good that thing's out of
there and i don't have to worry about
dying because they
my freaking doctor when i went in he's
like
he's like eventually that you know that
ibc filter will just plug up
i was like well how long yeah what's
that doesn't sound cool yeah he's like
10 15 more years probably maybe 30 i'm
like bro i'm freaking 31 years old
like
i was like 20
yeah i'm probably 30 at the time
um so anyway they got that out which was
great and then we pushed on on the heart
stuff and turned out
that my heart was actually okay
they one of the scans so they did an
echo and then whatever that other one is
where they
uh put you through a ct and they look at
some [__] i forget but anyway they give
you like a
calcium score on your arteries and all
this
and i had a calcium score of zero
so i told my wife i was like i got
goddamn baby arteries like i want to
hear no more [__] about all my steaks is
that because you had a filter in there
for so long or why is that i don't know
i don't really care i just i don't like
i don't want to hear any more [__] about
bacon and eggs and fatty steaks
it's good bring up the rib eyes that's
right
so it turns it actually it turned out i
just had a scar on my heart from getting
hit in the plates with the explosion oh
damn
so
it's my heart what did your plates look
like after the do you know yeah i could
see oh i got them
yeah i'll show you pictures are they
jacked up not really the
so i might the plates i had had a steel
backer on them as like i think they were
i can't remember what level they were at
the time um
my my uncle's uh did you have side sappy
plates in no jack no i took everything
on the front
um
yeah my uncle was like a i can't if he's
a major like colonel in the air force
like a
wreck investigator or something
and he had just rotated out and he had
bought these fancy ass plates so we just
mailed them to me
cause i took
my camera if it's five or six in the
plate
and the craziest part is that's game
over man oh
two of them are like right here i mean
right by the heart maybe toast
like you're almost dead before you hit
the ground
yeah
yeah the craziest part about those
plates is i didn't realize this until
one of my engineer buddies came over the
other day and he was like checking them
out put them on my counter and it's like
warped
like wobbles
so it was my guy hit hard enough to like
tweak it
what was the range that you got hit from
probably 15 meters-ish
and luckily you know i have my head down
like this
i guess like this
so probably my k-pop took a lot of that
concussion
oh yeah instead of taking it all right
here
oh man
um
does that get us up to present day yeah
man everything's good now i got four
kids and life is [__] great
freaking out standing man outstanding uh
if people want to find you um you got
brac braxtonmccoy.com
yeah that's like a central location for
you on instagram you're at braxton mccoy
braxton dot mccoy oh sorry all right
braxton mccoy that's
b-r-x-t-o-n b-r-a-x
all right cool
uh b-r-a-x freaking people getting super
sensitive about this
b-r-a-x t-o-n dot mccoy and on twitter
your braxton underscore
mccoy
if people want to follow you or uh find
you you can find in any of those places
and you're doing you're still are you
still speaking to companies or speaking
people or not really the coronavirus
kind of killed it for me check check
um echo charles yeah you got any
questions over there yeah remember we
were talking about your it bin yeah so
where are we at with that i mean does it
get
like jammed up or what because that's
kind of a big deal right yeah i split
down this down the middle kind of yeah
every morning i
i heat up a bath as hot as i can
tolerate it every morning yeah and i i
mean like if i'm at a
hunting or training i can't but other
otherwise every morning hard as i get it
and sit in there for 20 minutes and
just try to stretch it with my hands and
then i get out and stretch as much as i
can and then i roll it and just hope for
the best yeah does it like
like after a bout of like physical
activity does it like act up like right
after or whatever especially hunting
especially yeah
my knees get jacked and it starts to dig
with my hips too and my low back starts
to get weird even
just yeah everything gets kind of just
out of place
and then you said you have
ball bearings in you still yeah damn how
many
uh i think it's around eight or so
i have to i got there's a picture on my
instagram i'll look and see that's crazy
and how big are these
they're like
uh the size of a p like a little bigger
than a p yeah that's a good marble
smaller than a marble
slightly bigger than a p
has to say a p
p
like they're literal they're literally
wheel bearings that's what they are
that's crazy that's pretty typical with
ass vests
but they could put like he was saying
earlier like they could put like nails
and just random like
bolts nuts just any metal crap that'll
freaking rip you apart that's crazy man
good to meet you bro what have you done
with micah uh
no i have never met him we just have a
mutual friend all right i know a guy
that knows him
you guys definitely need a link up
that's what he said yeah he's freaking
awesome
uh any any closing thoughts bro no just
thank you for having me i appreciate it
well
i'm sorry it took so long
and uh thanks for joining us
more important
obviously man thanks for what you did in
ramada you you and the rest of the guys
in the 228
did an incredible job taking the fight
to the enemy and um prepared the
battlefield for us when we got there
and and also made incredible sacrifices
and we will not forget what what you
guys did
and we'll never forget your sacrifice or
the sacrifices of
guys like lieutenant colonel
michael mccoughlin
and sergeant adam can
and so many of the other brave soldiers
and marines
[Music]
who sacrificed their lives for their
brothers and we
will live to honor them
and thank you for helping us
find a way to do that appreciate it
brother thank you sir i appreciate you
and with that
braxton mccoy has left the building a
freaking outstanding guy
and
get the book
the book is is
just it's it's a great book i
look we we scratch the surface on it
there's so much stuff it's i feel like i
feel like i didn't do a good job i
didn't do the book justice and what i
read i don't know because there's a lot
in there man
there's a lot in there
and and
part of it is because you got to kind of
tell the story you know what i mean yeah
you got i mean at least that's what i
feel i feel like you got to kind of know
what's going on
and that kind of leads me to read a
little bit more of the
what's going on stuff as opposed to some
of that internal dialogue and some of
the discovery and stuff like that so
it's just an awesome book order the book
i i feel like i
enjoyed related
maybe in a weird way more than normal
without
maybe it was because of how he was too i
think just the whole thing together i
was like
i felt
not i mean in a way more into it but
more like
you connect like
i connected with it a lot like a lot
more than
than normal i guess given the
circumstances you know you think maybe
it's because he's more your age
but actually he's not more my health i
mean he's 36 yeah i'm like
six eight years old how old are you
forty-four
maroon i know i'm very youthful i know i
know i wasn't thinking youthful immature
yes okay i was thinking all right there
you go um
he the
the part like how he
he's talking about like the alcoholism
and then like his anger at this and
anger that for some reason like the way
he put it was like that's so true like
almost like not that i necessarily felt
all of that but it was like i felt like
i can see how that could be i could
totally see how that could be and this
one part that i think he like nailed was
when he was like something about the
existence of the devil
where
alcohol and drugs are like his tools
yeah bro it's so true strongest bro
that's so true like i'm almost i'm
almost tempted to say freak that is the
devil that's like you know the devil's
like spirit coming down and like
touching people and jamming them up
because it's true where and he was
saying this i don't know if he said it
on
air but he was saying i think it was
before we were recording when he was
like
hey people in school um or people like
teachers and stuff in school people when
you're young they don't tell you that
drugs are like
kind of good like they feel good do you
say that well he didn't say down there
yeah okay
he's like they don't tell you that
they're not they lie yeah and then it
kind of jams you up yeah but it's true
though it's like and obviously different
people like different drugs like you
know i don't have that much drug
experience but the very limited that i
do like no drugs to me felt good at all
not even like painkiller i took that all
that oxy like
not morphine but like you know the ones
they give you for your surgery yeah
after surgery um vicodin like all these
ones i took uh when i got neck surgery
and i was like i'm not taking anything
i'm so tough and then then i got home
and the stuff wore off and i was like
give me whatever they gave you to my
wife as i give it to me now that's real
uh but the weird thing is it didn't feel
like
it didn't i didn't feel any like even he
described like euphoria i didn't feel
any of that i just felt like okay i can
go to sleep now yeah you know because
i'm not in agony yeah like killed so i
didn't i didn't i didn't i don't know if
yeah i felt a little bit like weird and
woo woozy i didn't even feel that i
didn't like it though i didn't really
feel that either but then even like we
like weed and stuff like that it's like
yeah i don't like the feeling or
whatever except for
alcohol
that's the one that's your that's your
that's where the devil gets you yeah and
that's where i experience the devil
scenario because it is it's like oh
especially when you're having fun or
you're bonding with someone and you guys
are both going down memory lane all
hardcore and you just don't want it to
end you're like oh this is the best yeah
this alcohol is helping it it's helping
me you see i'm saying help me feel and
then like the next day that pray i
remember i was drinking with cake nuts
right i'm not gonna tell you when it
doesn't matter when
um something is a very recent scenario
i am working at the monster
like good thing you had that later fight
on saturday
yes sir
extending the good time like way past
like the plan mm-hmm and just you know
and we're just they were doing that
going down memory lane talking trash
having a laugh huge laughs
the best it was the best then the next
morning we're because we're on the same
not on the same flight but same time so
we're all going to the airport together
and like we're sitting there
but why do we even do that like is it
how i feel right now it's like not even
working like even last night was super
good fun but it's not even worth feeling
like this how much percentage of fun
could you have had without alcohol the
night before um uh i don't know like
let's say you had let's say you had 90
fun yeah without alcohol the night
before how much fun would you have had i
don't know eight i don't know i mean
because i'm tempted to say well you're
at 90. probably 90 or 89 or whatever
because
i think i but it could have been maybe
like 25 i think i can truly have like 90
yeah all the fun i understand with or
without yeah i understand but like not
everyone's like that yeah straight up
work just because like especially cake
mess he's kind of a reserved like person
oh so you know to break down that
but when we're together it's cool but
then you could tell because there's
other people like main tai was with us
at some point
they got that just like that huh we
don't even know where main tai was
we don't know when he showed up when he
departed sorry to freaking bust and
throw him under the bus but nonetheless
it was like you know certain things
you're like oh um but the key point is
the next day it wasn't even worth it it
wasn't worth it and we were literally
talking about how it's not worth it so
it's like a deal in the moment it's more
than worth it bro you can i'm thinking
about the flight
it's a complete lie it's a complete lie
but you feel it like to your in your
bones that it's worth it at the time and
the next day you know the reality that's
the devil right there that's how sneaky
it is it's true and so how he put that i
was like bro you're spot on
no he definitely
you know i even that last underground
podcast we did was a guy asked you know
hey you know how you know how much
drinking should i be doing you know i
right i got the friend group they would
they don't really want to drink you know
how you know what's a good way for me to
drink i'm just like i can't even i can't
even give as a matter of fact i saw i
talked to somebody at the at the muster
who was you know who's had
issues and he said when he heard that
question he was like please chuckle
please say say the right thing say the
right thing and i was like you know i
can't even support he's like yes he goes
you can't because it's a freaking lie
yeah it is at the end of the day it's a
lie man let's stay clean out there stay
clean stay clean another thing he said
about the ego which like conceptually
was like a lot of times like you'll say
this but he said this very specific
thing where he said oh the army should
have kept me in even though he knew he
couldn't have dipped it yeah but it's
weird because like you kind of have that
feeling it's almost like under certain
circumstances obviously like you know it
depends on who you are but it's like you
know how
it's almost like a more
advanced version of the the simple idea
of like you know the classic like oh
they didn't invite me to the party even
though i didn't want to go but like i
still should be invited you know kind of
because it's me it's like a weird
illusion and if you really if you really
pull the string on that like you can
blame everything like oh they didn't
keep me in the army that's why i'm
drinking right now yeah
that's why i'm doing this that's why i'm
doing that i'm out here that's why i got
you know that's why i'm in this
relationship with this person like you
can everything is just rooted and
there's one thing because they
wouldn't keep me that's a trap and
luckily he figured that out man yeah
luckily he figured that out
and it's good that other people
hopefully can recognize these things you
know
um
another big point physical yeah the
physical well-being yeah is paramount
you gotta be you gotta man you gotta get
you gotta get up in the morning you
gotta get after it you gotta get up at 4
30 no you got a bit five no but getting
up consistently doing some work
so good for you man so good for you so
yeah a ton of lessons there
instead of drinking vodka yeah i got a
better idea we'll drink the discipline
yeah drink a monk yeah or monks yeah
drink a mold drink some go
drink some maybe even want to drink a
little bit of that
pre-workout discipline go
sarah goes uh my wife says um she was
like you know what you should do you
should make a video and it was this is
like such an old concept all right
seeing videos like this god bless
bless her don't do don't do her like
that right now such she just doesn't
want a good idea she just doesn't want i
like her idea what was it she watched
that much tv like i did sarah but she
said
i got you sir she was like you should do
you should do a video like showing like
how discipline go the energy drink is
like it's an energy drink but it doesn't
have sugar in it and then show this
other energy drink that you can't show
the label of course and then just show
how much sugar is in it and then do the
equipment you know how they use
scoops of sugar yeah and be like this is
how much sugar you're drinking she's
like do a video like that it's like that
would be good i was like don't be funny
so we started the video about like that
but then we started saying it like oh
and here's a scoop of rap poison arsenic
we just started pouring like actually
yeah
yeah good idea see a.d jocko over here
yeah but it all originated with sarah
charles creative genius creative
director and you're over there they
saying
maybe you need some discipline go homie
uh if you want to get some discipline go
you want to get some more go to
jockofield.com hook that up go to the
vitamin shop go to wawa
go to heb down in tejas
yup we got it going on so we're
spreading check that stuff out also
origin usa origin originusa.com forgot
to tell braxton that we got hunt gear
coming he will he will get to hunt in
some american made gear you know he
doesn't want to buy stuff from
china or from overseas 100 he there's
only one kind of hunting gear he is
wanting and that's american-made hunting
gear
so we'll get you some of that origin
usa.com if you want some of that you
need jiu-jitsu gear if you need
a t-shirt if you need a sweatshirt if
you need a pair of boots jeans jeans
two pair on the way i should i should
have talked to braxton about that as
well because you know he wants to wear
american-made everything yeah
yeah i do
originusa.com jacquardstore.com what we
got there we've got some
a lot of uh how should i say
the various things but mainly it's
apparel sparrow
you want to represent on this path
apparel discipline equals freedom yeah
good
we're restocking some stuff we're going
hard oh wait so we ran out of stock
from i said you just put yourself on
report
[Music]
it's a life i like hey look it was
pretty cool to see at the muster people
representing with the shirt locker
shirts yeah you can see that those are
seems like they're kind of hit it's
trying to represent you like to say
landing their landing people
people are kind of stoked
because that's just
that's just like full representation
yeah like yeah i'm in the game over here
alongside what about you
it's funny too because people will like
come to me and ask me like hey where did
that guy get that shirt
she's got a shirt knocker all day all
day but yeah that's how like that's what
somebody's gonna buy one old shirt from
the shirt locker if desired yeah so
basically it goes like this joined shirt
locker
membership subscription 34 a month yes
you get a new shirt every month and
if you want if you want you have
access exclusive access
to like yeah all the all the other stuff
because it's like a private store you
can buy anyone anyone from see that's
that's what's called
observing the feedback loop the feedback
loop was some people wanted some of
those uh other shirts that were had come
out yeah they so they thought they
missed it so it's like oh i missed that
one shirt and that's kind of you know
the one and then maybe two three months
later they're like oh i missed that one
again you see what i'm saying so it's
like they they felt like apparently that
was almost like a like a gamble you know
but it's not a gamble there's no gamble
it's a win it's a win-win uh check that
out subscribe to the podcast subscribe
to jocko underground taco
underground.com that's where we're we're
answering a bunch of questions we're
talking about topics we're getting deep
into uh
aspects that we might not hate here but
that are very integral to living
and crushing and doing well so jocko
underground.com it's also where we are
because in case we get kicked off of
this platform or some other platform
uh
we got our own platform
jackondeground.com if you want to join
if you want to help out on that eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford it look
okay we want you in the game
email assistants at jocko
underground.com check out the youtube
channel check out psychological warfare
check out flipside canvas with dakota
meyer making cool stuff to hang on your
wall
that's a good idea books you can get a
bunch of books i wrote a bunch of them
also
braxton
wrote one it's called the glass factory
when i'm saying this right now whenever
you're listening this there's only 300
hardcovers left at
ain't going to last braxtonmccoy.com
if they are get one
that's a first a dish that you ain't you
know you ain't coming by again if they
don't have that cool get it from amazon
um you'll get a one that's printed on
demand which is still awesome because
it's a great book so many lessons
learned only cry for the living check
out holly mckay's book she's been on
here before
wrote a fantastic book she risked her
freaking life to write so go check that
one out and then i written a bunch of
books you know what they are
let's get the get we'll get the kids
books i just realized i didn't give
braxton a copy of mikey the dragons i'll
have to send it to him braxton hit me up
um
so i've written a book a bunch of books
checked them out echelon front
leadership consultancy just just
finished the muster as we were just
talking about uh next one is atlanta
hotlanta october 12th through the 14th
we're gonna sell out
cove it's over now officially a fish
officially over
because people do not care
and
uh
we're back to the pre-coveted numbers at
muster
so it's gonna sell out
there you go battlefield we're doing ef
battlefield a little bighorn it's almost
sold out
i think there's literally two more seats
probably not by the time you listen to
this but if you want to go to
littlebighorn with us uh check that out
all that stuff salonfront.com also we
have the academy extremeownership.com
we're teaching this stuff all the time
just did a live event today interacting
with everybody that's on there
if you have questions on how to handle a
situation just go on there and you can
ask me and we can interact you can give
me the details the deets have you heard
this expression yeah from you it's lame
isn't it
i like it good keep it
uh if you want to help out service
members active and retired their
families mark lee's mom mama lee she has
an awesome charity organization what she
does is she helps people helps veterans
that need medical help that the
government's not paying for
so if you help her she will help
veterans that need it
america's mightywarriors.org
also we talked a couple times about
micah today his organization heroes and
horses.org it's the first time i've
gotten that thing right
so it's dot-org
he's taken vets up into the wilderness
for 41 days 41 days i think so 41 days
on a horseback
dude
freaking awesome
and uh
once again
braxton
what a what a what a stud what a hero
what an awesome guy you can follow him
he's on the web if you want to talk to
him
braxtonmccoy.com
his instagram is braxton.mccoy
his twitter is
braxton underscore mccoy hit him up
of course on the twitter on the gram on
the facebook
echo's attica charles i'm at chocolate
listen you go on there cool i don't mind
you going i don't want you checking in
don't don't dwell
don't hang out there don't move in there
don't say oh i'm going to look at this
other thing and this other thing and
this other thing and just like that
little dopamine grabs you by the by the
freaking throat and pulls you in there
don't do it
otherwise like at my house right now
just had a couple people i had a couple
of people from the underground mm-hmm
dope i mean dope
so for those of you who don't know that
don't have the jocko underground.com
at my house right now if you pull out
your phone
with my family
people just start going dopamine
dopamine dopamine dopamine so
it's real yeah it's real it's a real
thing it's
it's it's what we're doing it's keeping
people in check i'm putting my phone
back away because it's annoying
right so don't let that happen
but you can find us there just watch out
for the algorithm special thanks to all
the military personal personnel out
there especially our wounded warriors
who continue to fight long after the war
is over we salute you and thank you for
everything you have done and everything
you continue to do
for our country and our way of life
thank you
to the wounded vets and also to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all the first responders out there you
also sacrifice every day to protect our
way of life here at home
and we thank you for that
and to everybody else
remember these lessons learned
from braxton
they're they're they're so important and
look they're so hard-earned
from braxton for what he went through to
figure these things out and then to pass
them on to us the lessons do not lie to
yourself
that will be the main source of your
suffering we often create the vast
majority of our own problems
and listen i get it
i get that you can't control everything
no one can control everything
but take ownership of what you can
control and it's usually a lot more than
you think
and then sharpen your sword
sharpen your sword
and by that i mean your body your mind
your spirit
and then go out there into the world
[Music]
and slay those dragons
and until next time
zekko and jocko
out